Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Warst du auf Reisen?
Ja, ich war einmal wieder in Köln.
Was hast du denn in Köln gemacht?
Ich habe mir Turandot angesehen in der Oper. Das war keine besonders gelungene Inszenierung. Problematisch in Köln ist ja auch nach wie vor, dass die Oper seit 100 Jahren renoviert wird und noch immer nicht fertig ist. Also ist man in so einer Ausweispielstätte, die akustisch hochproblematisch ist. Also es ist ein Elend und auch eine Schande für die Stadt Köln überhaupt, dass das so ist. Aber viel interessanter war, als ich hinfuhr, hörte ich den Welt-Spiegel-Podcast. Und da war Janina Kugel zu Gast, die jetzt gerade mit zum Beispiel auch der UN eine Studie herausgebracht hat zum Thema Personalmangel. Und wir hören da jetzt gleich mal rein. Ich habe ihn jedenfalls dann schon gleich am eigenen Leibe gespürt, als ich im Hotel war und fragte, wann, wie lange denn die Bar geöffnet habe. Und da sagte man mir gar nicht, die ist jetzt komplett geschlossen wegen Personalmangel. Ich erinnere mich, ich war im August in diesem Hotel und sprach mit der Barkeeperin, lobte sie für den Cocktail, sagte zu ihr dann bis zum nächsten Mal und sie meinte, nein, nein, sie verlässt jetzt das Hotel, geht woanders hin und es ist noch keine Nachfolge gefunden. Man sucht schon lange. Und jetzt haben wir Ende Oktober und noch immer keine Nachfolge. Und das ist doch sehr, sehr eigenartig, weil ich mich jetzt schon frage. Also klar, auf die gesamte Volkswirtschaft gesehen, fehlen Leute. Aber es gibt ja zugleich nicht extreme Lohnanstiege. Also man kann ja jetzt, wenn ich das jetzt betriebswirtschaftlich sehe, sagen, mit Geld kann man Leute locken. Also ab einem gewissen Betrag fängst auch du an, Cocktails zu rühren beim Steigenberger oder so. Ja, und das ist die große Frage, dass sich diese von manchen Keynesianern, die ja immer dann doch gerade heraufbeschworene Lohnpreisspirale offenbar gar nicht abzeichnet. Also ich sehe nicht, dass mit hohen Löhnen gelockt wird, sondern dann sagt man lieber, da schließen wir früher. Oder mir zählt jetzt ein Freund aus Berlin, der ging immer zum Mittagstisch zu verschiedenen Restaurants, ist nicht mehr möglich. Die öffnen erst ab 17 Uhr.
Würdest du sagen, es ist eine Performance?
Es ist eine Megaperformance. Eine der besten. Wir kennen alle diesen alten Spruch von Verding gemacht zum 11. September.
Der ein bisschen Ärger besorgt hat.
Richtig. In diesem Fall haben die Aktivisten daraus gelernt, es ist niemand zu Schaden gekommen. Und dadurch kann man auch als Zuschauer, der gar nicht weder am Ort noch zur Zeit dabei war, sondern nur die mediale Rezeption, die ja für sich dazu gehört, komplett eingepreist, also mein Urteil, sagen, das ist eine Megaperformance. Und ich habe mich jetzt die Monate oft gefragt, wenn ich mir irgendwelche Bilder anschaue, warum schaue ich mir die eigentlich an? Was ist das Besondere? Weil das hier jemand kuratiert hat, den ich nicht kenne, dann hat man die Dokumente komplett überladen mit diesen Kurationsentscheidungen. Wir haben es ja thematisieren, den ganzen Antisemitismusvorwürfen und so weiter. Alles ganz wichtige Diskussionen. Und in dem Falle muss ich jetzt einfach sagen, und ich war kürzlich bei meinem Kumpel Olli hier in so einer ganz kleinen Ausstellung, ganz privater Rahmen, 10 Bilder hängen an der Wand. Und die Kunstaktion sieht so aus. Sie gehen auf Flohmärkte und kaufen dort Landschaftsbilder. Landschaftsbilder, die sie einfach für 10 Euro schön gerahmt und so weiter kaufen. Wir kennen die alle, die so in Gästewohnungen und so weiter rumhängen. Irgendwer hat ja so fast Bob-Rosse-artig halt ein paar Bäume, Licht und so weiter gemalt. Die Bilder zeigen aber quasi nur Kulisse. So, und die haben diese Bilder aufgekauft. Und wir wissen, Kaufverträge auf dem Flohmarkt sehen so aus. Hier hast du einen Zehner. Das Bild ist jetzt deins, was auch bedeutet, du darfst mit dem Bild machen, was du willst. Wir sind hier nicht irgendwie im Freeport, wo man nochmal zehn Seiten dazuschreibt. Das darf aber nicht beschädigt werden. Der Rahmen ist dieser. Da darf man nichts verändern und so weiter. Und die haben dann diese Kulissenlandschaftsbilder genommen, von denen wir nicht wissen, wo kommen die eigentlich her und so weiter, und haben eine Szene draufgeklebt, einfach ergänzt. Und zwar künstlerisch genau im gegenteiligen Metier sich bedient. Sie haben zum Beispiel Comics ausgeschnitten, die Figuren oder Disney-Charaktere, wie sie sich am Ende nochmal das Happy Ending, Heiratsanträge machen, aber in dem Falle jetzt eben vor Kulisse. Sie haben also die alten Bilder genommen und sie haben sie einfach benutzt. Sie haben sie nicht nur ausgestellt, sondern sie haben sie nochmal mashup-mäßig veredelt. Und ich finde, so sind auch die Klimaaktivisten hier vorgegangen. Sie haben sich die Sonnenblumen genommen, die nun mal nur ein Abbild der Natur sind. Van Gogh hat einfach die Natur gemalt. Genau, sie sind gemalt, sie sind ein Abbild. Van Gogh hat sich hingesetzt und hat gesagt, Natur ist so schön, aber leider habe ich sie nicht zu Hause. Also male ich mir ein Bild davon und stelle das dem Konkurrenz ins Gästezimmer. Und dieses Signal, wir domestizieren hier uns auf unsere Weise, also wir kulturalisieren Natur. Wir machen aus Naturkultur, dieses Signal zu nehmen und zu sagen, ja, dann machen wir das genauso mit der Klimakrise. Wir packen die ganze große Klimakrise in unser kleines Projekt und machen auch nur ein Signal.
Und kommen wir da nicht genau an das Problem, dass wir sagen können, es ist eine gelungene Performance. Man könnte auch über die Bilder von Arnulf Reiner sprechen, der übermalt hat, also der Bilder malte und sie dann übermalte. Und das war das Bild. Wir haben verschiedene Formen der Übermalung, der Appropriation. Wir haben Performances, die den musealen Raum in Frage stellen. Diesen White Cube, diese Frage, wer wird eigentlich da repräsentiert. Das ist ja etwas, was wir seit Beginn der Avantgarde haben. Auch die Frage, was ist Kunst? Da haben wir einen Duchamp, der dort einen Flaschenhalter aufstellt und sagt, das ist Kunst, ich signiere euch das auch noch. Wir haben es mit Institutionenkritik dann seit den 60er- 70er-Jahren zu tun, wo dann wirklich diese Voyeurismus-Position befragt wird. Auch das, was wir rahmen, was ist eigentlich dann immer außerhalb des Rahmens. All diese Dinge werden natürlich hier wieder aufgerufen. Und wir können das in diesen gepflegten Kunstdiskurs einordnen und können da unsere Theorien ableiten oder weiterspinnen. Sind aber damit in der Sphäre des Spiels, wo die Kunst ja ist, also diese Art der Domestizierung in der Kunst, ist alles erlaubt. Da kann selbst Jonathan Mese den Hitler-Cruz machen, weil es in den Rahmen der Kunst ist, ist es nicht in irgendeiner Weise etwas, was justiziabel ist. Und das bedeutet aber, wenn es in der Sphäre der Kunst ist, kann es dann nicht damit dazu führen, dass wir eigentlich einen Aktivismus sehen, der auf der Zeichenebene bleibt und nicht etwas bewirkt im Sinne von, er verändert das politische Handeln oder individuelle Handeln im Hinblick auf den Klimawandel. Beziehungsweise könnte man sogar so weit gehen, leitet es nicht sogar thematisch weg davon, indem wir jetzt darüber reden, anrufreiner über malungen und dergleichen statt über den klimawandel zu sprechen.
Ja, das finde ich gar nicht. Denn in diesem ganzen Projekt und ich bleibe dabei, das ist eine tolle Kunstaktion, steckt eben drinnen auch die Kommunikation der eigenen Ohnmacht. Sie gehen eben nicht in die Parlamente und heben dort die Hand. Und überstimmen sozusagen die anwesenden Politiker, weil das geht ja gar nicht. Die Zugangsregeln fürs Parlament sind ja ganz andere. Sie sind ja ausgeschlossen. Ich habe es ja im Buch beschrieben. 3% der weltweiten Parlamentarier sind unter 30. Aber die Hälfte der Weltbevölkerung ist unter 30. So und das lässt sich halt, also da findet keine Repräsentanz statt. Wir haben in Amerika gerade die Taylor Lawrence hat da ganz wunderbar in der Washington Post drüber geschrieben, ein Podcast der Otherworld heißt, der sich mit dieser Para-Wissenschaft und so weiter behandelt, Geisterjagd und so was. Wir fragen uns, warum denn? Und die Antwort ist, naja, weil die ganzen Millennials so wenig zutrauen, also das ist die Erklärung von Taylor Lawrence, wir haben einen Gemütszustand der jüngeren, sagen wir mal, der Millennials unter 40-Jährigen, der so weit weg ist von Demokratie ist gut für mich, die Institutionen helfen mir, Vaterstaat hebt mich auf und so und unterstützt mich, dass man das mittlerweile auch in dieser Art der Medienrezeption ganz allgemein findet. Diese Leute befassen sich nicht mal mit der Politik, wie sie im Fernsehen dargelegt wird, weil sie da nicht mal als Zuschauer und Konsument, als Wähler noch ernst genommen werden.
Aber wie die Medien funktionieren, das wissen sie. Also es ist ja, jetzt muss man es dazu sagen, gerade bei dieser Londoner Aktion, ein größeres Think Tank auch dahinter, also man hat heute weniger, nur einfach so auftretende Aktivisten, die dann vielleicht noch, wenn es hart auf hart kommt, irgendeinen Anwalt finden, also so wie wir das in den 70er Jahren hatten, dass dann irgendeinen Schili, Maler oder Ströbele dort mal verteidigen müssen. Also das ist eine andere Konstellation. Heute haben wir es eher mit Think Tanks zu tun, die zum Teil gut mit Geld ausgestattet sind, hier ja auch von einer Getty-Erbin, aber es gibt jetzt nicht die Verschwörungstheorie, die man spinnen muss, sondern man muss einfach sagen, da sind Gelder und natürlich unterstützen die verschiedene Protestaktionen auch und bekommen die Aktivisten so auch, naja, einen gewissen, einen doppelten Boden oder ein Netz aufgespannt sollte irgendwas passieren. Also es ist ja hochprofessionalisiert und wir haben es dann mit einem medialen Zirkus zu tun, der dann in Gang gesetzt wird, den kann man dann in abgeschwächter Form noch mal wiederholen. Also man kann das dann noch mal für jedes Land machen, also wie jetzt in Potsdam geschehen, aber dann läuft sich das tot. Also man kann jetzt nicht jede Woche irgendwo in einem Museum was machen und hoffen, dass noch irgendjemand darüber berichtet. Dann ist selbst die kleinste Lokalzeitung wird sagen, warum sollen wir das nochmal machen jetzt?
Also den Kartoffelbrei in Potsdam blende ich schon aus, mir geht es nur um diese van Gogh-Aktion. Es gehört dazu, dass die jungen Leute, Extinction, Rebellien oder letzte Generation, dass die einfach sagen, ja wir machen hier justiziable Dinge, wir verstecken uns aber nicht, wir lassen uns von der Polizei mitnehmen und wir lassen auch Anklage erheben, aber wenn wir vor Gericht stehen, sagen wir einfach nur, wir gestehen. Wir erkennen das ganze Theater, Legitimation durch Verfahren, eines Urteils gegen uns gar nicht an, wir sagen einfach, wir gestehen. Ihr müsst euer Theater hier nicht vorführen, wir gestehen einfach. Und das finde ich auch eine wahnsinnig kluge Sache, so heranzugehen, weil man dann eben auch im Vorfeld sagt, wir gehen ins Museum, ja vielleicht haben wir noch das Ticket gekauft, alles andere, was wir gemacht haben, ist illegal, aber es ist eben auch folgenlos. Und in deren Sicht geben wir uns gerne in eure Mühlen der Verfahren und sagen, wir gestehen, wir waren es, wir wollten ja, dass es sichtbar ist. Was sollen wir das jetzt bestreiten?
Aber warum überhaupt Museen, also ich finde es wirklich interessant, dass man es mit Museen zu tun hat, die sonst ja von jungen Leuten so gut wie nicht mehr frequentiert werden. Also das finde ich interessant, dass die Hochkultur hier noch einmal als Referenz sind, wo sie sonst vollkommen marginalisiert ist. Also ein Bezug auf Hochkultur ist eigentlich nicht mehr vertreten. Man sieht es auch jetzt so in Serien oder so, wenn da ein paar ältere Figuren mal irgendwas empfehlen, jüngeren Leuten und sie kennen in der Regel dann diese Empfehlung nicht mehr. Das heißt, wir haben es eigentlich mit einer geschichtslosen Zeit eigentlich heute zu tun. Ich meine das jetzt nicht nur bezogen auf die jungen Leute, sondern generell wird die Hochkultur extrem marginalisiert. Und in dieser schwachen Position spielt sie jetzt noch mal eine Rolle, indem sie da attackiert wird und man könnte ja auch von van Gogh, also würde man jetzt biografisch vorgehen, sagen, es ist so mit die schwächste Künstlerposition, so ein schwaches Künstler-Subjekt wie van Gogh, der litt an der Welt wie kaum ein anderer Künstler, dass man sich ausgerechnet den aussucht für eine Attacke, also was ja dann auch mitunter so gelesen wurde als ein Angriff auf. Van Gogh, was ich nicht tun würde.
Also ich habe, du hörst mich knistern. Ja, ich profitiere jetzt von meinem Zeitabonnement. Elisabeth Räther hat auf Seite 3 gleich, man hat ja diesen Platz völlig zurecht zugestanden. Der Text ist geformt wie die Tomatensoße, das Bild runterfloss. Also auch dieser Text verdeckt hier gerade die Sonnenblumen, abgedruckt. Also man geht auch hier mit dem Gemälde etwas entsprechend um. Und sie hat noch mal darauf hingewiesen und dann fiel es mir auch wie Schuppen von den Augen. Und du stellst genau die richtige Frage, warum die Kunst? Das ist doch nun wirklich und so weiter. So eine Domäne für sich und so.
Man könnte ja auch zu Rock am Ring gehen oder irgendeinem Spektakel.
Genau, wollen wir nicht eigentlich die Kunst entpolitisiert haben, haben wir nicht das als größten Kritikpunkt von Brock mit übernommen, dass die Dokumenta völlig politikverseucht ist und so weiter. Und wir haben hier von ihr eine Frage aufgeworfen, warum gibt es so einen gigantischen Anspruch der Gesellschaft auf die Unversehrtheit ihrer künstlichen Artefakte? Und genau das wurde ja angegriffen. Es wurde ja nicht van Gogh angegriffen, sondern van Gogh ist ja wirklich nur eine Schifre. Aber man hat eben gesagt, ihr baut extra Museen und stellt da so Wärmefühle rein und achtet auf das Licht und die Temperatur und so weiter, weil ihr eure Kunstwerke unversehrt haben wollt. Und genau diese Unversehrtheitsansprüche, die ihr da formuliert, die greifen wir jetzt an, indem wir Tomatensuppe drauf werfen. So und genau diesen Unversehrtheitsanspruch haben ja die jungen Aktivisten nicht der Kultur gegenüber, sondern der Natur gegenüber. Und damit findet so eine Doppelung statt. Also eine Transferleistung wird da abverlangt in der Beobachtung dieser Aktion, die ich wirklich atemberaubend klug finde. Weil man hier denjenigen, die sich diese Reichtümer an ihre Museen stellen, auf Kosten der Natur einfach den Spiegel vorhält und sagt, also da habt ihr Unverletzbarkeitsansprüche im Museum und dann geht ihr aber vor die Tür und sagt, cool, jetzt habe ich mir die ganze Kunst angeguckt, zum Glück kümmert sich jemand drüber, darum, dass sie auch in 500 Jahren noch so toll aussieht. Jetzt steige ich in mein SUV und fahre erst mal nach Hause und haue erst mal eine Tonne CO2 in die Natur. Und genau das einmal nicht ganz deutlich zu sagen, sondern nur anzudeuten, damit etwas klügere Kommentierungen, wie zum Beispiel hier in der Zeit, genau darauf den Fokus legen. Finde ich genau richtig. Also das macht auch diese Kunstaktion zu so einer tollen Kunstaktion, weil sie, und das ist eigentlich das Besondere, den van Gogh noch mal aus dem Museum rausholte. Sie haben eigentlich van Gogh noch mal befreit, bestärkt.
Das ist ja das große Problem, sobald was musealisiert ist, ist natürlich auch die Kunst dann gezähmt dadurch, aber wir haben es eben ja bei diesem Einspieler schon gehört von dieser britischen Aktivistin. Ist es nicht ein ganz eigenartiges Gegeneinander ausspielen, das da stattfindet? Also man kann mit dieser Argumentation bleibend generell hier alles abblasen. Also wir können sofort mit Blick auf den Hunger im Jemen, mit Blick auf den Klimawandel sagen, das war es ab sofort kein Podcast mehr, am Samstag auch nicht in die Oper. Es hat keinen Zweck. Also es geht nicht. Also diese Argumentation würde in einen absoluten Totalitarismus führen, der wirklich nicht mehr anerkennt, dass es noch auch andere Werte gibt, wie denn zum Beispiel eine Unversehrtheit von Kunst, was mit Kunstfreiheit und all dem einhergeht. Wenn wir das so zuspitzen, können wir fast nichts mehr machen. Dann müssen bzw. müssen wir uns nur noch den großen basalen Menschenheitsaufgaben stellen und dann ist jede Ablenkung davon. Und das beginnt mit dem Hören eines Podcasts und geht über zum Museumbesuch bis hin zum Restaurantbesuch, was auch immer. Es muss alles eigentlich geächtet werden.
Genau, ganz genau. Und genau deswegen finde ich ja diese Aktion so toll, wenn man sie singulär betrachtet. Also wenn man wirklich nur London, die National Art Gallery, weil diese Gemälde, die dort hängen, gehören dem ganzen Volk. Dort hat man nicht einem Eigentümer des Van Goghs-Bilds oder so geschadet, sondern das gehört einfach allen und es ist auch unversichert.
Da muss man ja übrigens noch nicht mal Eintritt zahlen.
Und man muss keinen Eintritt zahlen. Man geht einfach hin. Und wir haben ja eben diesen Widerspruch zwischen Rigorosität und Pragmatismus. Jeder bei Verstand stimmt dir zu. Wir brauchen auch diesen Pragmatismus, weil ansonsten verfangen wir uns in so einer Rigorosität. Und dann ist also wirklich jede Lebensqualität verloren. Aber zur Kunst gehört es eben auch zu sagen, für diesen kleinen Moment, für diese fünf Stunden, zwischen wir öffnen die Dose Tomatensoße und das Bild hängt blank geputzt wieder an der Wand und es ist als wäre nichts geschehen. Das waren fünf Stunden. Für diese Zeit nehmen wir mal die Rigorosität und lassen den Pragmatismus mal links liegen. Die Zeit heilt alle Wunden. Nach fünf Stunden ist der Pragmatismus zurück. Das Museum ist wieder offen. Alle fahren mit ihren Autos dahin und so weiter und so fort. Aber für diesen kurzen Moment, deswegen, ich finde, das kann man auch nicht wiederholen. Diese aktuelle Aktion gehört dann nicht in diese Reihe.
Und deswegen ist auch die Frage der Wirksamkeit eine sehr schwierige. Also wirksam ist natürlich jetzt, dass wir einen Diskurs darüber führen, aber im Sinne von was verändert es für das Klima? Diese Frage ist im Prinzip nicht zu beantworten und deshalb auch quasi nicht zu stellen. Man kann nur sagen, dass es in der Einmaligkeit interessant ist. Es gibt ja dieses Beispiel auch, das war meines Wissens während des Vietnamkriegs, dass es den Theatermacher Peter Brook gab, der bei einer Theatervorstellung einen Schmetterling anzündete. Der verrannte dort. Und das hat natürlich für wahnsinnig aufsehen gesorgt. Die Leute waren empört, das bürgerliche Publikum war außer sich. Also hier hat jemand Natur zerstört, also ein Tier zerstört. Und hat aber gesagt, ja, aber was denn mit Vietnam? Riecht euch nicht auf so. Und das kann man natürlich jetzt nicht immer sagen, gut, lieber alle Tiere abschlachten als einen Menschen oder was auch immer. Aber darum ging es natürlich nicht. Also es ging in dieser rigorosen Haltung natürlich nur dafür, dass in diesem Rahmen plötzlich Leuten der Diskurs an sich klar wird, beziehungsweise eben schwindlig wird, in welchen Fügungen man eigentlich so drin hängt, ja auch geistig. Und dann ist das eigentlich die Parallelaktion zu dem, was Peter Brook gemacht hat. Das, was wir jetzt da bei van Gogh sehen.
Genau und es ist eben wichtig, hier über van Gogh und nichts anderes, nicht Monet oder so zu reden. Es gibt noch eine Pointe, die ich wirklich wahnsinnig finde. 14. Juli 2022. Ich lese mal aus der Rheinischen Post, es könnte aber jede andere Publikation sein. Überschrift Unbekanntes Selbstportrait von van Gogh in Schottland entdeckt. Text. Hinter einem Gemälde von Vincent van Gogh ist in Schottland ein bislang unbekanntes Selbstportrait des bekannten Künstlers entdeckt worden. Wie es aussieht und wie besonders diese Entwicklung ist, das ist der Teaser für den Text, und beschrieben wird hier, wie van Gogh damals malend aus Ressourcenknappheit seine eigenen Bilder übermalt hat. Und nicht nur das, er hat seine eigenen Selbstportraits übermalt. Dieser Umgang des Künstlers mit sich und seinen Werken ist ja auch noch mal einzubeweisen, in diese Aktion sich einen van Gogh rauszusuchen. Und so sagen, aufgrund von Ressourcenknappheit im anderen Metier, aber diese Transferleistungen verlangen wir jetzt mal von allen, die das hier beobachten, nehmen wir jetzt mal einen van Gogh und sagen, wir malen mal drüber. Wir wissen, es ist ja nur temporär. So wie auch dieses Gemälde, nur temporär. Die Welt muss sich jetzt entscheiden. Will sie lieber das Selbstportrait von van Gogh oder das Original-Gemälde haben? Es ist eben beides in einem Bild. Dann kann man halt restauratorisch das eine abkratzen und damit das bisher unbekannte van Gogh-Portrait freilegen. Aber man hat eben auch ein van Gogh zerstört in diesem Moment. Vielleicht wussten die das gar nicht. Aber dass van Gogh sich selber, also so einen Umgang mit sich selber hier hatte, und wir jetzt noch mal so einen Umgang mit einem van Gogh sehen, finde ich einfach ganz herausragend. Also diese Aktion in London war einfach ein richtiger Knaller. Das muss man einfach sagen. Ich bin da ganz begeistert.
Und wir hören uns dann noch mal das Lied über Vincent van Gogh. Kennst du das? Das ist sehr schön. Aber ich empfehle da doch nicht die Originalversion, sondern die von Julio Iglesias. And when no hope was left in sight on that starry starry night, you took your life as lovers often do. But I could have told you, Vincent, this world was never meant for one as beautiful as you. Also was diese Fragilität sehr schön vorbricht.
Also wir wissen, wie die Biografie endet von van Gogh. Und das sollten wir vielleicht auch noch mal mit in die Diskussion holen, wenn wir hier über solche Klima-Sachen reden.
Diese, diese Aktion, aber da sind wir wirklich im Bereich des Kunstdiskurses, der aber ja eigentlich gut ist, wenn er ein gesellschaftlicher wird. Und wenn jeder, der sich jetzt so maßlos darüber aufgeregt hat, schlimm, was die da machen, daraufhin sagt, ich gehe jetzt alle zwei Monate mal ins Museum, dann wäre ja wahnsinnig viel gewonnen. Ich glaube, dass da viele auch selbst lange nicht mehr drin waren. Aber wir wollen mal bei diesen Protesten bleiben und verlassen aber jetzt die Kunst. Hören wir mal kurz einen Beitrag aus Nano.
Angesichts der Dramatik einer drohenden Umwelt- und Klimakatastrophe formt sich auch international Protest in der Wissenschaft unter dem Namen Scientist Rebellion. Sie berufen sich auf die Pflicht zum zivilen Ungehorsam. Zu ihnen gehört Nana Maria Gröning, Molekularbiologin an der Berliner Charité, die hier gerade von der Polizei abgeführt wird.
Ziviler Ungehorsam bzw. ziviler Widerstand wird oft als radikal bezeichnet. Ich würde es als vernünftig bezeichnen. Radikal sind die, die unsere Lebensgrundlagen nicht wertschätzen und retten. Es braucht diese Art von Widerstand und Protest, damit das Thema niemals von der Agenda verschwinden kann.
Scientist Rebellion hatten sich auch in diesem Monat in einem Showroom mit Porsche-Luxus-Schlitten am Boden festgeklebt. Dann gab es ja eine Aktion, ich glaube, das war Extinction Rebellion oder letzte Generation, am Finanzministerium, dass man dort den Schuldenschnitt einfordern wollte für den globalen Süden. Linda hatte da mal irgendwelche Zusagen gemacht, an die hat er sich nicht gehalten. Wir konnten jetzt viele, viele weitere solcher Aktionen auflisten. Was wir also generell feststellen können, ist, ja, es gibt noch Fridays for Future, und die hatten ja ihre Demo im September, aber da haben wir ja selbst gesagt, es hat nicht mehr so gezogen. Es war auch medial nicht mehr dieser Effekt da. Es ist dann nur noch die kurze Meldung der Tagesschau. Jetzt aber erleben wir solche Aktionen von Wissenschaftlern, nicht nur in Deutschland, sondern überall. Und da fragt man sich, wo kommt das jetzt eigentlich her, beziehungsweise wie verändert sich jetzt gerade ein Diskurs. Und dann ist es ja so, dass es diesen Theoretiker Andreas Malm gibt, der dieses Buch geschrieben hat, wie man eine Pipeline in die Luft sprengt. Und ich habe das damals gelesen und war dann vor allem überrascht darüber, dass auch ein Adam Toos dieses Buch rezipiert hat und sagte, na ja, wenn jetzt diese üblichen Proteste von Fridays for Future und so weiter nicht funktionieren, nicht fruchten, dann ist das durchaus möglich, dass sich eine solche Radikalisierung in Anführungszeichen beziehungsweise eine solche Zuspitzung ergibt. Und es war interessant, dass er dieses Buch sehr wohlwollend rezipierte. Und das Buch ist also natürlich keine Gebrauchsanweisung, wie man es jetzt genau macht, eine Pipeline in die Luft zu sprengen, sondern stellt Fragen. Und ich habe jetzt diesen Andreas Malm, weil dessen Name jetzt sehr oft in diesem Monat gefallen ist in Beiträgen, mir dann nochmal angesehen bei YouTube, der da einen Vortrag gibt vor ein paar Monaten. Und er erwähnt dann auch sehr stark deutsche Proteste jetzt, also jenseits von Fridays for Future. Und wir hören hier mal rein.
Ich hab gerade nur kurz ihn gegoogelt, aber sein zentrales Argument scheint zu sein, wenn jemand über Gewalt spricht, dann sollten wir erstmal da anfangen, wo der Naturgewalt angetan wird von unserem Selbstverständlichkeiten und so.
Das leitet uns direkt über zum nächsten Clip.
Und mehr zu diesem Punkt. Diese Verpflichtung ist nicht zerstört, dass diejenigen, die auf der hohen Räume leben, die ihre Räume und Helikopterpads haben, von diesen Anzeigen profitieren.
Also bei Gefahr im Vollzug gelten andere Regeln, und es ist Gefahr im Vollzug.
Er spielt das immer moralisch dann durch. Er sagt aber auch deutlich, es geht jetzt nicht um Gewalt gegen Menschen, sondern gegen Dinge.
Das ist der moralische Fall, um Fossilfuelverluste zu zerstören. Die Klimawahl beginnt, die Vorwürfe zu betrachten. Never the latter.
So, das ist ganz entscheidend. Und ich glaube, wir müssen das auf mehreren Ebenen als entscheidend ansehen. Einmal auf der moralischen Ebene. Es gibt ja dieses Stück von Albert Camus, Die Gerechten, da geht es um einen Anschlag auf die Zarenfamilie. Da ist die Frage, darf man das machen? Also er hat den, also man kann quasi so ein, der Tyrannenmord es zurechtfertigen. Aber was ist, wenn die Kinder des Zaren mitten in der Kutsche sitzen, kann man dann sagen, gut, ist nur Kollateralschaden oder wo beginnen da die moralischen Fallstrecke? Das stellt sich hier gar nicht mehr. Es geht gegen Dinge und Dinge kosten sehr viel Geld, wie wir wissen. Du hast es ja, glaube ich, beim letzten Mal betont, der Klimawandel trifft Deutschland hart, weil hier alles ganz teuer ist, weil hier jedes Haus 500.000 Euro kostet und dann hat man da ordentliche Summen. Jetzt, wenn wir auf dieser Ebene der Kosten argumentieren, müssen ja Risiken eingepreist werden. Das ist ja gerade das, was wir erleben und dahin würde ich jetzt gerne unseren Diskurs mal bringen. Was wir gerade erleben, ist, dass gesagt wird, wie lange wird man noch in China investieren können für das Risiko, dass da Xi sagt, ab sofort geht das und das nicht mehr. Da könnten solche hohen Kosten durch entstehen. Lohnt sich das überhaupt, dieses Risiko einzugeben? Und genauso ist es ja auch bei Versicherungen. Also was versichert man nicht mehr? Man kennt es ja auch von irgendwelchen Schauspielern, die nicht mehr besetzt werden, wenn man sagt, gut, das ist eine Katastrophe. Da brauchen wir zehn Leute, um die Balaune zu halten. Das kann keine Versicherung mehr mitmachen, wird ständig krank, was auch immer. Solche Fragen stellen sich natürlich auch für Investoren, stellen sich für Firmen generell. Das heißt, man könnte irgendwann, wenn wir jetzt die Sphäre der Kunst verlassen, aber dann denken, oder werden nicht nur mal eine Ausfahrt gesperrt oder so, aber da wird einfach ein Werk gerade lahmgelegt. Die können jetzt da fünf Tage nichts produzieren wegen Extinction Rebellion oder anderen Protestern. Dann sind das ja extreme Kosten. Das sollen wir jetzt mal im Hinterkopf behalten und wir hören nochmal, wie Malm sagt, wie gewaltsam der Klimawandel ist.
Ja, das ist ja nun keine aktivistische Spielerei auf der Bühne, sondern wir haben ja 2003 diesen Hitzesommer gehabt, weshalb die EU-Kommission sich dann fragte, was ist denn da los? Und man hat mal nachgezählt. Nur statistisch ermittelt, da kommt auch der Begriff Übersterblichkeit her von der Hitze. Den haben wir dann erst für Corona sozusagen domestiziert und für uns alle brauchbar gemacht. Aber es ist diese Hitze-Diskussion. Und Frankreich hat damals auch 30.000, allein im August 2003 30.000 mehr Todesfälle durch Hitze. Und dann kennen wir ja in Deutschland noch die Diskussion mit den Feinstaub in der Stadt. Feinstaub ist jetzt nicht unbedingt Klima, sondern das ist dann mehr so das Auto, das eben durch Autoreifenabnutzung und so weiter da auch Feinstaub sorgt. Und wir hatten ja ganz lange eine Diskussion, darf man jetzt die Straßen da sperren oder nicht? Weil wir die juristischen Diskurse immer darauf hinauslaufen haben, ne wir brauchen aber einen konkreten Schuldigen. Das kann nicht der Straßenverkehr allgemein sein, sondern wir müssen dann den einen rausziehen, der halt für den Feinstaub verantwortlich ist. Und da gibt es ja diese Schifte auch in der Rechtsprechung, dass man dann sagt, ne wir müssen die Straße sperren, weil das Niveau einfach allgemein so hoch ist. So wie man auch beim Lärm und so weiter so langsam sagt, ne wenn es zu laut ist, gibt es einfach Gegenmaßnahmen. Wir müssen da nicht die Lärmquelle erstmal identifizieren und dann juristisch in den Zivilprozess reinbringen, sondern das machen wir einfach und in deren Sicht ist das hier auch ganz schön aufgeklärt. Wäre natürlich cool, wenn er selber auf der Bühne die laufenden Diskussionen da bringt, damit man auch, weil das so ein bisschen Kratifikation bringt für die ganze Thematisierung, dann schwebt es nicht wie so eine Kunstaktion irgendwie drüber, sondern dann hat man da so ein bisschen anschlussbares Material.
Und deshalb ist die fossile Wirtschaft quasi wie eine Waffe zu betrachten.
Ja, bin ich total dafür, finde ich sehr sympathisch, denn man konnte relativ zügig gegen diejenigen vorgehen, die ein Gewässer vergiften oder die Straße, aber die Luft war da immer fein raus. Man konnte alles in die Luft hauen, weil das sich dann einfach verdünnt sich ja und so. Und da hier einfach mal das Gegenprogramm zu fahren, ist ja natürlich genau richtig.
Und er malt ein mögliches Szenario aus.
Und jetzt, imagine, als ein spekulierter Szenario, dass die Menschen in Tansania und Uganda die Stärken des Projektes von diesem Prozess aufbauen. Oder, imagine, dass ein Klimawandel in Frankreich die Prozesse von Total zerstört, bis die E-Cop verhöhnt wird. Imgegen der Argument, dass nicht ein einziger Leben in diesen Kampagnen verletzt wird, sondern nur Maschinen und andere Dinge zerstört werden. Was wäre dann die Option? Es wäre ein Minimum von 7.661 Menschen, die pro Jahr für die kommenden Jahrteile bezahlt werden. Und einige würden diesen Selbstversuch nennen.
Er würde sogar, glaube ich, so weit gehen, dass dann ein Vorgericht so zurechtfertig beginnt. Das ist ja eigentlich noch so die Strategie Jacques Verges, dieser Advokate des Teufels, der früher erst linke Demonstranten, Aktivisten, auch Terroristen und dann später alle verteidigt hat. Aber der hat ja diese Strategie vor Gericht gehabt, wenn gesagt wurde von Seiten des Richters, das sind Terroristen. Und sagte ja, nein, das sind Widerstandskämpfer. Also der hat das immer als Angriff als beste Verteidigung gesehen.
Aber es ist ja auch verdreht. Ich meine, jeder macht irgendwann mal einen Erste-Hilfe-Kurs und lernt dann, ja, es gibt Situationen, in denen du natürlich jemanden die Rippen brichst, um ihm das Leben zu retten. Und natürlich darfst du das Auto einfach die Fensterscheibe einschlagen, um da ein Leben zu retten. Und ja, diese Verkettung, warum ist das so kompliziert zu verstehen, dass wir natürlich das ein oder andere machen dürfen, und zwar selbst ermächtigt. Wir ermächtigen uns selbst und erklären im Nachhinein, wir haben ihr Leben gerettet.
Bei BlackRock gab es ja auch Proteste. Auch da haben versucht, welche in die Lobby einzudringen. Oder das haben sie auch geschafft, aber sind dann nicht weitergekommen.
So richtig in New York oder so? Oder wo fand das statt?
Ich meine schon, dass es in New York war. Und es gab noch bei einem Fonds irgendwas. Es gab mehrere Sachen, die auch so ein bisschen mit den Finanzmärkten zusammenhängen. Nun wissen wir, dass Larry Fink generell sagt, ja wir müssen da mal mehr und schreibt dann diese Briefe an die Shareholder und dergleichen. Aber natürlich tut sich da noch zu wenig. Er, Andreas Malm, sagt ganz klar auch, es gibt eine Gewalt beim Investieren.
Ich glaube, wenn du über Klimaschutz und Gewalt diskutierst, sollte das erste, was erkannt werden sollte, ist, dass, wenn Gewalt verletzt wird, es in der Aktivität ist, in diese neuen Installationen für die Produktion von Öl, Gas und Kohl.
Investitionen bringen Menschen um. Und jetzt hören wir etwas Überraschendes. Und zwar gibt es da einen Investor, der gerade einen neuen Klimafonds auflegt. Der nennt sich Albert Wenger. Was von dem genau zu halten ist, weiß ich selbst nicht so. Er spricht sich auch immer wieder für Atomkraftwerke. Er sagt, wir müssen eine neue Technologie und alles haben. Aber er ist auf jeden Fall jemand, der das Thema Klimawandel ganz oben auf die Agenda gesetzt hat. Und er war im OMR Podcast zu Gast und sagt erst mal Folgendes.
Persönlich bin ich überzeugt davon, dass wir hier 50 Prozent des Brustsozialprodukts darauf verwenden müssen, und zwar weltweit für eine Reihe von Jahren. Und wir sind bei vielleicht zwei, drei in manchen Wirtschaften bei vielleicht fünf Prozent. Das heißt also, wir sind nicht hier, wir liegen hier nicht zehn oder zwanzig Prozent zurück, sondern bei um einen Faktor zehn von dem, was wir wirklich machen. Ich denke, es wird noch sehr viel, sehr viel schlimmer werden müssen, bevor genug Politiker verstehen.
So bis genug Politiker verstehen, worauf er hier jetzt eingeht, ist, inwieweit die Politik zu wenig tut. 50 Prozent des BSP schlägt er vor. Das ist natürlich eine sehr stattliche Zahl, da so wichtig sei jetzt der Kampf gegen den Klimawandel. Und er schlägt dann auch eigentlich sehr ähnlich wie Ulrike Herrmann eine Kriegswirtschaft vor.
Das Beispiel ist, im Zweiten Weltkrieg hat die US-Regierung es sofort gegangen, hat gesagt, ihr dürft keine Autos bauen, ihr müsst Flugzeuge bauen. Es sind General Motors gegangen, hat gesagt, ihr dürft keine Autos bauen, ihr müsst Panzer bauen. Und damals, ich habe in meinem Buch so eine Kurve, die zeigt, wie so in den Zwanzigerjahren die Automobilproduktion angestiegen ist, und dann ist sie total abgeknackt während des Zweiten Weltkriegs. Und das ist natürlich dann auch durch Propaganda unterstützt worden. Und da gab es diese Poster. Auf dem Poster sieht man ein Auto, in dem Auto fährt nur einer. Und auf dem Beifahrersitz ist so ein gespenstlicher Hitler. Und der Titel war If you drive alone, you drive with Hitler. Also wir müssen bereit sein zu sagen, wir können jetzt nicht mehr Benzinautos bauen. Wir müssen einfach jetzt nur E-Autos bauen. Und übrigens, wir müssen auch Wärmepuppen bauen. Und übrigens, wir müssen auch Atomkraftwerke bauen. Und übrigens, wir müssen auch Solaranlagen bauen. Und jetzt werden wir einfach viele Dinge mal eine Zeit lang nicht bauen.
Und er geht sogar so weit und sagt, wir müssen die Energie rationieren.
Ich glaube, man muss leider, weil es eben halt eine so große Krise ist, man muss viel direkter in die Energiemärkte eingreifen und den besonderen Elektrizitätsmarkt. Und man muss das Preismodell komplett ändern. Und man muss einfach sagen, wir müssen hier rationieren, im Großen steht rationieren. Und das müsste man jetzt schon, das hätte man jetzt so früh wie möglich anfangen müssen.
Ja, wir haben ja von Ursula von der Leyen damals gehört, wie sie den European Green Deal vorstellt. Und dann noch meinte, das ist die neue Wachstumsstrategie. Weil wir auf anderen Gebieten da wirklich auch an so Grenzen kamen. Und dann hat sie ja so verschiedene Sachen wie den Grenzanpassungsmechanismus und so weiter vorgestellt, was ja bedeutet. Es sind nicht nur die Künstler oder Publizisten, die hier sagen, wir müssen auch mal gewaltsam eingreifen in den Lauf der Dinge, sondern Ursula von der Leyen selbst als Chefin der EU-Kommission hat gesagt, es gibt Geschäftsmodelle, die wir zertrümmern müssen. Um dann andere an deren Platz. Das Beispiel ist ja dann immer das große Stahlwerk, das dann den ganzen Hochofen umstellt auf Wasserstoff und so weiter, was aber bedeutet. Dafür muss man den ganzen globalen Stahlmarkt einmal so richtig auseinandernehmen und sagen, chinesischer Stahl kann nach Europa geliefert werden, aber alle Klimakosten werden eingepreist. Es kostet 300 Prozent Zoll. So ganz hart. Und wir haben ja gerade jetzt die Woche wieder gehört, dass das Europaparlament jetzt auch die finale Zustimmung uns weitergegeben hat. Also 2035 darf das letzte Verbrennerauto verkauft werden. Ab dann darf ein Auto keine Klimagasse mehr ausstoßen während des Betriebs. Und dann haben wir Volker Wissing, den deutschen Verkehrsminister, der dann sagt, ne, das ist ja der falsche Weg. Wir müssen auch uns E-Fuels und so weiter den Weg offen lassen, weil wir ja die Bestandsflotte noch haben, wo man entweder denkt, weiß ja nicht genau, dass es nur um Neuverkäufe geht und die Bestandsflotte gar nicht aus dem Verkehr gezogen wird, sondern es wird dann auch noch weiter Benzin geben. Oder hat er wirklich so eine Idee von, nur wenn wir weiter verbrennen, verbrennen, verbrennen und dann eben wo auch immer heraus synthetisiert, entweder auf dem Feld angebaut oder irgendwo aus der Luft gezogen, das CO2, den Kohlenstoff, dass das dann auch wieder sozusagen eine positive Vererbung auf die Bestandsflotte haben soll. Dass wir nur dann zu diesen neuen Verbrennungsmaterialen kommen, wenn wir sie auch im Verkauf haben und nicht nur für die bestehende Flotte anbieten. Wo du denkst, das passt alles nicht zusammen. Das ist einfach ein Festhalten an den alten Sachen, obwohl jetzt wirklich aus allen Richtungen. Black Hawk hat den Brief geschrieben, die EU-Kommission ist der Meinung, die Aktivisten sagen es auch. Und trotzdem hast du die FDP so da sitzen, die einfach sagen, das geht nicht. Wir müssen auch nach 2035 weiter Sachen in unseren Autos verbrennen. Und man läuft hier so die Straße entlang und freut sich darüber, damit das Porsche-Gefühl noch bleibt. Genau, damit das Porsche-Gefühl bleibt von Ulf Poschert. Und gleichzeitig läuft man hier so die Straße entlang. Das kennt wahrscheinlich jeder in seiner Nachbarschaft. Und irgendwie ist man doch ganz froh, dass es im Oktober noch ein bisschen wärmer ist und nicht alle Heizungen angeschmissen werden, weil es immer noch einen gibt in der Nachbarschaft, der einfach jeden Scheiß in seinen Ofen reinschmeißt und damit die ganze Nachbarschaft verpestet. Und genau das muss noch aussortiert werden. Aber trotzdem haben diese Leute die Anwälte der FDP, die dann einfach in einer deutschen Regierung sitzen und sagen, nein, nein, nein, nein. Und das ist eigentlich... Vielleicht sollten wir die FDP auch unter dieser Maßgabe, welche Gewalt sie uns antun damit.
Und es ist erstaunlich, dass man dann, auch wenn er jetzt einen Klimafonds auflegt, ist es ja jemand, der an den Finanzmärkten agiert, dass dann jemand wie dieser Albert Wenger solche Forderungen stellt.
Worauf verwenden wir das Kapital? Und in welche Richtung lassen wir das philistische Kapital weiter wachsen? Und das ist das, was wir jetzt gerade besprochen haben mit dem Klima. Verwenden wir das jetzt, um noch mehr Benzidautos zu bauen? Oder verwenden wir das, um eine Zeit lang Werbepumpen zu bauen? Und natürlich muss man das umstellen. Aber es sind Roboter zum Teil und es sind Maschinen. Und man kann die umstellen und man kann damit andere Dinge machen.
Jetzt soll also die Produktion am besten umgestellt werden, dass man Werbepumpen baut. Und das ist doch sehr, sehr eigenartig, dass wir gar nicht diesen hyperkapitalistischen Diskurs, der nur eine andere Art von Kapitalismus jetzt will, dass wir das so wenig haben, wenngleich wirklich die Frage ist, inwieweit das volkswirtschaftlich funktionieren würde, also solange wir im kapitalistischen Rahmen sind, dass man solche Projekte macht, Werbepumpen statt Autos. Denn da ist ja jetzt eigentlich von einem Investor den Vorschlag zur Planwirtschaft. Und Planwirtschaft, na also man kann Kapitalismus natürlich mehr planen, als man das jetzt gerade tut. Aber es ist schon sehr schnell auch an den Grenzen, beziehungsweise wo man die Gesetzmäßigkeiten des Kapitalismus schon sehr weit aushebeln muss.
Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher. Ich habe jetzt auch viele Vorträge von Ulrike Herrmann, gerade im Rahmen der Buchmesse und so weiter. Sie ist ja total der Meinung, das geht mit den kapitalistischen, also marktwirtschaftlichen Prinzipien einfach nicht, weil wir diese Verzinsungsidee und im Laufe der Zeit muss Rendite erwirtschaftet werden und so. Und ich denke mir irgendwie, wir sind halt einfach nur komplett entwöhnt davon, dass wir uns auch kulturelle Grenzen einziehen können. Bislang arbeiten wir ja nur mit naturalen Grenzen. Aber dieser Grenzanpassungsmechanismus zum Beispiel, also einen echten Zoll, einen echt schmerzhaften Zoll, der Faktor 8 des Preises drauf legt.
Aber der trifft uns ja alle. Also wir reden da jetzt sehr abstrakt drüber. Aber wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel sagen, also man könnte ja auch eine Forderung stellen, in Deutschland darf kein Auto mehr produziert werden, dass Benzin braucht ab 2025. Könnte man ja jetzt einführen. Das würde bedeuten für das Land, dass unser Wirtschaftswachstum ja nicht nur sinken würde, sondern wir hätten extreme Wohlstandsverluste dadurch. Und das bedeutet ja nicht einfach nur, dass Familie quantklatten weniger hat, sondern das bedeutet ja, dass zum Beispiel Menschen arbeitslos werden, keine Lohnentwicklung und so weiter. Und dies ist ja etwas, wovor eine große Angst da ist. Natürlich ist eine Politik oder eine Regierung eines Staates, der nun mal kapitalistisch organisiert ist, auch an diesen Wettbewerbsvorteilen interessiert, die man zum Beispiel durch Luxusprodukte wie Autos oder in Frankreich Modewaren international erhalten kann. Und das ist ja etwas, wo wir, wenn wir da sagen, wir machen das jetzt mal nicht, in eine ganz heikle Situation geraten.
Ja, aber wenn wir Marktwirtschaft ernst nehmen und sagen, da hängt aber ein grundsätzliches, eine Wachstumserwartung dran. Und dann stellen wir fest, wir sind aber in einer Rezension. Also es geht bergab für, was weiß ich, die Definition ist ja irgendwie drei Quartale in Folge oder so.
Ja, wie das ja aussieht, wird das ja ganze 23 Rezessionen sein.
Genau, das kann man ja auch über drei Jahre ziehen. Die Frage ist ja nur, verabschieden wir uns, nur weil wir es gerade nicht hinbekommen, Wachstum zu organisieren, gleichzeitig von der Wachstumslogik. Oder bleibt die Perspektive, die Erwartung, dass man in einem Wirtschaftssystem arbeitet, in dem es grundsätzlich ermöglicht wird, Rendite zu erwirtschaften. Und nur weil man mal durch eine abflauende, wie auch Habeck es sich nicht zutraut, Schrumpfungsphase zu gehen, sondern dann vom Negativwachstum usw. spricht. Das Prinzip Wachstum bleibt ja trotzdem drin, auch wenn gerade niemand Rendite macht. Deswegen löst sich ja nicht gleich alles auf. Und deswegen bleibt ja nicht die ganze wirtschaftliche Ideengeschichte plötzlich links liegen und ist abgeschlossen oder so. Sondern man muss dann halt neue Orientierung finden, neue Perspektiven aufbauen, sich vielleicht auch mit anderen Wachstumsniveaus zufrieden geben. Man kann immer noch über die Maßstäbe, was ist eigentlich Wachstum? Habeck arbeitet ja dran oder lässt so ein paar Leute daran arbeiten, dass man da auch ein bisschen neu definiert. Deswegen dieser große Abschied von der Marktwirtschaft als Forderung, nur weil es nicht durchgehend Wachstum ist. Also ich glaube, wir werden uns relativ zügig daran gewöhnen, dass die westliche Welt auch mit Dellen des Wachstums umgehen lernt, weil man gar nicht drum herumkommt. Also schon allein die Demografie wird es uns ja auferlegen. Und die neuen Klimagesetze, die dann auch irgendwann greifen. Sie sind ja bis jetzt immer nur verabschiedet. Und irgendwann greifen sie auch.
Nur wenn das in diesem Rahmen jetzt läuft, dann bedeutet das einfach, dass die Menschen ärmer werden.
Genau.
Aber das meint jetzt nicht, reiche Leute leisten sich irgendeinen Urlaub weniger, sondern dass man erfahrt, dass die breite Bevölkerung ärmer wird. Also das heißt, die verdienen weniger Geld. Die haben nicht die Möglichkeit, noch eine Eigentumswohnung zu erwerben. Die haben nicht die Möglichkeit, ordentlich über die Runden zu kommen. Das meint ja, wenn weniger Geld da ist.
Genau. Aber wenn du diese Wachstumslogik umdrehst und sagst, die Europäer werden für ihre Mobilität eben nicht mehr 250 Euro pro Nase pro Monat ausgeben, sondern nur noch 9 Euro, dann hast du ja faktisch in allen Bilanzen ein krasses Absenken des Niveaus. Das heißt aber noch lange nicht, dass du deswegen weniger Kilometer fährst. In Spanien ist der Nahverkehr einfach kostenlos. Man steigt flächendeckend ein, fährt irgendwo hin. Das kann volkswirtschaftlich gar nicht mehr bilanziert werden als, oh, hier liegt aber Wachstum vor und so weiter. Und die Leute sind trotzdem mega mobil. Und der Fernverkehr ist eben einfach immer pünktlich. Also man kann sich halt darauf verlassen, ne, ich muss ja nicht zehn Stunden extra einplanen für meine Reise, weil ich irgendwie die Verspätung und so weiter, das sind ja alles die volkswirtschaftlichen Kostendrücker, sondern nein, man fährt mit dem kostenlosen Nahverkehr zum Fernbahnhof und steigt in einen pünktlich abfahrenden Zug. Fertig ist die Laube. Die Gesellschaft bleibt mobil, die Kontakte sind da, ohne dass es sich kostenmäßig irgendwie entschlägt.
Ich glaube, dass man eine super Gesellschaft bauen kann. Ich befürchte nur, dass das im kapitalistischen Rahmen nicht möglich ist, weil die Profite ja auch da nicht gemacht werden, wenn alle Leute für neun Euro durch die Gegend fahren können, sondern Profite werden dadurch gemacht, dass sich am besten die Menschen alle zwei Jahre ein neues großes Auto kaufen.
Genau, und dafür brauchen wir dann sektorübergreifendes Denken, dass man nämlich sich sagt, der volkswirtschaftliche Gewinn wird schon irgendwo anfallen, aber nicht bei der Mobilität, sondern wir querfinanzieren die Mobilität über den ansonsten aufkommenden, die volkswirtschaftliche Brosperität, die wir durch günstige Mobilität geben. Und diese sektorübergreifende Denken haben wir ja nun in der Klimapolitik schon ziemlich deutlich drin. Und das kann man ja genauso als Vorbild und Prinzip einfach nehmen und dann sagen, ja, dann stürmen wir das jetzt mal einfach allen über. Ist ja auch mal eine große Forderung bei der Demografie. Ja, ich bin ja nicht dafür zu sagen, die Mieten sind so hoch, die müssen jetzt mal runtergedrückt werden, sondern sektorübergreifend kann man auch sagen, ja, müssen halt die Löhne hoch. Wenn die Vermieter ihre Miete haben wollen, müssen halt die Löhne entsprechend steigen. Und so kann man ja die Stellschrauben entsprechend, aber man braucht dann eben diese große Perspektive. Und nachdem lange Zeit nur die Natur Grenzen gegeben hat, ziehen wir halt noch ein paar Politische ein. Das ist dann neu, das ist ein Novum, hebt aber die marktwirtschaftlichen Prinzipien noch lange nicht auf.
Nun haben wir über Wirksamkeit gesprochen. Die ist nicht allzu groß, wenn man van Gogh bekleckert, sondern wir sind dann zumindest nicht in der Weise affiziert davon, dass jetzt heute im Parlament was anderes beschlossen wird. Aber wie ist es tatsächlich mit diesem Aktivismus? Jetzt haben wir Malm gehört, der da schon mal so hypothetische Szenarien durchspielt. Was würde das bedeuten? Und das kostet natürlich die Firmen was. Und bevor man sich da wieder irgendwelche Proteste aufhalts, lässt man es lieber ganz oder baut zurück oder die Politik genehmigt etwas nicht, weil es sonst wieder zu Protesten führt. Also da kann natürlich ein radikaler Aktivismus entsprechend Früchte tragen. Und erstaunlich ist dann, dass dieser Albert Wenger auch die letzte Generation erwähnt.
Siehst du da irgendjemanden, der dabei ist zu ändern?
Oder irgendeine Tendenz?
Na ja, es gibt neue Klimabewegungen, wie zum Beispiel letzte Generation in Deutschland oder Just Up Oil in England, die jetzt sagen, die Zeit der Protestmarsch ist vorbei, wir brauchen hier mehr einen Civil Disobedience Approach. Und historisch, ob das jetzt das Wahrrecht der Frauen ist oder Civil Rights oder auch die HIV-Bekämpfung, historisch hat man dann Fortschritte gemacht, wenn es zu diesen Civil Disobedience Bewegungen gekommen ist. Und deshalb bin ich, sag ich mal, eher ein bisschen mehr hoffnungsvoll, dass es vielleicht jetzt doch Bewegung geben kann.
Also wir haben hier einen Investor, der ganz klar sagt, naja, Aktivismus, und er verweist auf die Sofragetten, die gewalttätigen Protest dann gemacht haben. Und auch Stonewall, also LGBT, war ja auch eine gewaltsame Sache. Das war ja nicht immer nur sommerlicher Karneval, wie das heute so rezipiert wird. Und es ist sehr erstaunlich, dass es da in dem Diskurs stattfindet. Er sagt dann noch etwas zu seinem Klimafonds. Er wird dann gefragt, was ist, wenn der nicht erfolgreich ist?
Wenn unser Klimafonds nicht erfolgreich ist, dann hat das zwei mögliche Gründe. Der eine ist, dass wir komplett die falschen Firmen gewählt haben. Das ist natürlich immer eine Möglichkeit. Aber die andere Möglichkeit ist einfach, dass wir den politischen Willen nie entwickelt haben, um wirklich hier aktiv zu werden. Und in dem Fall, denke ich, machen wir größere Probleme, als dass der Fonds nicht erfolgreich war.
Wenn dieser Fonds nicht erfolgreich wird, möglicherweise gab es dann einzelne Fehlentscheidungen. Aber wenn an sich Klimafonds nicht erfolgreich werden, dann bedeutet das einfach, dann hat man es verpasst. Man hat es nicht politisch umgesetzt, bzw. es hat sich nicht genügend Kapital gefunden. Und was wir, glaube ich, jetzt noch in den Blick nehmen sollten, ist, dass wir einen Kulturkampf auf einer neuen Ebene nun finden. Wir kennen all diese Kulturkämpfe in der Politik, auf Twitter, bei den Aktivisten. Und jetzt finden wir sie aber plötzlich bei Investoren. Ich hatte schon mal vor Monaten erzählt, dass in den USA von Konservativen, von Republikanern Fonds aufgelegt werden, die nur Firmen im Portfolio haben, die gegen die Abtreibung sind. Also wo schon eine solche Kulturkampf-Sache vorkommt, dann im Investieren. Und etwas jetzt auch ziemlich Neues ist Strive. Ich weiß nicht, ob du davon schon gehört hast. Das ist ein Fond, hinter dem unter anderem auch Peter Thiel steckt. Und der wurde aufgelegt von Vivek Ramaswamy, der glaube ich täglich sieben Interviews gibt, von Fox News bis CNBC. Und dieser Fond möchte genau nicht ESG-konform sein.
Also die Anti-Wurken?
Das ist Anti-Wurk. Die schreiben jetzt auch die ganze Zeit Briefe an Disney. Hört mal da und damit auf. Und vor allem richten die sich mit Briefen an Chevron an all die Schmutzigen und sagen, macht mal ruhig weiter. Wir hören jetzt mal hier Vivek Ramaswamy bei CNBC.
Wenn du eine Öl-Kompanie bist, sei eine exzellente Öl-Kompanie.
Wenn du eine Solare-Kompanie bist, sei eine exzellente Solare-Kompanie.
Aber wir werden nicht sagen, dass Öl-Kompanien nicht Öl-Kompanien sind.
Und Joe, das betrifft, was ich als eine Fiduciere-Issue mit den top Asset-Managern im Welt.
Und was ich heute in der Welt finde, ist ein Problem, wo die größten Asset-Manager auf dem Planeten, BlackRock, State Street, Vanguard, ich glaube, sie nutzen ihre Kundenwohnung, um für die Bewege in den Bordesläden der Corporate America zu verhindern.
Erkennt den Klimawandel als Problem an, sieht auch, man muss irgendetwas tun, muss anders investieren und jetzt versuchen, sich manche dagegen zu stimmen und ja, Peter Thiel ist mächtig und ja, der hat auch Geld, aber verglichen mit dem, was Blackrock zum Beispiel an Kapital zur Verfügung hat oder was jetzt auch hier Ramaswami in so einem Fonds hat, ist das natürlich ein Kampf gegen Windmühlen, die den jetzt anfangen zu führen und machen einen Kulturkampf, der aber wahrscheinlich aufgrund des fehlenden nötigen Geldes, Ich kann das nicht unter Streif oder Strive oder wie sie es nennen, aber Karel Swisher hat sich kurz darüber lustig gemacht.
Peter Thiel gibt halt auch 50 Millionen dazu, was ja im Grunde nichts ist, gerade im Kampf gegen Black Rock und so weiter. In deren Sicht ist das auch so eine Art Kunstaktion auf dem Gebiet, wo Peter Thiel halt operiert, dass er weiß, mit so ein bisschen Geld mach ich eine große Überschrift und so weiter, dann wissen alle Bescheid. Wir haben ja in Sachen Black Rock auch alle Texte gelesen, sowohl die Larry-Fink-Briefe, wo drin stand, wenn ihr für 30 Jahre Kredite vergebt, schaut euch doch noch mal ein Überschwemmungsgebiet an, wo steht denn das Gebäude und so weiter. Und gleichzeitig auch kürzlich diese Texte, in denen noch mal dargestellt wird, dass Vanguard und Black Rock eben jetzt auf die CDU-Linie eingeschwenkt sind und erstmal all in fordern. Wir können jetzt keine Atomkraftwerke ausschalten, weil wir haben eine Krise zu bewältigen und so weiter. Und in der Hinsicht, ja, hängt das alles in der Luft. Es ist gerade wieder ein bisschen mehr Semantik als Struktur, aber Black Rock wird wahrscheinlich bei nächster Gelegenheit dann auch wieder schon allein, weil sie diese Vorreiterrolle da einfach haben wollen, sie dann wieder umschwenken und dies wieder ein bisschen forcieren.
Das ist schon sehr amüsant, dass er hier diversity als Begriff mit dem Spiel bringt, um eine Meinungspluralität zu haben. Und jetzt will er auch noch sagen, dass man so eine Kapitalkonzentration erlebt. Also wir haben jetzt quasi von rechts eine Kapitalismuskritik, also die sich am liberalen Kapitalismus stört. Und ja, er geistert damit durch alle Talkshows und wird eingeladen, ist dann auch ganz lustig in seinen Antworten. Aber ich glaube, das wird wirklich auf dieser Ebene des Kulturkampfes bleiben. Also wie du sagst, das ist auch im Prinzip eine Kunstaktion. Ob das ausreicht, was BlackRock und so weiter tun, ist fraglich. Man muss auch gerade bei solchen Antipoden aufpassen, dass die nicht dadurch die andere Seite in zu gutem Licht dastehen lassen. Dass man jetzt sagt, ach Larry Fink gehört zu den Guten. Das hier ist der Böse, der Ramaswami. Der will ja gar nicht was machen, was mit Klimawandel zusammenhängt. Aber da wäre ich doch sehr vorsichtig. Jedenfalls glaube ich, muss man nicht sehr viel Angst davor haben, dass Ramaswami und Thiel jetzt bald alle Investoren, alles Kapital anziehen können.
Du hast ja die Soufragetten genannt.
Ja, die haben ja sogar ein Gemälde zerstört.
Genau, Mary Richardson, 1914. Wir erwähnen selten, dass wir die Neuen Zwanziger sind, weil es auch alte Zwanziger gibt. Aber ich will kurz hier aus diesem Zeittext von Elisabeth Rehter vorlesen. Denn vieles von dem, was wir gerade besprechen, ist nicht neu, auch wenn es uns so innovativ daherkommt. Und wir es oder ich zumindest so krass loben. Für die Aktivisten von Just Stop Oil sind die Soufragetten Vorbilder, zumindest in deren Frühphase. Als die Praktiken des gewaltfreien Widerstands entwickelten. Sie erreichten bekanntlich ihr Ziel, das Wahlrecht für Frauen wurde eingeführt. Also in deren Sicht gucken wir auf eine Erfolgsgeschichte. Allerdings zerstörten die Soufragetten nicht nur Gemälde, sie radikalisierten sich, als sie irgendwann feststellten, dass sie nicht bekamen, was sie wollten. Eine Soufragette warf sich vor das Rennpferd des Königs und starb. Die Frauen steckten im ganzen Land Kirchen im Brand und legten Bomben in Bahnhöfen. Der Innenminister sollte entführt werden. Die Soufragetten gelten heute als Erfinderin der Briefbombe. Männer hielten jeden für unbedeutend, der sie nicht angreife, glaubten sie. Eine Bewegung müsse also hinreichend gewalttätig sein, um Respekt zu erlangen. Also wir haben es hier beim Kampf gegen das Patriarchat mit Frauen zu tun, die sich gesagt haben, Männer sind so gewalttätig unter sich, dass sie sich gegenseitig Respekt zollen, indem sie sich ihre Gewalttätigkeit vorführen. Jemand muss als Sieger aus dem Kampf gehen, nur dann ist er für alle anderen derjenige, der Respekt verdient hat. Also bekämpfen wir sie auch gewaltsam. Und dann hat man Erfinder der Briefbombe, das sagt ja einiges. Die Geschichte des Frauenwahlrechts, das wir heute so gut finden, geht also einher mit der Erfindung der Briefbombe. Und mal gucken, wie weit es jetzt getrieben wird.
Ich empfehle sehr den Film Die Soufragetten, der ist mit Meryl Streep, ist aber trotzdem ein sehr guter Film. Und da kann man tatsächlich die Gewalttätigkeit des Protests sehen. Und dass es hier nicht einfach nur darum geht, so ein bisschen Awareness zu schaffen. Knut Kortzen hat ein Buch veröffentlicht, das heißt Die Weltverbesserer, und beschäftigt sich damit 100 Jahren Aktivismus. Und verweist darauf, dass 2001 Sloterdijk schon sagte, Erregbarkeit ist jetzt die erste Bürgerpflicht. Und er schrieb dann weiter, Wir brauchen daher keinen allgemeinen Militärdienst mehr. Was verlangt wird, ist der allgemeine Themendienst, also die Bereitschaft, seine Rolle zu spielen als Reizleiter für opportune kollektive Psychosen. Also er steht ihm da natürlich erst was skeptisch gegenüber. Kortzen schreibt dann, Um einen weiteren unerfreulichen Seitenaspekt nicht auszusparen, der eng zusammenhängt mit der Fokussierung auf Hashtags und Parolen. Das schlechte Lesen wird dadurch befördert. Es reicht gemeinhin schon der Verfassernahme oder die Überschrift eines Artikels, um selbige zu skandalisieren. Dies fällt gerade beim journalistischen und akademischen Aktivismus auf, der es besser wissen müsste. Und Sloterdijk schrieb dann 2001, Das schlechte Lesen ist eine Waffe, die von den Teilnehmern am Wettbewerb um Aufmerksamkeit immer unverholener eingesetzt wird. Ich spreche jetzt nicht von den Unfähigen, sondern von denen, die, wenn sie wollten, anders könnten. Aber warum sollten sie noch wollen, die Zeiten, als Bildung höflich machte, scheinen vorüber, die guten intellektuellen Manieren werden vom Textmobbing abgelöst. Sloterdijk hat 2001 geschrieben. Können wir ja, Prächt Wälzer Debatte, können sehen, wir können es jetzt auch sehen, wenn überall zu lesen war, wollten Van Gogh Bild zerstören oder haben Van Gogh Bild bekleckert. Nein, das Glas vor dem Van Gogh Bild wurde bekleckert. Also das muss doch möglich sein, dass man auch so eine Differenzierung macht. Es gab allerdings auch einen Vorfall, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, wo das ist, wo man nur sagen würde, Gott sei Dank war da Filz dazwischen, dass es nicht angegriffen wurde, das Bild. Also auch da ist nicht alles so bombensicher wie hier der Van Gogh in London. Deswegen, also da hört dann bei mir der Spaß dann doch eher auf, wenn jetzt wirklich wieder zerstört werden wollten aus Unwissenheit.
Genau, da hört der Spaß auf und das wissen die eben auch hoffentlich.
Dann macht doch da Andreas Malm andere Angebote. Dann heißt es noch bei kurzen, noch bevor man einen Gedanken ausspricht, erweckt man, ob er nicht auf der gegnerischen Seite Applaus ernten könnte. Also auch das ist so etwas, was wir in so einem hyperaktivistischen Kontext natürlich immer haben. Die Torheit, den Feind zum Schiedsrichter des eigenen Redens zu machen, ist endemisch, seitdem sie Enzensberger 1962 formulierte. Und zwar schrieb Enzensberger, die Angst vor dem Beifall von der falschen Seite ist nicht nur überflüssig, sie ist ein Charakteristikum totalitären Denkens. Kritik, die ihr Konzessionen macht, ist durch keinen Hinweis auf taktische Überlegungen zu rechtfertigen, sie ist hinfällig.
Was machen wir demnächst ohne diese Leute? Enzensberger und Sloterdijk, das ist ja erstaunlich.
Wir nehmen diese ganzen Werke und lesen sie einfach wieder. Wir sagen dann, das ist ein interessantes Buch von 1965. Das klöpfen wir uns jetzt einfach mal wieder vor. Aber vor dem Hintergrund dessen, was letzte Woche passiert ist.
Sloterdijk hat 2001 über diese neue Resonanzsuche aller Beteiligten in der Gesellschaft geschrieben. 2001 war das Jahr, in dem noch kein Facebook, kein Twitter, eigentlich sogar nicht Internet, die Dotcom-Blase platzt gerade und die FAZ sagt, komm wir gründen mal eine Sonntagszeitung. Also eigentlich nimmt die ganze Gesellschaft nochmal Anlauf und sagt, wir machen hier nochmal Hochkultur und großes Föhton. Und gleichzeitig ist da so ein hellseherischer Sloterdijk, der das schon so vorwegnimmt.
Vielleicht noch ein letztes Zitat kurz und schreibt am Schluss, wie auch immer die Geschichte des Aktivismus weitergeht. Ein Satz aus seinen Anfangstagen dürfte bis heute gelten. Er mag auch diesem Versuch, seine Geschichte zu erzählen, entgegengehalten werden. Das Buch Dezeit ist aus verteufelt hartem Material gearbeitet, meinte Karl von Osiecki 1918 in Ein Wort über Aktivismus. Und dann das Zitat, man schreibt sich entweder mit dem Meißel ein oder gar nicht. Der Gänse Stil des gelehrten Skriventen zerbricht daran beim ersten Buchstaben.
Ich will mal ganz profan dieses Thema abschließen, Klima, denn wir haben die Klimadiskussion und so weiter, aber wir haben ja auch noch einen Ukrainekrieg. Und der Chef der Weltwetterorganisation, wir haben ja gerade erstaunliches Wetter gehabt, also wir liegen ja zehn Grad über den Index Temperaturen der letzten Jahre. Es ist eigentlich erstaunlich, der 28. Oktober war ein Hitzetag, also ein Sommertag, teilweise über 25 Grad in Deutschland, wie wir es eigentlich noch nie zuvor überhaupt in einem Oktober-Tag, nicht mal am ersten, vier Wochen vorher, mal in einem Jahr registriert haben. Und naja, im Rahmen jetzt hat eben auch die Weltwetterorganisation sich zu Wort gemeldet. Und zu Wort gemeldet finde ich besonders mutig, denn beim Deutschlandfunk referiert man ihn auf besondere Weise und benutzt ein Wort, man hätte es gerne mal bei ihm im Original gehört, wo ich mir denke, uiuiui, da hat sich ja keiner was getraut.
Der Krieg in der Ukraine für das Klima könnte er positive Auswirkungen haben. Zu diesem Schuss kommt die Weltwetterorganisation in Genf. Auf lange Sicht, so die WMO, beschleunige er nämlich die Entwicklung umweltfreundlicher Energien. Der Chef der Weltwetterorganisation sprach heute sogar von einem Segen.
Der Ukraine kriegt als Segen fürs Klima. Also hier werden auch so Sachen miteinander aufgerechnet. Das ist nicht diese Art von sektorübergreifend.
Wie wir das jetzt meinen.
Nein, das ist ein bisschen übertrieben.
Und es ist auch eine sehr eigenartige Rechnung doch, oder? Also kann das kann das gehen?
Also sagen wir es mal so.
Gut, wenn man die Rüstung schon mal ausklimmert und dann sagt, na ja, jetzt sind nochmal alle angetrieben, doch über Windräder nachzudenken.
Ja, das interessante ist eben mit den Windrädern und gerade mit der Solaranlage. Das sind ja Preise pro Kilowattstunde, die du nicht anders kriegst. Also gerade in Afrika, wo man sich jetzt gerade die Frage stellt. Und gestern kamen ja wieder die Zahlen von Statista. Jemand hat mir das auf Instagram geschickt. Sollen wir den Mik kurz besprochen, weil es so bahnbrechend ist. Also in Europa gibt es jetzt erstmals und wir sind auch wirklich weltweit führend – mehr über 65-Jährige als unter 25-Jährige. Also es ist ein echter Kipp. Die Prozentzahlen sind so 18% sind über 65 und 16% sind unter 25. Und in Afrika, flächendeckender ganze Kontinent, 40 zu 3. Also man kommt auf einen Überhang Faktor 10 mehr unter 25-Jährige als über 65-Jährige. Was bedeutet, denen steht eben jetzt dieses neue Zeitalter bevor, so wie wir das Jahrhundert hatten. Bevölkerung wird verdreifacht, Lebenserwartung verdoppelt. Also da ist jetzt so richtig die Innovation kommt von den Jungen. Da ist jetzt Powerhouse angesagt. Und der Wetterorganisations-Chef hat hier auch nochmal sich zu Afrika geäußert. Denn die stellen sich jetzt die Frage. 4 Cent pro Kilowattstunde mit Solar. Kriegt man gar nicht mehr hin mit Kohle plus man muss ja noch dieses Loch buddeln. Also bis man überhaupt im Cashflow angekommen ist, muss ja ganz schön viel erdbewegt werden. Genauso wie so ein Atomkraftwerk. Ja, das kann man dann zwar recht billig betreiben. Gerade wenn es abgeschrieben ist, lernen ja gerade die Deutschen, dass man da doch noch mal 300 Millionen pro Monat rausziehen kann, das so ein Atomkraftwerk. Aber man muss es halt irgendwann mal gebaut haben. Diese Investitionen, um die kommt man ja nicht drum rum. Und jetzt gibt es hier doch, finde ich, erfreuliche Aussichten, dass man vielleicht gar nicht so viel Politik braucht, weil die Marktwirtschaft ihre eigenen Prinzipien hier in Anschlag bringt.
In den nächsten acht Jahren müsse die Stromerzeugung aus erneuerbaren Quellen verdoppelt werden. Entwicklungsländer, etwa in Afrika, sollten von Anfang an darauf setzen, sie hätten die Chance, das Zeitalter der fossilen Energien zu überspringen. 60 Prozent der besten Flächen für Solarenergie weltweit liegen in Afrika. Es gibt ein großes Potenzial für die Windenergie und auch für die Wasserkraft. Das ist eine große Chance für Afrika.
Vielleicht wird es doch ein bisschen ein Selbstläufer, allein über den Preis. Dass es sich in den afrikanischen Ländern sehr viel mehr lohnt, Windräder und Solaranlagen aufzubauen, als jetzt Löcher zu graben und Atomkraftwerke einzumauern. In der Hinsicht ein kleines positives Zeichen zumindest. So, kommen wir mal in die deutsche Tiefebene. Ich möchte einen Clip spielen, auch im Nachklang zu diesen ganzen Thematisierungen. Prächt, Wälzer, wie funktioniert es, welche Aufgabe stellt sich eigentlich der politische Journalismus und so. Und es ist nur ein ganz kurzer Clip, 13 Sekunden. Kara Swisher hat einen neuen Podcast, On. Und sie hatte als allerersten Gast Maggie Haberman, die wir ja kennen als diejenige, die nicht nur jetzt auch nochmal ihr Trump Buch geschrieben hat, was ich super krass finde, weil sie sich gesagt hat, ich bin ja Maggie Haberman. Ich muss ja nicht, nur weil Trump jetzt gerade noch frisch im Abend war, ein Buch vorlegen, sondern ich lasse mir mal Zeit. Ich warte mal bis die Midterm-Elections über zwei Jahre ins Land. Und dann schreibe ich um, wer sich dafür interessiert, was ich zu Trump sage, liest ja dann trotzdem. Und da bin ich ja direkt angesprochen irgendwie. Ich will auch nochmal lesen, was Maggie Haberman jetzt zu Trump sagt. Und sie kriegt hier als allerletzte Frage von Chaos Fisher, was rätst du denn den neuen Journalisten, die jetzt eben mit so einer neuen Art von Politik zu tun haben? Also mit Trump und Brexit und Bolsonaro und solchen Typen, die ja...
Bolsonaro, gutes Stichwort. Er hat wohl verloren. Er hat wohl verloren. Lula wird gewonnen haben, wenngleich es knapp ist. Und das bedeutet natürlich viel Chaos in Brasilien.
Es ist so knapp, dass es wirklich Chaos bedeutet.
Man wird sehen. Aber an sich ein bisschen positive Nachricht dann doch. Hätte man vielleicht erstmal nicht gedacht, dass er das macht.
Das kann man mal sagen. Und Maggie Haberman gibt hier ihre Antwort, wie man mit diesen neuen Herausforderungen, weil neue Politik umgeht. Das ist tatsächlich exzellent und nice. Denn es ist auf den Punkt gebracht, worum es geht. Wenn wir Fernsehpodcasts machen, wenn man einfach nur so im Politikpodcast der Deutschlandfunk, vom Deutschlandfunk hört usw. Es treffen sich Journalisten, sie wollen den Fluorfunk transportieren, sie reden über ihre Themen, wie zum Beispiel, ich war auf dem Grünenparteitag, ich war bei der CDU und dann...
Hast du schon gehört, da soll es ja noch mal doch im Vorsitz noch mal eine Rockade geben und dann geht das los.
Genau, diesen ganzen Krimskrams, als wären sie selber die Berater der Politiker und würden ihnen noch mal sagen, wie man das eigentlich hätte besser machen können und warum man jetzt auch mal Verständnis für die Grünen haben muss als FDP und so weiter. Dieser ganze Plattradatsch, wo man echt denkt, Leute, das ist auch eine Art von Korruption, wenn ihr euch im Metier der Politik eure Orientierung holt, obwohl ihr eigentlich im Mediensystem seid. Denn das sind nicht eure Probleme. Ihr redet da nur darüber. Das findet bei euch auf der Sachebene bitte statt und nicht auf der Soziallebene. Ihr habt da kein Skin in the Game. Wir fordern das eigentlich von euch. Und unter dieser Maßgabe habe ich mir dann gedacht, ich bringe mal einfach die Clips aus dem Bundestag mit. Der Oktober war ein voller Bundestagstag. Es gab ganz viele Debatten. Und wenn man sich anschaut, was die Journalisten interessiert, geht es nur darum, warum hat Olaf Scholz diesen Brief geschrieben, in dem drin steht, wir machen das jetzt so und so.
Und was heißt eigentlich?
Richtlinienkompetenz? Genau, Stefan Dethier dann. Ich kann mich nur darüber aufregen, wie er da seinen Politikpodcast, diese juristischen Exegesen, was das eigentlich bedeutet. Diszipliniert man damit einzelne Kabinettskollegen oder führt man Entscheidungen herbei? Überrumpelt man also den Bundestag, indem man einfach sagt, nein, der Bundestag muss ja trotzdem noch entscheiden.
Ich finde das wirklich auch so ambisant, dass man sofort wieder, und man kennt das ja schon lange, dieses Wort, und das wird dann jedes Mal wieder aufs Neue analysiert, dass man absolut wieder in diesem Modus gefangen ist, wo wir zwei Corona-Jahre hatten, wo Angela Merkel eine Ministerpräsidenten-Konferenz einberufen hat und das darüber regelte, wo sich dann die Hälfte der Ministerpräsidenten beklagt, wir haben schon seit vier Stunden nicht mit ihr gesprochen, wir sitzen einfach da und wissen gar nicht, was los ist. Und als selbst das nicht mehr ging, hat sie quasi von Anne Will aus regiert. Und das haben wir ja alles erlebt. Und jetzt gibt es mal so eine Sache, wo der Kanzler das in Form eines Briefs macht und sofort, dass man wieder, oh, was ist denn da los und so weiter. Also bitte, wo sind wir denn?
Wir wählen einen Bundeskanzler. Oder wir wählen ein Parlament, das wählt sich ein Bundeskanzler. Dieser Bundeskanzler wird vereidigt. Alle wissen, das ist jetzt der Typ. Wenn irgendwas zu entscheiden ist und es gibt Streitereien, der kann schlichten. Der kann nämlich einfach über Richtlinienkompetenz und egal, wie man das Wort benutzt. Er hat die Macht, die haben wir ihm verliehen. Und dann wendet er sie an. Und es ist das größte Rätsel für die Journalisten, wie das sein könnte. Da muss man sagen, das ist schon erstaunlich.
Der Koalitionspartner hat ja die Möglichkeit des Koalitionsbruchs. Das kann man ja herstellen und sagen, wir brauchen Neuwahlen. Aber das war ja offenbar nicht so wichtig für die FDP, dass man jetzt sagt, wir haben den Brief bekommen, machen wir nicht jetzt Neuwahlen.
Genau, wenn es dazu zu einem Bruch kommt, würde ich sagen, dann kann man auch darüber berichten. Aber einfach nur, der Kanzler hat was entschieden. Dafür ist er da, er soll Sachen entscheiden. Er legt die Tagesordnung der Kabinettssitzung fest. Krass, da fand da ganz schön viel nicht statt. Wie zum Beispiel diese Costco-Sache, über die wir ja noch sprechen. Aber dass der Kanzler eine Nachricht entscheidet, ist wirklich Hund beißt Mann. Das ist die Nachricht, das ist einfach wild. Naja, wir gucken uns jetzt die Themen an, die immer wieder liegen geblieben sind, weil alle so aufgeregt waren wegen solchen Sachen. Und Karolaj ist ja nicht linker Fraktionschefin, obwohl sie es wollte. Sie hat also damals verloren und macht trotzdem erstaunliche Arbeit. Und zwar auf allen Ebenen, die ein Politiker so bespielen kann. Sie hat also ein Buch zum Thema, das heißt Vonopoly, ein wahnsinnig guter Titel. Und sie hat einen Antrag im Bundestag zum Thema. Also sie ist so eine Art Amy-Klobuchar zum Thema Wohnen in Deutschland. Und sie hat hier am 21. einen Antrag vorgestellt.
Ich eröffne die Aussprache und erteile als erster Rednerin der Kollegin Karin Lay, Fraktion Die Linke, das Wort.
Herr Präsident, meine Damen und Herren, wir haben in den letzten Tagen viel über die Energiepreiskrise gesprochen, zu Recht, aber noch zu wenig über die Mietenkrise. In Salzgitter stiegen die Mieten in einem Jahr um 13 Prozent, in Rostock um 12 Prozent. Deshalb stellen wir als Linke heute unser Krisenpaket Miete vor. Was tut die Bundesregierung? Heizkostenzuschuss und Wohngeldreform. Ja, aber es bekommen eben nicht alle Menschen Wohngeld. Und zweitens muss man eben auch aufpassen, den Energieriesen und den Wohnungskonzernen wie Vonovia nicht auch noch das Steuergeld in den Rachen zu werfen. Und deshalb, wir brauchen einen bundesweiten Mietenstopp. Da verkämpft der Mieterbund, da verkämpfen viele Initiativen seit vielen Jahren. Und das hat die SPD im Wahlkampf ja auch unterstützt. Olaf Scholz, Sie, Herr Kühnert, Tönten, wir wollen den bundesweiten Mietenstopp. Und jetzt, außer Spesen, nichts gewesen. Im Koalitionsvertrag kein einziges Wort dazu.
Ja, also das finde ich ganz großartig. Und die Themesetzung ist spektakulär gut. Denn nach zwei Jahren Corona, wo der deutsche Staat alles getan hat, Sonderhaushalte in dreistelligen Milliardenhöhen, nur damit die Vermieter ihre Miete kriegen, stolpern wir jetzt ins nächste Problem, dass wir nämlich einen Ukraine-Krieg haben und der Staat wieder alles dafür tut, damit die Nebenkosten-Lieferanten ihre Nebenkosten erstattet kriegen. Also Energie, Heizen, der ganze Kram. Und da fragt man sich ja wirklich langsam, ja, sollten wir nicht wirklich das anders machen? Also ein Preisdeckel einführen? Weil was soll so ein Stadtwerk machen, wenn wir sagen, die Leute sind in Frankfurt am Main bei 50 Prozent ihres monatlichen Einkommens wird aufgebracht für das Wohnen.
Das ist eine unglaubliche Zahl.
Also die Grenze ist erreicht. Warum sagt man nicht einfach Mietenstopp? Wir frieren jetzt die Mieten einfach mal ein. 2017, 2013, wie auch immer, das waren alles keine schlechten Jahre für die Vermieter. Wir gehen mal auf dieses Niveau zurück. Man muss es nicht ausbeuten bis zum Rest. Und dass wir auf eine schon vorhandene Wohntkostenkrise, noch mal eine Nebenkostenkrise drauflegen einfach. Und dann wieder überlegen, wie sichern wir jetzt die Renditen derjenigen ab, die uns das alles damit versorgen. Statt einfach mal zu sagen, wir senken jetzt einfach mal das Niveau.
Und die Tendenz zur Mietsteigerung ist ja doppelt gegeben. Nicht nur dadurch, dass wir eine Inflation haben, sondern auch dadurch, dass wir Zinspolitik-Tickets haben, die Kredite ganz teuer macht. Sehr viele Wohnhäuser sind hier auf Kredit gekauft. Und dann ist dann so die Rechnung, naja, das wird hier mit 0, 9 Prozent finanziert. Und dann bekomme ich so und so viel Miete raus. Dann hat sich das gelohnt. Und dann hat sich das Haus in 15 Jahren gerechnet. Also das ist jetzt dann nicht von Novia, sondern das sind dann, gibt dann noch so ein paar reiche Leute, die kaufen und dann Vermieter werden. Und weiß ich nicht, wie viele Wohnungen haben, 50, 60, 70. Und deren Geschäftsmodell funktioniert natürlich nicht mehr, wenn plötzlich die Kredite 3, 6, 4, 2 Prozent kosten. Und wenn deren Zinsbindung fällt und die dann plötzlich andere Zinsen zahlen müssen, dann werden die das natürlich auch wieder noch den Mietern aufhalsen.
Genau und dieses Problem war mir auch gar nicht bewusst, weil ich ging eigentlich davon aus, naja in Deutschland hat man seinen Mietvertrag einmal unterschrieben und dann ist das halt die Miete. Nur es gibt ja auch beim Vermieten Inflationsausgleiche und so weiter. Oder eben gleich eine Mietanpassung, also dass man die...
Erzählt mir jetzt auch jemand aus Leipzig, dass es richtig schwierig geworden ist, noch andere Mietverträge zu bekommen. Also die sind fast alle jetzt flexibel.
Genau und Karin Lay stellt das mal als Sonderproblem, weil sie sich auskennt auf dem Gebiet für uns da.
Ein bundesweiter Mietenstopp wäre auch das beste Mittel gegen Inflation, denn die geht ja zu einem erheblichen Teil aufgestegene Wohnkosten zurück. Das bringt mich zu unserem zweiten Punkt. Indexmietverträge steigen automatisch mit der Inflation. Ein Plus von 10 Prozent, das kann sich doch kein Mensch leisten. Auch hier bei diesen Verträgen muss ein Mietenstopp gelten.
Indexmietverträge, wer es nicht weiß, da steht einfach drin. Der Mietpreis ändert sich mit der Indexmiete des Gebietes. Und wenn über welche Kostentreiber auch immer die Kosten hochgetrieben werden, dann ist die Miete da flexibel und dann wird sie einfach angepasst. Dann gibt es da Inflationsausgleiche und alles Mögliche.
Das ist dann wie im Supermarkt mit der Butter.
Genau, wie an der Tankstelle. Da schickt der Vermieter einfach einen Brief und sagt, ja, wird jetzt teurer, weil die Indexmiete steigt. Und ich kannte das nicht als flächendeckendes Problem, aber sie nennt hier mal eine ganz erschreckende Zahl.
Die Immobilienbranche wittert natürlich ihre Chance. Die Mietervereine berichten, dass bis zu 90 Prozent der neuen Mietverträge als Indexmietverträge abgeschlossen werden. Das darf nicht sein. Bei dieser Inflation müssen Indexmietverträge verboten werden.
Ja, es sind ganz viele Studenten dazu, wie es jetzt betroffen ist, die zum ersten Mal irgendwas mieten, das dann auch vielleicht nicht kennen, was das eigentlich bedeutet. Sagen, geht ja noch von der Miete und dann kommt das böse Erwachen. Also kommt jetzt ja gerade bei vielen. Die haben das mal vor einem Jahr unterschrieben, als die Zeit noch anders war.
Ja, 90 Prozent. Das sind immer so Sachen wie in Amerika auch. Die Babyboomer haben alle noch kostenlos studiert. Und zwei Generationen später gehst du mit 100.000 Dollar Schulden durch. Und diejenigen, die die demografische und damit auch demokratische Macht haben, kennen das Problem gar nicht, diese Art von Megaförschuldung mitzunehmen. Aber es brauchte nur eine Generation, um die alle komplett zu versauen. Also dass sie einfach ihr Leben lang mit diesen auch nicht durch Privatinsolvenz oder so weiter abschüttelbaren finanziellen Problemen haben. Und das scheint sich hier gerade einzuschleichen in Deutschland, dass wir zu Indexmietverträgen als flächendeckend 90 Prozent, hat sie gesagt. Das ist natürlich dramatisch, wenn einfach innerhalb, also sagen wir mal, wenn Mietverträge, die innerhalb der letzten zehn Jahre abgeschlossen worden sind, plötzlich alles Indexmietverträge sind.
Aber du siehst auch, wie der mediale Diskurs wieder ist. Ich bin ja der Letzte, der sagen würde, vergesst die Autofahrer und ist gut, dass Benzin teuer ist. Aber da wird ja jede Preissteigerung mit 100 Berichten und Sondersendungen bedacht. Und hier passiert einfach flächendeckend in Deutschland eine Bindung vertraglich, die Menschen ruinieren wird. Denn beim Auto habe ich noch eine gewisse Flexibilität. Aber ich kann ja nicht sagen, ach ja, dann ziehe ich halt aus, ist jetzt wieder zu teuer geworden. Also man ist einfach da in einem absoluten Knebelvertragsverhältnis drin.
Ja, vor allem, sie hat jetzt hier Rostock und so genannt als Städte mit 13 Prozent Wohnkosteninflation Jahr auf Jahr.
Ja, auch mal gut, solche Städte zu hören. Weil viele ja immer glauben, das ist nur eine Frage von Berlin und München.
Genau, es ist eben nicht nur Frankfurt, Stuttgart und so. Und wenn man sich das mal überlegt, ich habe ja im Buch auch zitiert, dass die Wohnkosteninflation der letzten zehn Jahre im Durchschnitt über zehn Prozent lag. In diesen zehn Jahren fanden drei Bundestagswahlen statt, 2013, 2017 und jetzt die aktuelle. Und das ist kein Thema, nie. Es ist wirklich ganz, ganz, ganz erstaunlich. Dann geht es hier so ein bisschen ins Detail, da wo es dann auch tagesaktuell drückt.
Und drittens, Borministerin Galwitz sagte in den Medien mehrfach, das Kündigungsrecht müsse geändert werden. Das finde ich nämlich auch. Schon seit Jahren ist es ein Problem, dass Mieterinnen, die Mietschulden haben, aber sie rechtzeitig begleichen, trotzdem ordentlich gekündigt werden kann. Wir sind hier als Linke mehrfach mit Anträgen dagegen gescheitert. Aber jetzt, angesichts dieser Krise, ist das ein wirkliches Pulverfass.
Also, man ist im Verzug, weil man sich doch das Geld erstmal noch leihen muss für die nächste Monatsmiete. Man bezahlt sie dann aber doch und hat damit aber erwürgt oder verwürgt, in einem nicht kündbaren Mietverhältnis zu sein. Sondern dann kann der Vermieter einfach sagen, ja du warst ja einmal im Verzug, es ist zwar alles ausgeglichen, aber damit bist du jetzt vogelfreier. Und das sind natürlich auch alles solche Sitten, die sagen so langsam, es ist nicht gut. Im Finale legt sie nochmal den Finger an ein paar Wunden und nennt dann auch nochmal ihren Buchtitel.
Nun habe ich keinen Zweifel daran, dass die FDP fest an der Seite der Immobilielobby steht. Ich meine eine Mini-Mietrechtsreform, wie sie im Koalitionsvertrag steht, in weiter Sicht. Jetzt blockieren sie auch noch eine gerechtere Verteilung des CO2-Preises. Aber auch bei dem, wo die SPD zuständig ist, beim Vorkaufsrecht, geht es nicht voran. Ich frage mich deswegen, warum sich SPD und Grüne immer wieder von der FDP die Hosenträger langziehen lassen. Meine Damen und Herren, das ist unser Krisenpaket Miete.
Ich bitte um Zustimmung, das Vonopoly muss beendet werden.
Und übrigens, das Vonopoly muss beendet werden. Sehr gut.
So muss man es machen.
Jetzt reagiert die SPD. Wir hören die Berichterstatterin zum Thema Sander Martens. Also sie ist zuständig, um dieses Thema in der Regierungspartei, in der Kanzlerpartei SPD voranzutreiben.
Greif ich heute danken, die Chance auf, die uns die Linke mit ihren drei Anträgen zum Thema Miete bietet. Vieles davon und noch mehr wird unser Gesetzesentwurf behandeln, denn wir demnächst hier im Plenum debattieren werden. Und das auch genau mit dem Ziel, dass sie mit ihren Anträgen anstreben, Mieterinnen und Mieter vor den immer weiter steigenden Mieten und vor dem Verlust ihrer Wohnung zu schützen. Was die Mieterinnen und Mieter aber heute noch mehr umtreibt.
Und das finde ich schon so ein bisschen perfide, was jetzt kommt. Denn man kann jetzt sagen, ok, ein bisschen wenig Zugkraft und so weiter, aber sie hat zuerst gesagt, wir sehen das ja auch, wir wollen das ja so machen und demnächst kommt das auch. Jetzt kommt aber ihr kleines Aber.
Und belastet als steigende Kaltmieten sind die explodierenden Betriebskosten für Heizung und Warmwasser. Die einen müssen jetzt schon höhere Abschläge zahlen, die sich verdoppelt oder verdreifacht haben. Die anderen haben Angst vor hohen Nachzahlungen, die selbst für eine Mittelstandsfamilie nicht mehr zu wucken sind.
Ja, das ist, das fehlt eigentlich nur noch der Satz, und das ist allein Putins Schuld. Da braucht man gar nicht mehr drüber reden, da haben wir nichts mehr mit zu tun.
Ja, wir haben es tatsächlich beim Wohnen mit zwei Problemen zu tun. Die Grundkosten, erstmal grundsätzlich, Quadratmeterpreise, Bodenpreise und so weiter, Grundsteuer, Scheiß, der da alles gemacht wurde, und die Nebenkosten jetzt eben auch. Und sie versucht das hier gegeneinander aufzuspielen.
Also es könnte man, jetzt müssen man jetzt das eine Mal sich kümmern um das, dass das jetzt Priorität so hat, sei das es ist ja am Ende eine Rechnung, es ist ja eine Summe, es ist mir egal, wo es günstiger wird.
Genau, ihre Argumentation war gerade, die Mieter in Deutschland haben gerade gar keinen Kopf für ihre Grundkosten, weil sie ja mit den Nebenkosten so viel zu tun haben. Das ist natürlich total bescheuert, so was zu sagen. Das begegnet einem aber immer wieder. Das ist ja so ein ganz beliebtes Modell in der Politik, wie auch bei Corona und so weiter, dass Detlef Schiele eben sagt, ja, uns fehlen ja ganz schön viele Arbeitskräfte. Und dann ist aber der Allgemeine Tee noch, so eine Demografie können wir uns gerade nicht kümmern, wir haben mit Corona alle Hände vorzutun und so. Ja, und man kann nur ein Thema abbehandeln, alles andere wird so irgendwie abgeschoben.
Und das ist natürlich die Erklärung dafür, wir hatten Bundestagswahlen ohne Ende, wir hatten diese Mietsteigerungen, das passiert dann nicht, weil dann immer gerade irgendein anderes Thema pressiert.
Ja, genau, man steht sich da gegenseitig im Weg. Und das ist ja das Tolle an Institutionen, dass sie eigentlich mehrere Themen parallel behandeln können, aber nicht auf öffentlicher Bühne. Auch aus der Regierungsriege, Chanan Bayram, wir kennen sie sehr engagiert, die Grüne.
Sie ist doch auch die Mietenexpertin schlechthin, die bei Tilo damals saß und das mal alles gesagt hat, wie furchtbar das zum Beispiel auch mit Gewerbemieten ist, weil da gibt es ja noch mehr Flexibilität bei den Preissteigerungen.
Und entsprechend vehement kommt sie hier auch. Es klingt fast die Opposition. Und sie wird ein Thema nennen, das sie auch schon viel bei Karin Lay und über das wir auch schon sprachen. Wir haben über Münster und Ulm und so weiter gesprochen. Wir hören den Clip jetzt einfach nur, um nochmal aus dem Munde einer Fraktionsmitgliederin, einer Regierungspartei zu hören, wie die allerwichtigsten Themen einfach liegen bleiben.
Ein weiteres Instrument, das gerade in meinem Wahlkreis, in Friedrichshain-Kreuzberg und Prenzlauer Berg Ost eine große Rolle spielt, ist das Vorkaufsrecht. Und da will ich ganz, ganz, ganz dringend sagen, wir brauchen das unbedingt. Wir können als Staat nicht auf das Vorkaufsrecht verzichten, meine Damen und Herren, und wir werden als grüne Fraktion auf allen Ebenen dafür kämpfen. Darauf soll sich jeder einstellen, meine Damen und Herren.
Aber wem sagt sie es?
Das fragt man sich, ja.
Also das Vorkaufsrecht, dass die Kommune einfach sagen kann, du verkaufst dein Grundstück, wir sind der einzige Käufer für dich.
Na die Antwort ist natürlich, dass Bayram da so eine ziemlich solitäre Stellung in der Partei hat.
Sie ist Opposition.
Sie sagt das jetzt ihrer Partei, guck mal, da haben wir doch mal damals drüber geredet, ihr hattet mir doch auch mal da so ein paar Zusagen gemacht. Dafür hält sie die Rede, ja.
So und dann, wir gucken jetzt noch zwei Clips aus der Debatte von der AfD. Machen wir üblicherweise nicht, eine Partei des Hasses braucht man hier nicht.
Besonders lustig ist das.
Aber ich dachte irgendwie, das ist so schräg, so bekloppt. Wir hören uns das an. Also wir haben es mit einem Thema zu tun, von dem 40-50 Prozent der Deutschen so langsam sagen, das bricht mir irgendwie das Genick.
Auch die Bio-Deutschen sind betroffen.
Auch die Bio-Deutschen sind betroffen. Es raubt ihnen die Lebensqualität, die Perspektive und so weiter. Wohnen ist einfach scheiße teuer Deutschland. Und jetzt Auftritt AfD.
Nächster Redner ist der Kollege Ruhig, Backcamp AfD-Fraktion.
Herr Präsident, Herr Präsident, meine Damen und Herren. In der Literaturwissenschaft bezeichnet man eine immer wiederkehrende Erzählung als Topos. Ein Topos ist ein festgefügtes, leicht wieder zu erkennenes Muster, eine vertraute Geschichte. Die böse Stiefmutter, die trügerische Ruhe oder der traurige Plauen. So vor ein paar Tagen ein Beitrag in der FAZ. In linken Gedankenwelten nennt sich dieser Topos heilsbringender Mietendeckel. Konkret wünscht sich Die Linke hier und heute einen solchen Mietenstopp für die nächsten sechs Jahre. Das Problem daran ist, dieser formellinke Wunsch widerspricht dem Grundgesetz der Ökonomie.
Ich finde das so schräg, dass die AfD, deren Lieblingsargument ja ist, jetzt kommen Die Linken wieder mit ihrem Veggie-Day, mit ihrem Woken-Kram, mit was weiß ich für Forderungen, jetzt muss ich auch noch irgendwelche Personalpronomen lernen. Haben wir nicht echte Probleme? Genau. Wenn jetzt sagt der Bundestag, ey Leute, wir haben jetzt mal echte Probleme, Wohnkosten. Was macht die AfD? Kommt ihr mit, ein Top-House in der Literaturwissenschaft ist...
Und zitiert das aber auch nur aus der FAZ, also er weiß es nicht immer selbst. Das finde ich aber auch ein bisschen...
Es ist so schräg.
Es hat sich aber in Künstlerschale umgebunden.
Ja, es ist ein ganz edler Auftritt. Und er begrüßt den Président auch auf französisch wahrscheinlich oder wie auch immer er sich hier nochmal kulturell aneignen wollte, wo er nicht ist, sondern sich so ein bisschen wegtransferiert hat.
Genau, da würde sich auch jeder Franzose natürlich Naserumpfen wegdrehen.
Und jetzt hat er ja gesagt, die Diskussion erübrigt sich, weil sie widerspricht den Grundgesetzen der Ökonomie. Jetzt fragen wir uns, welches ist denn das Grundgesetz der Ökonomie? Erfüllt es uns Gott sei Dank.
Und das ist ganz einfach. Der Wert einer Sache bestimmt sich aus Angebot und Nachfrage. Wer versucht, seine schmutzigen Socken im Internet zu verkaufen, wird feststellen, dass deren Wert gegen Null tendiert. Sozialisten haben häufig Schwierigkeiten, dieses Gesetz von Angebot und Nachfrage zu verstehen.
Also nach meiner Beschäftigung mit OnlyFans kann ich ja sagen, ich glaube, gebrauchte Socken im Internet zu verkaufen, scheint sehr lukrativ zu sein. Man liest da zahlen, da wird es einem schwindlig.
Also ich komme mir in der Alten Republik auf diesen George Frank, oder wie heißt er, zu sprechen, der vor 150 Jahren, nachdem er sich den wilden Westen angeschaut hat und alle im Goldrausch und so weiter fährt er an die Ostküste und denkt, da ist ja schon die neue Zivilisation angekommen, man fährt also nach New York, New Amsterdam und so, guckt sich das an und stellt fest, krass, so viel Elend habe ich ja noch nie gesehen, stellt sich raus, ja, sind die Wohnkosten. Die Wohnkosten sind genauso hoch, wie die Leute es gerade noch bezahlen können, weil sie müssen ja irgendwo schlafen. Also die 8 Stunden Pritsche, 2 qm, brauchen sie. Und sein Grundgesetz der Ökonomie, Angebot und Nachfrage, wenn man das gewähren lässt, kann man sagen, ja, dann wird die Nachfrage den Preis bestimmen, in Sachen Wohnen, damit sind aber auf allen anderen Gebieten ist das Grundgesetz dann aufgehoben. In der Versorgung mit Nahrungsmitteln, im kulturellen Betrieb, in der Mobilität. Also dann schlägt einfach die eine Nachfrage nach, einen Schlafplatz brauche ich, weil um diese biologische Notwendigkeit komme ich nicht herum, hebt dann alle anderen auf. Und da sieht man so ein bisschen, wie sich die AfD das so vorstellt. Welche Reduktionen auf die einfachsten Biologismen da so drinstecken, das regeln wir mal über die Nachfrage. Und sei es, dass alles andere dann nur noch Hölle ist. Hauptsache, dieses Grundgesetz der Ökonomie wird da irgendwie durchgepeitscht.
Und so hat es Abden Sinclair beschrieben. Ich hatte mit Ole jetzt im Wohlstand für alle über den Roman gesprochen in der Dschungel. Da geht es um die Schlachthöfe von Chicago und wie dann alle Arbeiter auch in solche Wohnmodelle gesteckt werden bzw. Hauskredite und so weiter aufgequatscht bekommen, die sie eigentlich gar nicht richtig zahlen können oder nur dann, wenn sie alles andere, was das Leben auch noch ausmachen könnte, völlig aufgeben und quasi sich ruinieren dafür, dass sie einen Schlafplatz haben. Und das ist die Konstellation, die Abden Sinclair beschreibt und die hier auch Herrn Beckamp offenbar vorschwebt.
Genau, das ist einfach ein ganz großes Drama, was wir hier sehen. Wir überspringen einen kleinen Clip zum Thema noch nie so wenig Wohnungen, Bauprojekte genehmigt wie jetzt gerade und zwar wegen Kostengründen. Die Leute springen wieder ab. Man plant natürlich in Zeiten, in denen man 1, 2 Prozent zinsen und dann hat man den aber nicht festgezurrt und weiß, das gilt nur für zehn Jahre und danach wird der Zinspreis neu ermittelt und dann drohen aber plötzlich 6 Prozent und dann weiß man, das macht ja mein Kredit doppelt so teuer. Genau, also das ist einfach nicht zu machen.
Man kann dann rechnen einfach, dass der Kredit dann 100.000, 150.000 Euro mehr kostet bei einem Einfamilienhaus, also das ist so verrückt und dass das auch nicht thematisiert wird, dass wirklich nicht noch irgendjemand traut zu schreiben endlich gibt's auf dem Sparbuch mal wieder Zinsen, dass das wirklich noch irgendjemand glaubt. Das muss doch auch ein jeder, der das in den Computer tippt, der muss doch auch in irgendwelchen Wohnverhältnissen nehmen. Der kann doch nicht da sitzen und sagen, ach das ist aber schön, dass ich jetzt für meine 10.000 Euro auf dem Sparbuch zweieinhalb Prozent Zinsen bekomme und dass diese Niedrigzinspolitik eine Verarmungspolitik jetzt bedeutet, dass das nicht gesehen wird. Also ich bin da wirklich tot. Also das müsste eigentlich der große Angriffspunkt sein.
Genau, findet aber alles nicht statt. Wir bleiben noch kurz im Bundestag. Man hat über die Rente gesprochen. Das sind alles so diese Tagesordnungspunkte. Wir haben eine Aussprache von 26 Minuten oder mal 90 Minuten vereinbart. Dann reihen sich halt so Beiträge aneinander oder werden zu Protokoll gegeben. Rente wurde am 22.10. thematisiert. Und ich sage ausdrücklich, bevor wir jetzt diesen Clip hören, 21.55 Uhr. Der Plenarsaal ist entsprechend leer. Es ist wenig los. Das Thema ist gigantisch. Ein Drittel des Bundeshaushalts sind Rentenzahlungen und so. Und nachdem man sich einfach nur im Fernsehen über die Rente informiert, gar nichts erfährt. Wir haben ja diese kleine Reportage, wo Johannes Vogel von der FDP noch mal irgendeinem jungen Journalisten sagt, übrigens, das ist ein Umlagesystem. Also die einfachste Information überhaupt. Da gibt es gar keine Reserve oder so weiter. Da war dann schon ein mega Aufhänger und so. Stellt sich raus, im Plenum des Bundestages geht es auch nicht viel tiefer. Man erklärt sich einfach noch mal 21.55 Uhr, wie das Rentensystem so eigentlich funktioniert.
Sie wissen ja alle, die Rentenversicherung ist eine umlagefinanzierte Versicherung. Das macht sie volkswirtschaftlich sinnvoll und stabil. Deswegen muss aber auch der Geldfluss gut organisiert sein, denn das, was eingezahlt wird, wird auch sofort wieder ausgezahlt. Darum braucht es einen Liquiditätspuffer, eben diese Nachhaltigkeitsrücklage, der am besten wie jetzt sehr gut gefüllt ist. Aber wenn auch aufgrund des demografischen Wandels und der Veränderung eines Tages im Laufe der Zwanzigerjahre auf den Mindestwert zugesteuert werden muss, dann sollte auch das Kissen so dick sein oder der Puffer so groß sein, dass man in der Rentenversicherung nicht auf Liquiditätshilfen des Bundes angewiesen ist. Um fünf vor zehn kann man noch mal so schön technisch alles erklären.
Das war schön, vielen Dank.
Das ist Slapstick, oh der Ende.
Den habe ich noch nie vorher gesehen, Markus Kurth von den Grünen. Also, ja schön, dass wir das noch mal gesehen haben. Dann wollen wir mal gucken, wie das Kissen dicker wird, obwohl es ja so ganz nebenbei noch diesen demografischen Wandel zu geben scheint.
Ja, kann ja dann irgendwas beruhen und so. Der Antrag hier lautet Festschreibung einer 0, 4 Monats Mieten-Renten-Reserve in Umlageverfahren, was also bedeutet, statt 0, 2 Monats, also das wäre dann eine Woche, 0, 2 Monate sind ja ungefähr so eine Woche, grob ein bisschen weniger als eine Woche, fünf Tage oder so, dass also wenn am Monatsanfang die Gehälter ausgezahlt werden, also auch abgezweigt wird in die Rentenkassen, dass dann noch eine Woche Zeit ist, bis die Rentner das ausgezahlt bekommen. Also nicht viel Puffer. Der Antrag lautet hier von den Linken, glaube ich, vorgetragen, wir möchten gar 0, 4 Monats Mieten, also dass zwei Wochen sind. Keine Ahnung, was das für einen Unterschied macht. Es ist total absurd. Er hat jetzt eben festgestellt, es sind ja gerade 1, 6 Monats Renten-Puffer, also ungefähr sechs Wochen. Um sowas redet man da, streitet da und dann fällt halt noch mal so die grundsätzliche Erklärung, wie das Rentensystem funktioniert in Deutschland ab. Und es wird dann auch nicht, es ist erschreckend, muss man so sagen. Denn ich habe ja auch fürs Buch oder für den einen Text im Blättern und so mal alle Rentenkonzepte, die zur Wahl standen bei der letzten Bundestagswahl, gelesen. Und dieser Streit hier zwischen einer AfD-Frau, die der linken Antragstellerin vorwirft, ja gar kein Rentenkonzept zu haben, ist leider wahr. Weder die AfD noch die Linken haben ein Konzept. Und das einzige, was sie machen können, ist im Bundestag sich das vorwerfen.
Aber Herr Birkwald, auch Sie haben der Rente mit diesem Antrag keinen Gefallen getan. Denn es stellt sich ja wirklich die Frage, wie ausgerechnet die Linke, die bis heute zum Thema Rente kein einziges sinnvolles Konzept entwickeln kann, sich ausgerechnet an einem technischen Detail abarbeitet, das sicher nicht unwichtig ist, aber mit Sicherheit auch kein Instrument um, wie Sie meinten, damit die Stabilität der Rentenversicherung zu erhöhen.
Ja, da ist es schon 21.57 Uhr, aber die Stimmung ist gut. Jetzt kommt die Antwort der Linken.
Das Wort hat Matthias W. Birkwald für die Fraktion Die Linke.
Sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin, meine Damen und Herren, hier ist unser Rentenkonzept, 2.15, erste Fassung, 2.17, zweite Fassung. Die haben nur 100 Zeilen und da steht nichts Anständiges drin.
Das war wirklich Fake News.
Die Linke ist im Bundestag die Vorkämpferin für eine gute Rente in Ost und West.
Ja, ein Rentenkonzept ist was anderes als eine Wunschliste. Und die Linken haben leider nur eine Wunschliste. Die wünschen sich halt, dass sie viel, viel Rente kriegen. Aber da wird konzeptionell nichts aufgegriffen. Weder die Demografie, noch die volkswirtschaftlichen Grundlagen, noch sonst irgendwas. In der Ansicht, hier sind lauter Blinde im Bundestag, die sich hier solche Streitereien 10 Uhr abends irgendwie liefern. Völlig sinnlos. Na ja, eine kleine Sache können wir uns noch anschauen. Es gab ein neues Buch, es heißt Die Akte Scholz.
Wie viele Bücher gibt es eigentlich jetzt zum Thema Scholz und Comics?
Genau, es geht so ein bisschen. Also es ist der Warburg-Skandal, dieser Hamburger Bank. Bei der man ja immer noch rätselt, wie viele Bücher es gibt. Ich fand es aber in dem Falle ein bisschen instruktiv. Die Redner wissen, dass Cum-Ex und so weiter als komplizierte Gemengelage gilt. Und man deswegen ja es so ein bisschen runterbricht, ein bisschen illustrativ macht und so weiter. Und wir beginnen mal bei Matthias Mittelberg von der CDU.
Herr Scholz verweist ja immer darauf, ihr könnt mir das bis ins letzte noch nicht nachweisen. Aber de facto sind schon die äußeren Umstände aussagekräftig genug. Er sagt, ich wollte mich nicht einmischen. Dann führt man vielleicht mit den Beteiligten einmal ein Gespräch und erklärt ihnen, ich will, ich kann, ich darf mich nicht einmischen, alles in Ordnung. Was aber stattgefunden hat, war, dass er sich dreimal mit den Chefs der Warburg Bank in seinem Amtszimmer, in seinem Büro getroffen hat, um ihn, ich weiß nicht, wie begriffsstutzig diese Banker waren, um ihm dreimal, jeweils eine Stunde lang zu erklären, dass er sich nicht einmischen will und dem Chefbänker Olearius hat Olaf Scholz dann noch von sich aus hinterhertelefoniert, um ihm wahrscheinlich noch mal zu versichern. Möglicherweise hatten die Banker es immer noch nicht verstanden nach diesen Gesprächen, dass er sich nicht einmischen will. Dann hat er den einen noch mal angerufen, um ihm noch mal zu versichern, ich will mich nicht einmischen. Und zur Erhärtung seiner Absicht hat er dann noch die Empfehlung, ausgesprochen, ich kenne noch jemanden anderen, der sich auch nicht einmischen will, nämlich den Herrn Schentscher. Der ist hier Finanzsenator. Und weil ich so genau weiß, dass der sich auch nicht einmischen will, gebe ich euch den Tipp, schickt mal eure Unterlagen an den Herrn Schentscher. Dann könnt ihr sicher sein, dass es keinerlei Einmischung gibt.
Das ist doch mal eine rhetorisch gute Rede. Da kann man doch mal glücklich sein, dass es so einen Bundestag gibt und wirklich mal jemand verstanden hat, wie das da funktioniert. Matthias Mittelberg, CDU, CSU, muss man sich mal merken, hat rhetorisches Talent.
Ich finde auch, das war ganz gut erklärt. Jetzt kommt Michael Schrodi, der den Karren wieder aus dem Dreck ziehen muss.
Das wäre auch schlimm, wenn man da jetzt so ran muss.
Ganz weit in der Hinterbank geguckt, ob noch jemand 14.50 Uhr da mal kurz gegenhalten kann. Es ist die gleiche rhetorische Figur, wie wir sie eben schon bei der SPD gesehen haben.
Sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin, meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren! Gestern hat die Ampelkoalition in einer Aktuellen Stunde darüber gesprochen, wie wir die Gaspreisbremse jetzt implementieren, wie wir Menschen in dieser Situation schützen. Heute hat die CDU CSU eine Aktuelle Stunde aufgesetzt, in der sie sich mit einem Buch beschäftigt, in dem alte Unterstellungen neu aufgewärmt werden. Deutlich ist nicht zu zeigen, welche Prioritäten die einzelnen Fraktionen setzen.
An all dem anderen ist ja wie gesagt Putin schuld, deswegen können wir eigentlich über gar nichts sprechen mehr.
Der SPD-Mann wirft jetzt der CDU vor, er hier wieder, aber die Leute interessieren sich jetzt für die Krise.
Auch wie er Buch sagt.
So ein Buch schon wieder und so. So und jetzt kommt aber ein echter Knaller, nämlich Christian Görke von der Linke. Also, Middelberg sagt, es geht hier um Cum-Ex und der gerade regierende Kanzler hat da ganz schön viel Dreck am Stecken. Vielleicht sollten wir da noch mal ein bisschen nachgrafen. Dann sagt die SPD, ne, wir haben gerade ernsthafte Probleme. Die Leute wissen nicht, wie sie ihre Gasrechnung bezahlen sollen. Und jetzt kommt der Vorschlag der Linken.
Ich gehe in den Supermarkt, gebe eine Bierflasche ab, nehme einen Pfandbogen, lege ihn dann auf den Kopierer und lasse dann mit meinen Freunden diesen ganz häufig mir an der Kasse ausbezahlen. Mit dem Unterschied, dass die Supermarktkasse das Finanzamt ist und dass es bei Cum-Ex nicht um den Flaschenpfand geht, sondern um Milliarden. Im Ergebnis der größte Steuerbetrug in der Nachkriegsgeschichte. Mit diesen dubiosen Finanzgeschäften haben Banken, Großinvestoren, den deutschen Staat um sage und schreibe 35, 9 Milliarden Euro betrogen. Mit diesem Geld, meine Damen und Herren, könnte man zum Beispiel in diesem Winter jeden privaten Haushalt die Gasrechnung übernehmen.
Genial, das ist wirklich sehr, sehr gut. Vielleicht sollte man immer Bundestagsdebatten ein Buch zu Grunde legen, so ein bisschen wie im Salon. Dann müssen die reden, dann haben sie es gelesen und dann machen sie sich mal ein paar Gedanken und da kommt richtig gutes raus.
Wir hätten gar keine Krise, wenn Sachen Gas. Putin kann machen, was er will. Wir in Deutschland sind resilient. Wir haben nämlich so viel Steuern gezahlt vorher als Bürger, die uns nicht gestohlen wurden von irgendwelchen Bankern, die da Kanzler noch rausgehauen hat, dass wir einfach alle Gasrechnungen den ganzen Winter hätten bezahlen können. Also Cum Ex wichtet die ganzen Gasprobleme auf, die wir gerade haben. Alle Nebenkosten, die die Deutschen so haben. Dann könnte man sich auch wieder um die eigentlichen Mietkosten kümmern, weil und die Nebenkosten, wer sie hätte, hätten sie sich hier kümmern können. Also in der Ansicht Cum Ex bitte nochmal neu beobachten unter dieser Maßgabe. Und als wäre das alles nicht genug Slapstick in dieser Aktuellen Stunde, verkündet jetzt Kupicki als derjenige, der die Sitzung leitet, ein kleines Abstimmungsergebnis.
Und meine Damen und Herren der SPD, sorgen Sie dafür, dass sich Ihr Bundeskanzler erinnert und dass er sich ehrlich macht. Und vor allen Dingen, dass er sich der Befragung im Finanzausschuss endlich stellt. Es wäre nach der Veröffentlichung des GURES die Akte Scholz, glaube ich, ganz gut beraten.
Vielen Dank. Vielen Dank, Herr Kollege Görke. Bevor ich dem Kollegen Herrbrems das Wort erteile, unterbreche ich kurz die Aktuelle Stunde um Sie. Unter Tagesordnungspunkt 17 a. Über das Ergebnis der namentlichen Abstimmung über die Beschlussempfehlung des Ausschusses für Klimaschutz und Energie. Zu dem Antrag der Abgeordneten Amira Mohamed Ali, Dr. Gesine Lötsch, Gülkay Akbulut, weitere Abgeordnete und sich der Fraktion Die Linke, Strom- und Gasperren verbieten, Drucksachen 26, 86 und 28, 38, 53 zu unterrichten. Abgegebene Stimmkarten, 643. Mit Ja haben gestimmt, 603. Mit Nein haben gestimmt, 37. Enteiltungen 3. Damit ist die Beschlussempfehlung angenommen. Wir kehren nun zurück zur Aktuellen Stunde. Das Wort hat der Kollege Markus Herbrand, FDP-Fraktion.
Also der Bundestag nimmt eine Beschlussempfehlung der Regierung an, gegen den Vorschlag der Linken zu stimmen, Gasperren zu verbieten, also jemandem das Gas abzuklemmen, nur weil er gerade die Rechnung nicht bezahlen kann, während sie gerade Cum-Ex verhandeln und die linken Antragsteller darauf hinweisen, dass man ja mit dem Cum-Ex-Schaden alle Gasrechnung bezahlen könnte.
Und die SPD darauf hinweisen, dass man doch ganz andere Probleme hätte, nämlich nicht Cum-Ex, sondern Gaspreise.
Warum finden wir sowas nicht 20.00 Uhr in der Tagesschau, frage ich mich. Das ist doch besser, wenn wir eine Vorlage gar nicht machen.
Das ist eigentlich die Sendung, die man machen muss. Also nicht nur Tagesschau, sondern das müsste eigentlich abends die Sendung im Fernsehen sein, aber dafür sind wir ja dann da.
Richtig, genau. Aber es ist schade, dass Oma Erna es mitbekommt. Und wir gucken uns auch noch hier einen Artikel an.
Das ist jetzt auch für mich, der ich ja doch ein bisschen im Nachrichtenfluss auf bin. Alles sehr neu, also sehr komplett neues Material. Es hat ja alles stattgefunden, aber ich habe nichts davon gesehen.
Ja, und das ist besonders dramatisch, weil ja auf der Bundestagsseite, die ist ja perfekt redaktionell betreut. Du hast ja zu jeder einzelnen Debatte immer gleich fünf Absätze Text, wo du dir wirklich kurz einen Überblick verschaffen kannst, was wurde denn da gesagt und so. Eigentlich müsste man es wie eine Agenturmeldung einfach nur übernehmen. Na gut, es findet da nicht statt. Wir hören uns nochmal die Partei des Hasses an. Häufig ist ja so, dass die AfD so kleine YouTube-Clips produziert, in denen du hast ja diesen Alles-Weitel-Clip gespielt, wo einfach nur so Sachen gesagt wird, wo man so sich denken kann, ja stimmt irgendwie, da hat sie recht, keine Ahnung. Ich finde jetzt erstmal keinen Widerspruch. Und erst im Nachgang muss man sich dann die Frage stellen, ja aber warum müssen wir deswegen jetzt Menschen hassen und so? Und der Albrecht Glaser dachte sich, nö ich will mal richtig AfD sein. Ich komme jetzt nicht nur mit den Sachen, die allen anschlussfähig sind, sondern ich pack dann einfach mal alles mit rein.
Und wir reden immer noch von der Cum-Ex-Sitzung.
Genau, es ist immer noch diese Aktuelle Stunde, Cum-Ex und Akte Scholz und so. Und Albrecht Glaser dachte sich, ich mach nochmal kurz All-in-AfD-Hass.
Der tüchtige Beamte, der Schaden vom Land abwenden wollte, wurde nach der Amtsübernahme von Scholz in Berlin überraschend früh portioniert. Und die Steuerforderung in Höhe von 47 Millionen fiel in die Ferriero. Das ist also kein haltloses Schauermärchen, sondern beschreibt, meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren, die Lage der Nation. Genauso verhält es sich mit der inneren Sicherheit, mit dem Schutz vor Massenzuwanderung, der daraus resultierten Lage am Wohnungsmarkt, den Staatsfinanzen, dem Bildungssystem, der Energieversorgung, dem Beutesystem im öffentlichen Dienst, entgegen dem Leistungsprinzip nach Artikel 33, insbesondere auch in der Justiz und mit der notleidenden Meinungsfreiheit.
Und auch das noch, ja.
Einfach Topf auf, alles rein, einmal umrühren, fertig ist die AfD so. Der Bundestag hat dann noch...
Aber dieser heilige Ernst, mit dem es vorgetragen hat, das finde ich schon beeindruckend, dass er das noch so hinbekommt.
Er hat ja in Hessen, glaube ich, eine große Rolle gespielt damals. Aber wir wissen ja, wie es in Frankfurt gerade zugeht hier.
Ja, ist aber auch eine komische Kombination. Also er hat ein Halsduch, also nicht Krawattenschal, aber so ähnlich, im Hemd drin. Hat aber dann eine andere Farbe gewählt für das Einstecktuch. Und das beißt sich doch, meines Erachtens.
Das sind vier Klamotten-Teile und vier Farben. Das ist ein bisschen...
Das ist ein bisschen wirr.
Selbst mein nicht mehr ganz so leinhartes Auge ist...
Also da kann man auch sehen, auch da klappt wieder alles nicht. Wie bei Cum-Ex schon.
Genau, wenn schon Schieflage, dann überall. Der Bundestag hat auch darüber gesprochen, wie man den Alleinerziehenden hilft und den Studierenden. Können wir aber nachher gucken, ob wir da noch Zeit für haben. Denn China.
In China dauern Amtszeiten in der Regel ein bisschen länger als aktuell in Großbritannien. Wir sind gar nicht mehr dazu gekommen, Distrasse zu verabschieden. Wir haben schon einen neuen Premier, Dieter Hatz hatte, glaube ich, am zweiten Tag nach seinem Amtsantritt getitelt, noch immer im Amt. Deswegen wollen wir uns erst mit Großbritannien wieder beschäftigen, wenn da vielleicht ein bisschen ruhiger. Ich würde immer sagen, so sechs Wochen gehen wir jetzt jedem. Und danach wird es wieder interessant zu betrachten.
Wird sicherlich länger bleiben.
Vorher will man den Namen auch gar nicht schon lernen. Ja, wir blicken nach China. Da können wir uns auf jeden Fall auf viele Jahre mit Präsident Xi einstellen. Denn natürlich ist er wieder gewählt worden, in Anführungszeichen. Und er hat jetzt seine Amtszeit damit dann verlängert. Also länger als es eigentlich zugestanden ist. Und das heißt jetzt eigentlich Xi auf ewig. Beziehungsweise solange er lebt, werden wir ihn wahrscheinlich am Amt. Nein, aber er hat es so jetzt gefestigt, dass er sicherlich alles dafür tun wird, dass es wieder so kommt. Also wenn man so Politologen hört, dann sagen die immer so, ja, das wird ja dann so wahrscheinlich bis 2037 gehen oder solche Zahlen. Aber das sind jetzt wirklich die Perspektiven. Klar, es wird immer über dieses Büro. Ich hatte mir auch so eine Grafik hier mal angesehen, wie das eigentlich aufgebaut ist. Also es gibt ja dieses Politbüro.
Genau, das befindet ja am Ende darüber, oder?
Das dann befindet, also das sind sieben Leute, die dann alle ihm nahestehen. Und dann gibt es, also das ist das Standing Committee, das Ständige. Und dann gibt es darunter das Politbüro. Aber eigentlich wird das zentral, also er ist der Generalsekretär. Und dann gibt es das Politbüro mit den sieben Leuten. Und die hat ja quasi alle auf Linie. Und damit ist dann alles andere nur so ein Abnicken. Das heißt also, auch diesen Parteitag müssen wir uns natürlich als eine Show ansehen. Und nicht als eine, ein Ort der Debatte, wo man jetzt mal schaut, was ist wohl der richtige Weg und finden wir einen Kompromiss. Das stellt sich hier nicht. Wie kompromisslos Xi ist, war in seiner Rede doch sehr deutlich zu erfahren. Steigen wir mal ein, was er zu Zero Covid sagt.
In responding to the sudden outbreak of Covid-19, we put the people and their lives above all else and to nationally pursue our dynamic Zero Covid policy. In launching an all out people's war to stop the spread of the virus, we have protected the people's health and safety to the greatest extent possible and made tremendous encouraging achievements in both epidemic response and economic and social development.
Es gibt überhaupt keine Selbstkritik an dieser Zero Covid Strategie, sondern es ist auch klar, dass China bei dieser Zero Covid Strategie bleiben wird. Das heißt, sie haben zwar auch dieses Impfprogramm, aber es wird nicht irgendwas Neues importiert werden. Es wird nicht BioNTech oder sonst was kommen. Und grundsätzlich ist diese Zero Covid Strategie für Xi das Richtige und damit auch für die Partei das Richtige.
Sie hat gerade das chinesische Mandarin auf Englisch übersetzt. Ich übersetze mal auf Deutsch. Er hat vom Bürgerkrieg gegen das Virus gesprochen. All out people people's war oder was?
So und damit ist jeder, der sich dagegen stellt, auch dann Feind der Bürger. Also das ist ja eine interessante rhetorische Wendung. Er kommt auf das Thema Armut zu sprechen.
10 Jahre sind es seit dem Partei 18. Wir haben den Szenario des Communist-Parteis China erhebt.
Diese Armutsbekämpfung hat es ja tatsächlich gegeben. Und noch immer sind Wanderarbeiter natürlich in Armut, die auch existenziell ist. Aber es stimmt, hunderte Millionen wurden aus der Armut rausgehoben seit dann Nixon Mao, seit diesem Event, seit dieser Öffnung Chinas. Jetzt natürlich zu sagen, man geht diesen Weg weiter. Wir wissen, es gibt große wirtschaftliche Probleme jetzt schon in China. Sie hatten ja auch tatsächlich die Veröffentlichung der Wirtschaftszahlen verschoben. Sie kamen dann, fragt man sich auch, warum wurden die jetzt verschoben? Mussten dann noch irgendwas frisiert werden oder so? Das sind natürlich auch immer so Unterstellungen, die man sofort dann hat. Aber es ist definitiv ja so, dass durch demografischen Wandel und dadurch, dass es eine extreme Ungleichheit in der chinesischen Gesellschaft gibt, dieses Aufstiegsversprechen doch sehr jäh enden kann, beziehungsweise dann nur bedeutet, aus der existenziellen Armut herausgehoben zu sein und dann nicht mehr.
Genau, hier muss man eh diese Bekämpfung der Armut, also es war ja viel Wunschdenken in dieser Beschreibung dabei. Ja, die absolute Armut irgendeinem Lande irgendwie, selbst flächendeckend würde ich sagen, noch nicht überwunden, aber soweit kann er es irgendwie behaupten. Nur dieses kollektive Reichwerden, dass man eben nicht nur so in diesem FDP-Stile, wenn du fleißig arbeitest, kannst du dir Eigentum erwerben, also damit hast du Armut überwunden, sondern auch wenn du einen biografischen Bruch hast, wirst du aufgefangen von einem Sozialstaat, davon sind die ja ganz weit entfernt. Und es wird ihnen wirklich dieses Genick brechen, also dadurch, dass sie noch gar kein Rentensystem haben. Und jetzt aber so viele über diese Altersgrenze oben drüber rutschen, und Indien allein über die Bevölkerungsgröße so viel interessanter wird. Das aktuelle iPhone wird in Indien hergestellt. Soweit ist ja schon gekommen, dass Foxconn da genauso große Einrichtungen hat. Also das sind nochmal 10 Jahre, die China da richtig durchhalten muss, um sich so ein soziales Netz irgendwie aufzubauen. Um diesen Reichtum oder dieses nicht mehr arm sein wirklich zu konservieren, strukturell festzuschreiben.
Aber ich denke, durchhalten ist das richtige Wort. Also man geht hier schon vor einer enormen Zähigkeit aus. Also wir würden ja auch nicht durchhalten bei so einer Zero-Covid-Strategie. Also da würden wahrscheinlich dann auch die, die jetzt noch sagen, Team Vorsicht, würden dann sagen, also das geht jetzt zu weit. Während das dort sehr stark in den Köpfen implementiert ist, dass man lange durchhält, das ist zumindest die Hoffnung auch von Xi. Denn wie er ja eigentlich jetzt die Wirtschaft umstrukturiert, geht das nur mit Durchhalten. Wir hören mal weiter.
China ist die weltweit zweitgrößte Wirtschaft und ihr pro Kapitän Gdp hat von 39.800 Yuan bis 81.000 Yuan in den weltweit ersten Rang in der Form von Grünwirkung in China's Produzentensektoren ist die größte in der Welt Also zweitgrößte Volkswirtschaft ist China bereits.
Das ist jetzt auch nicht irgendwas Erdachtes, sondern das gibt es auch hier in der Grafik von der Weltbank, die das beschreibt. Als erstes kommen natürlich USA und dann der Rest. Und selbst wenn das Wachstum jetzt etwas langsamer gehen wird, kann man schon sagen, dass sie da noch weiter aufholen werden. Und das bedeutet dann natürlich, dass wir es, wenn wir von so einer kapitalistischen Weltordnung ausgehen, die wir nun mal haben, dass wir schon so einen Wettbewerb der Volkswirtschaften haben. Und Wettbewerb kann tendenziell natürlich auch kriegerisch ausgetragen werden. Wir kommen dazu gleich noch, denn es gab eine Anhörung auch in diesem Monat im Bundestag, wie eigentlich umgehen mit China. Und wir hören aber jetzt erstmal noch, naja, es gibt noch diese Wachstumszahlen. Und ja, es gibt auch wirkliche Erfolge zu verzeichnen. Da würde ich aber sagen, bis auf die Korruptionsbekämpfung ist das schon gar nicht so sehr Erfolg von Xi, sondern eher der davor liegenden Präsidentschaften.
Und Xi verfolgt aber schon einen anderen Kurs dadurch, dass er ideologisch versucht, so einen Konnex zu schaffen zwischen chinesischer Tradition, kommunistischer Partei, Marxismus, Leninismus und am liebsten auch das noch religiös aufladen will, um über so eine eigentlich die Leute bei der Stange zu halten. Also dass sie durchhalten. Wir hören hier mal die ideologischen Implikationen uns an.
Wir haben die ganze Prozess der Sozialismus und die politische und politische Entwicklung in der Entwicklung der Institutionen, Standards und Prozesse unserer Sozialismus.
Ja, es wird hier viel von Entwicklungen gesprochen, die die chinesische Kultur jetzt nimmt. Eigentlich kann man sagen, versucht er so eine neue Staatsideologie wirklich flächendeckend zu verbreiten mit allen zur Verfügung stehenden Mitteln. Er äußert sich dann hier auch zum Hedonismus.
Wir haben uns auf die Aufgabe geheimniskierter Formalitäten, Bürokratie, Hedonismus und Extravaganz und vorgelegt, sich zu ermitteln, die Mindest-
Das richtet sich jetzt alles direkt an die Partei intern, dass dort der Hedonismus nun beendet ist. Also damit ist ja dann auch gemeint, bei diesen Korruptionsgeschenken, das weiß man ja, wie viel goldenen Hörn plötzlich dort verteilt wurden und was weiß ich. Das ist etwas, was durch Xi dann, so glaubt er zumindest, verhindert wurde. Und tatsächlich hatte er da ja auch einige Erfolge, wenngleich so jemand wie Branko Milanovic auch immer wieder deutlich macht, naja, das ist eigentlich so stark, also die Korruption ist so stark, dass man wirklich zwar sehr hart durchgreifen kann, aber dass das immer nur, weil die Struktur so ist, wie ist dieser Partei, dass das immer nur so paar Jahre wieder ein bisschen abdämpft und dann kommt das natürlich wieder ganz stark nach. Und man sieht es ja dann auch in der Konstitution jetzt, wie Xi da seine Reihen hinter sich schließt. Das wird ja auch nicht alles nur Goodwill sein, sondern kann man auch wieder da neue Formen wahrscheinlich der Korruption erleben. Im Übrigen ist auch auf der feministischen Ebene ein Rückstritt. Also es gibt in der Führungsetage so wenig Frauen, wie seit 15 Jahren oder so nicht mehr. Er schließt das so ganz hinter sich ab.
Es ist ja immer auch ein Wettkampf gegen die Gelegenheit zur Korruption. Und wenn du einen Wirtschaftswachstum verdoppelt, er hat ja eben die absoluten Zahlen genannt in seiner Währung. Keine Ahnung, viel halt. Also man ist irgendwie von so und so viel. Also von 55 auf 114 war die Niveau, die er nannte, das heißt, er ausgibt extrem viel zu verteilen. Wenn der ganze volkswirtschaftliche Mehrwert über die Partei organisiert wird, also Ländereien hier, alles muss neu organisiert werden, Gewerbegebiet da und so, Genehmigungen.
Jaja, es geht ja über diese 100-jährigen Pachtverträge. Das ist natürlich ein Einfallstor dafür.
Ist dann der Kampf gegen Korruption, auch ein Kampf gegen Windmühlen irgendwie.
Aber man möchte marxistisch bleiben.
Chinese Communists are keenly aware that only by integrating the basic tenets of Marxism with China's specific realities and fine traditional culture and only by applying dialectical and historical materialism can we provide correct answers to the major questions presented by the times and discovered through practice and can we ensure that Marxism always retains its vigor and vitality.
Wer jetzt nochmal schnell nachlesen will, historischer Materialismus und dialectischer Materialismus, wie das alles zusammenhängt und dann hegelianisch-marxistisch umgesetzt wird, das ist natürlich reines Wortgeklingelt. Also es geht hier darum, dass wir einen Staat haben, der zwar ein sehr starker Staat ist, der durch diese Organisation über die Partei, also die Regierung ist die Partei, also da diese Differenz kann man ja auch nicht machen, sondern die Regierung ist die Partei, dass man dadurch natürlich ganz anders diesen Staat lenkt. Aber dennoch haben wir, Branko Milanovic hat das in seinem letzten Buch sehr gut aufgeschlüsselt, und das hat auch ganz klar mit einem kapitalistischen Staat zu tun, nur mit einer anderen Form von Kapitalismus. Und meine These ist ja, wir entwickeln uns jetzt alle nicht hin zum chinesischen Modell, das wäre zu verhindern, aber was wir doch als generelle Tendenz erleben können, ist eine Verstärkung des Staatskapitalismus. Also das ist ja diese Idee, dass ohnehin der kapitalistische Staat so ist, dass der Staat nie losgelöst ist von der Wirtschaft, sondern die hängen miteinander zusammen in irgendeiner Weise. Und was wir jetzt in den nächsten Jahrzehnten erleben, ist verschiedene Ausformungen des Staatskapitalismus. Der kann liberaler gestaltet sein, der kann autoritär gestaltet sein, der kann auf verschiedenen Sektoren anders gestaltet sein. Aber wir haben es jetzt mit diversen Staatskapitalismen zu tun, die sich unterschiedlich rechtfertigen. Und man, glaube ich, muss diese marxistischen Anrufungen, die da stattfinden, Aufrufungen, die da stattfinden, ganz ähnlich sehen wie, wenn sich jetzt ein Bolsonaro irgendwie mit religiösen Führern inszeniert und sagt, das ist mir jetzt wichtig, oder Trump die Bibel hochhält.
Oder Friedrich Merz sagt, ich bin für eine angebotsorientierte Wirtschaftspolitik, was ja auch nur bedeutet, der Staat subventioniert Angebote und der Bürger ist dann halt diesem Angebot ausgeliefert. Deswegen ja auch dieses große Faszinose um der CDU immer, welches System wird sich denn eben schon lange ausgebrochenen Systemstreit dann einfach durchsetzen. Ich finde immer wieder interessant, wenn er so redet, wie deutsch das alles ist. Marx, Dialektik, Hegel und so weiter. Die kommen glaube ich echt alle nach Trier. Also sobald die ihr Geld haben, haben die so viele Reden von ihm gelesen und so, dass sie alle als Bürgerpflicht haben, irgendwann mal in Trier, in Marx Geburtshaus vorbei zu schneiden. Und hier so ein bisschen ihr Geld auch mal als Touristen nach Europa zu bringen.
Ja, ist doch schön, dass diese deutsche Tradition des Denkens doch noch irgendwie da ist, aber natürlich jetzt hier in so einer pervertierten Form. Aber in einer sehr schönen Form kann man es übrigens nur ganz nebenbei hören bei dem Podcast Once and Two's von Adam Toos, der jetzt so ein Live-Event gemacht hat. Und Adam Toos wurde da von dem Host gefragt, wie er denn überhaupt so arbeite und vor allem, wie es sein könne, dass er als Ökonom oder als Wirtschaftshistoriker so viele verschiedene Dinge zusammenbringt, dass er da über Bruno Latour redet und dann über dies und das und so. Und dann gibt er erst mal einen Einblick, wie er in England studiert hat, wie man nur Essays schreibt und wie wichtig es ist, gute Essays zu schreiben. Wie dann das amerikanische System, wo er ja jetzt selbst Professor ist, funktioniert. Und dann sagt er, aber das ist alles nicht die Antwort. Die Antwort auf die Frage, warum so breit gefächert und auch Blick auf die Literatur und was weiß ich, lautet Germany, Germany, Germany und Marx. Weil Marx das natürlich auch machte. Und er ist ja hier in Deutschland zur Schule gegangen und hat dann die Bücher von Surkamp und so früh gelesen. Und das ist eigentlich das, was diesen breiten Blick ausmacht. Das sei eine sehr deutsche Tradition, in der er da steht. Das fand ich sehr schön zu hören.
In der stehe ich ja auch. 200 Seiten Text, 300 Fußnoten. Ja. Und ich habe gehört, nicht jeder ist so erpicht darauf, ein ordentliches Literaturverzeichnis zu führen.
Man hört so allerlei. Nun gehen wir weiter zur Selbstversorgung. Also China, ja, nabeln die sich ab. Schon, ja, kann man sagen. Jedenfalls kann man es erst mal positiv formulieren. Sie wollen sehr stark die Binnenwirtschaft fördern.
Wir werden die aquakulturelle und rote Entwicklung zuerst und die Erspannung unserer Erlebnisse in der Erlebnisse der Poverty koncentrieren. Talent- Ökosystems- Wir müssen die Grundlagen für die Sicherheit der Menschen und alle Frauen in der gesamten Zeit der China nicht unter der röhrlichen Linie von 120 Millionen Fakten aufregen.
Also alles in den eigenen Händen, Lieferketten, also eigentlich haben die eine ähnliche Diskussion wie wir, die führen die jetzt für sich, also das ist ganz interessant. Wir sagen, wir müssen von China loskommen, China sagt ja, also die sagen nicht, wir müssen von der Welt loskommen, weil sie natürlich auch das brauchen. Aber was für sie wichtig ist, dass sie nicht stark von Importen abhängig sind. Wir hatten im Salon schon so ein Text über die Kornkammern, warum die wie verrückt alles besuchen zu speichern, also auch diese Unabhängigkeit, sich da zu bewahren oder oder sie jetzt erst herzustellen. Einher geht natürlich mit all diesen großen Programmen auch, dass man eine Bevölkerung hat, die mitzieht. Und da ist ein Weg über das Internet natürlich ganz entscheidend. Eine gesunde Umgebung im Internet will man schaffen, damit die neue Ideologie sich da verbreiten kann. Ich glaube, das muss man nicht mehr näher interpretieren.
In Amerika ist halt eine Arbeitsteilung. Da sagt das nicht der Präsident, sondern nur der Facebook-Präsident.
Du hast jetzt schon einen Verweis gemacht. Als ich mich anfing, jetzt im Monat über damit zu beschäftigen, da trugen ja so Nachrichten ein, hat man jetzt so die Rede. Und dann kommt man so, natürlich so, also es ist so bei mir schon fast zwanghaft, dass ich das immer versuche, mit Sachen zu verbinden. Und dann hatte ich aber auch schon einiges über Facebook, über die Earnings und so weiter gehört. Und das verbinden wir nachher mal. Gut, dass du es schon mal hier aufgemacht hast, Mark Zuckerberg. Wir bleiben noch mal ganz kurz bei Xi. Identitätspolitik auf Chinesisch.
Wir können uns immer nicht richtig vorstellen, in welchem Rahmen die da Defizite haben. Wir haben ja dann doch so ein Verständnis von wir Deutsche und so weiter, eigentlich übertreiben wir es mehr so. Wir sind zu sehr deutsch irgendwie. Und in China ist es ja doch anders, also dieses Misstrauen unter Nachbarn und überhaupt und die eine Region gegen die andere ausgespielt.
Na ja, es ist ein System, das über Jahrzehnte mit Denunziationen funktionierte, was zugleich hoch korrupt war. Denunziationen wirklich in die intimsten Lebensbereiche hinein mit der Einkindpolitik, wo Kinder versteckt wurden, dann spät abgetrieben wurden und lauter solche Dinge. Das heißt, wir haben es da natürlich mit einer Misstrauensgesellschaft zu tun und natürlich ist die sozialistische bzw. die Maoistische Ideologie natürlich nicht darauf ausgelegt gewesen, den Familienkern zu stärken. Wir haben ja oft in sozialistischen Ländern auch eine sehr frühe Einführung von liberalen Scheidungsrechten, was natürlich nicht da ist, nur einfach weil die progressiv sind, sondern natürlich auch, weil die Familie potentiell auch einen Widerstandskern bilden kann gegen eine Staatsideologie. Und hier haben wir aber jetzt ein Xi, der stark für die Familie plädiert. Und ich würde auch das mal herausstreichen wollen, das scheint mir neben dem Staatskapitalismus so ein weiteres Paradigma zu sein in aller Welt, dass die Familie als Nukleus rausgestellt wird, als das, woran man festhalten muss. Das siehst du in jedem Blockbuster. Du kannst dir das ansehen, ob in Italien die Meloni oder in Brasilien, wo immer wird die Familie jetzt von der herrschenden Politik immer heraufbeschworen als irgendetwas. Natürlich auch, weil man als Staat dann doch nicht mehr so viel anbieten kann. Also wo das große sozialistische Versprechen natürlich da ist, da braucht man nicht so sehr die Familienbande im Sinne von Zusammenhalt, Solidarität. Während, wo die, naja, die die Winde ein bisschen heftiger wehen, man plötzlich natürlich darauf angewiesen ist, im Privaten dann wenigstens eine Abfederung zu erhalten.
Genau, hier unten steht Minimum von Schirmacher, das ja auch damals schon so ein bisschen in die Richtung ging. Jetzt drückt es natürlich als Thema. Wir erinnern uns Joe Biden, 100 Tage im Amt. Er beruft beide Kongresskammern ein und schließt seine Rede mit. Wir müssen die Familie stärken. Nur so haben wir im Systemstreit gegen China eine Chance.
Stimmt.
Und das ist natürlich immer wieder dieser Fokus auf, wir brauchen eine Schlagkräftigkeit, nämlich ökonomisch verwendbare Bevölkerung. Und die ganz historische Erfahrung sagt, es klappt nur in der Familie. Nur die Familien können es organisieren. Wir können höchstens politisch um die Familie drum rumschweben und unterstützen und so weiter. Aber am Ende muss es die Familie erledigen. Deswegen ist das auch ein krasser Spagat, wenn Xi hier sagt, die Familie und so, ideologisches Fundament, die Kernfamilie stärken. Und gleichzeitig wird er nicht davon ablassen, bis unter die Bettdecke regieren zu wollen. Und das widerspricht sich. Also so kommt man nicht vorwärts. Dieses elementare Grundvertrauen, das man braucht, weil es den Zusammenhalt der ganzen Gesellschaft elementar fundiert, wird in dieser familialen Bande erfahren und erlebt.
Und wenn das aber erfahren wird, dass unter die Bettdecke regiert wird, dann hat das eher die Tendenz, dass sich die Familie gegen den Staat verschwört.
Genau, dann hat man die Nachbarschaften, die sich sagen, ne, hier sind irgendwie Disbalancen. Das passt nicht zusammen. Hier passt einfach Semantik nicht zur Sozialstruktur. Und da kann man dann viel soziologische Analyse machen. Machen die ja dort auch. Aber das kriegt man nie wieder eingebunden. So eine Art Corona-App, die wirklich alles abdecken möchte, gibt es dann einfach gar nicht. Sondern dann erntet man nur das Misstrauen.
Die Mitte, die gesellschaftliche Mitte, die nimmt selbstverständlich Xi auch in den Blick. Und sagt Folgendes.
Wir werden das System der Einkommenvergabe verbessern. Wir werden die Vergabe mit der Arbeit als Hauptstelle behalten, mit mehreren Formen der Vergabe existieren, nebenan.
Die Mitte wächst allerdings, glaube ich, nicht mehr so richtig. Das könnte die große Gefahr werden, also die große Unruhe dann auch auslösen. Wenn also dieses Aufstiegsversprechen für viele nicht mehr erreichbar wird, beziehungsweise diese Mitte dann auch ins Strauchelgerät und wieder an Wohlstand verliert, also wenn da sehr schnell das erlebt wird, was man hier im Westen dann auch erlebt als Mitte, dann geht das natürlich sehr, sehr schief schnell. Und da drückt die Demografie und auch die kommt vor. Da würde ich gerne wissen, was will er tun, um das zu boostern?
Sehr gute Frage. Er kann gar nichts tun. Das ist einfach ein Metier, wo er nicht regieren kann. Es ist ja interessant, dass sich das hier überall so doppelt.
Geburtenkontrolle ist ja noch einfacher. Das haben die ja tatsächlich gemacht mit dieser Ein-Kind-Politik. Aber Leute dazu zu bringen, dass sie Kinder haben und aufziehen, das wird nicht gehen.
Das wird nicht gehen. Und du brauchst vor allem, das ist eben dieses große Paradox, eine Wirtschaftspolitik, die die Familie so hofiert und pampert, dass sich alle wohlfühlen und zwar so wohlfühlen, dass sie nicht nur denken, cool, um mich wird sich gekümmert, ich mache jetzt mal Karriere, sondern ich traue mir auch noch ein Kind zu, dass meine Karriere eigentlich wieder im Wege steht. Und wenn du aus China solche Nachrichten hörst, wie die größte Bank ist jetzt kurz vor der Pleite, es sind 300 Milliarden in Frage und betrifft ungefähr so 80 Millionen Familien, die schon mal angespart haben für ihre Wohnung, und dann hört man ja, die müssen jetzt alle zittern. Die gehen jetzt nicht zur Arbeit, sondern die stellen sich an die Bankfiliale und hoffen, dass noch ein bisschen Geld übrig ist. Dann weiß man, die kriegen die nächsten fünf Jahre keine Kinder. Also da kann man gleich mal flächendeckend verlieren. Und diese Art von Sensibilität und auch echter Tragweite politischer Entscheidungen, dass man sich wirklich richtig hinstellt und sagt, liebe Sparerinnen und Sparer, ihre Bankenlagen sind sicher und so weiter, kann nicht mal Xi machen, wenn die Nachrichtenlage ist, hier kippt gerade eine Bank mit 300 Milliarden, Bilanzsumme, und zwar nur auf Familien, Wohnungen, Bau gemünzt. Also da kommt auch so eine Struktur einfach in ihre Grenzen politisch.
Wir gehen in den Deutschen Bundestag. Da gab es, wie gesagt, eine Anhörung zu China. Und wir hören jetzt als erstes Ben Schreer vom International Institute for Strategic Studies, der sich jetzt erlaubt, mal den aktuellen Konflikt mit dem viel größeren Konflikt, wie ich finde, gelungen zu verbinden.
Die russische Föderation ist gegenwärtig. Eine unmittelbare Bedrohung für die regelbasierte Ordnung mitten in Europa. Aber mittel- und langfristig werden Russlands Mittel zur Umgestaltung des gesamten internationalen Systems eher begrenzt sein. China dagegen ist der einzige strategische Konkurrent mit dem politischen Willen und den potenziellen Mitteln, die Ordnung nach seinen autoritären Vorstellungen zu ändern. Und hat es auch teilweise schon getan. Chinas Strategie ist umfassend, diplomatisch, wirtschaftlich, militärisch und technologisch. Kurz gesagt, wenn man das mit in einem Bild umschreiben sollte, dann ist Außen- und Sicherheitspolitik Russland ein Orkan. Aber China ist sozusagen der sicherheitspolitische Klimawandel.
So der Klimawandel. Aber was machen wir dann damit? Es ist ja folgendermaßen, mal von diesen Ideologien, Xi ist jetzt abgesehen, haben wir eine Volkswirtschaft, die sich gut entwickelt hat und die sich auch noch weiter entwickelt und trotz dieser harten Maßnahmen, zero Covid, immerhin noch Wachstum ordentliches hat. Also es ist ja gar nicht so katastrophal in China, wenn man bedenkt, wie radikal diese Maßnahmen sind. Und gehen wir mal davon aus, dieser Wachstumspfad, der kann doch noch etwas länger beschritten werden. Gehen wir mal davon aus, dass wir es tatsächlich mit China, mit der stärksten Volkswirtschaft zu tun bekommen, 2030, 34, 35, wann auch immer. Dann ist es natürlich so, dass man dann eine Rivalität jetzt ganz im Sinne von kapitalistischen Staaten stehen sich gegenüber produziert hat und wir wissen aus den Rivalitäten in der EU, wo sich auch die Länder kompetitiv gegenüberstehen, dass Deutschland natürlich da immer am Ende sagen kann, wir machen das jetzt so, bitte anschließen oder hört mal auf mehr Geld auszugeben, was auch immer. Und die Gefahr, die natürlich jetzt der Westen und besonders Amerika sieht, liegt nun darin, was ist, wenn China Sachen diktiert? Nur in der Logik des globalen kapitalistischen Systems ist es immer so, dass der, der die stärkere wirtschaftliche Macht hat, Ansagen machen kann. Man kann natürlich sich mehr davon loslösen, man kann sich da etwas entkoppeln. Das Problem besteht natürlich, dass diese Entwicklung auch zu einer Eskalation führen kann, wenn die eine Macht nicht anerkennen will, dass sie nicht mehr die Nummer eins ist. Also das kann passieren. Und dann war Inga Solty von der Rosa-Luxemburg-Stiftung auch dort zu Gast in der Anhörung und sagt folgendes.
Die große Frage des 21. Jahrhunderts ist, ob wir es gelingen kann, der Tukididis-Falle zu entgehen und den ein friedlichen Aufstieg Chinas in der Weltordnung zu ermöglichen, zu verhindern, dass der relative Abstieg der USA und der Aufstieg Chinas weltkrieg ausgetragen werden. Und in dieser Hinsicht ist in meinen Augen eine Konfrontationspolitik gegen China nicht im Interesse der breiten Bevölkerungsteile in Deutschland, in Europa und muss dringend verhindert werden.
Ja, wir haben jetzt diese Idee, wir haben das mit Russland nicht früh genug gemacht. Wenn man auch fragen muss, was haben wir früh genug gemacht oder nicht. Also man kann sagen, wir hätten auf erneuerbare Energien früher setzen sollen. Unabhängig von Russland können wir generell mal sagen, das war ein fundamentaler Fehler. Die Frage der wirtschaftlichen Einbindung Russlands in europäische Geschäfte, die jetzt als Fehler grundsätzlich zu brandmarken, würde bedeuten, ja, was wäre die Alternative gewesen? Hätten wir 2002 auf Konfrontationskurs zu Russland gehen sollen und warum erst mal? Also nehmen wir mal an, die Amtszeit von Putin hätte 2020 geendet. Dann hätte man zwar nicht gesagt, war ein toller Präsident, aber dann hätte man gesagt, es gab einen Krieg, der Frieden wurde bewahrt. Bis auf, ich weiß sehr wohl, was da an der Krim usw. vorgefallen ist. Aber wir hätten das sozusagen auf der Ebene EU-Russland irgendwie miteinander ausgehalten. Und deswegen müssen wir jetzt mal ganz klar überlegen, welche Politik folgt daraus mit China? Wir haben jetzt diese Diskussion, ich habe da keine Clips mitgebracht, zu Costco. Also diese Frage, inwieweit sich die Chinesen beteiligen dürfen mit Investments am Hamburger Hafen. Hamburger Hafen, würde man sagen, kritische Infrastruktur. Jetzt sagen Leute wie Mark Schieritz, ja, aber das sind nur 24, 9 Prozent. Das heißt, die haben nicht die Mehrheit das Stimmrecht. Das heißt, die sind da zwar dann mit investiert, die profitieren bei Gewinnen davon. Aber die haben nicht die Entscheidungsgewalt. Die können nicht einfach wie zum Beispiel in Griechenland sagen, uns gehört jetzt der Hafen. Also muss man da glaube ich das differenzierter betrachten, wenngleich man auch durchaus sagen könnte, generell bei solchen Infrastruktursachen eher nicht. Bei der Anhörung macht auch jemand den Vorschlag, warum nicht eigentlich diese ganzen Herzen, die sich so als Konkurrenten gegenüberstehen, nicht vielmehr als europäische Verbündete miteinander zusammenarbeiten. Das wäre sicherlich auch eine sinnvolle Idee, die zu machen ist. Wenn man aber tatsächlich so weit gehen würde und sagt, wir müssen jetzt möglichst wenig noch mit China zu tun haben, dann glaube ich, ist das erstmal volkswirtschaftlich für uns auch eine ziemliche Katastrophe. Und damit meine ich nicht nur die Autoindustrie. Man muss ja auch fragen, worauf soll das jetzt alles hinauslaufen? Und ist es eigentlich zunächst einmal fair zu sagen, die sollen sich mal bitte nicht entwickeln? Also es gibt einen Unterschied, ob man Menschenrechte, die verletzt werden, thematisiert in China, oder ob man sagt, die sollen sich generell wirtschaftlich nicht weiterentwickeln.
Also die Diskussion ist ja auch wieder super interessant, weil sie auf unterschiedlichen Ebenen stattfindet. Auf der einen Seite diese Expertenanhörung im Bundestag, diese große Thematisierung, dürfen sich die Chinesen hier über Costco irgendwie in diese Hafenterminals einkaufen, wo ich auch denke, ich kenne die BWL-Diskussionen gar nicht, so einen Hafen besser zu betreiben. Wenn derjenige, der das Schiff fährt, dann auch jemanden da hat, der es entgegennimmt und so, kann ja durchaus alles sein. Auf der anderen Seite haben wir aber diese strukturellen Phänomene.
Die Abhängigkeit der deutschen Wirtschaft von China ist noch weiter gewachsen. Die meisten Firmen praktizieren eine Weiter-so-Politik. Sie wissen um mögliche China-Risiken, wischen sie jedoch vom Tisch. Im ersten Halbjahr investierten deutsche Firmen die Rekordsumme von 10 Milliarden Euro in China, der höchste Wert seit 2006. Allein von vier deutschen Konzernen stammt ein Drittel aller europäischen Investitionen. VW verkauft fast jedes zweite Auto in China. Mercedes und BMW sind ebenfalls stark engagiert. Der Chemiekonzern BASF plant alleine eine 10 Milliarden Euro Investition in ein neues Werk in China, von der Größenordnung des Stammsitzes Ludwigshafen. China dominiere den Wachstumsmarkt Chemie, daher könne man nicht, nicht vor Ort sein, erklärt die BASF, trotz aller Risiken.
Also werden wir gerade so kulturelle Diskussionen führen und so und irgendwie Angst vor Abhängigkeiten und so weiter. Es ist strukturell, wird es gerade verwoben, wie sonst nichts und auch nicht mal. Genau, dieses Verhältnis zwischen den beiden Ländern. Und eine Zahl mal herausgegriffen, also da war ich wirklich beeindruckt, E-Mobilität.
Ganz kurz, also dieses BASF-Argument ist ja ein Argument. Also es ist einfach eine Schwierigkeit. Also ich glaube, man muss, wenn man über so globale wirtschaftliche Verflechtung redet, diese extreme Widersprüchlichkeit aushalten. Man kann nicht sagen, wir gehen da ganz aus diesem Markt raus. Das schwächt wiederum die eigene Industrie. Andererseits ist die Präsenz der eigenen Industrie auch für das Land dort wieder gut. Sonst würden die das ja nicht machen. Das natürlich erhöht die wirtschaftliche Schlagkraft von China. Aber was will man da jetzt tun? Also es gibt da tatsächlich in dem Sinne keine goldenen Wege. Zumal es ja dann immer noch privatwirtschaftliche Partikularinteressen gibt, dass natürlich BASF den Markt nicht aufgeben wird für irgendein höheres Prinzip.
Also ich meine BASF als Chemie, es gibt ja auch so viele Maschinenbauerfirmen, gerade ASML und so, wie sie alle heißen, die ja so eigenartiges Zeug machen, wo man weiß, die haben die Kompetenz. Kann man nochmal neu erfinden, dauert dann 15 Jahre und so weiter. Dann lasst doch lieber diejenigen, die sich auskennen, mit ihren Eigentumstiteln juristisch abgesichert nach China gehen und dann bauen die sich halt ein Werk, das so groß ist wie ihr Urstammwerk in Ludwigshafen. Gleichzeitig betreibt halt Costco als diejenigen, die jedes dritte Schiff aus China, das in Hamburg fährt, warum sollten die nicht auch den einen Meter Hafen dann noch haben? Sie kaufen ja nicht die ganze Straße bis nach Bremen und sagen, dann ist unsere Straße Monopol, alle privaten Autos raus oder so. Sondern dieser Hafen hat halt die Aufgabe, chinesische Schiffe abzufertigen. Warum sollten das nicht die Chinesen selber machen? Also in der Ansicht ganz viel Verwirrung und ganz viel Verkopplung von so politischen Themen, die da vielleicht nicht so richtig hingehören. Wir haben vielleicht noch so andere chinesische Themen, die uns da mehr Sorgen machen sollten als diese wirtschaftliche Verzahnung. Und eine dieser wirtschaftlichen Verzahnungen, es kommen jetzt E-Autos aus China. Und die Importraten und insbesondere die Entwicklung ist wirklich erstaunlich.
Autohersteller aus China verkaufen immer mehr E-Autos nach Europa und nach Deutschland. Mehr dazu von Markus Gürne an der Frankfurter Börse.
Chinas Einfluss wächst. Nach dem Einkauf in das Hamburger Hafen-Terminal breiten sich jetzt chinesische Autohersteller in einer deutschen Schlüsselindustrie aus. Denn Chinas neuer Markt für eigene Automarken wie NIO, Link oder BYD ist Deutschland. Während für deutsche Hersteller Lieferzeiten jenseits der zwölf Monate normal geworden sind, liefern chinesische Hersteller schneller. Das Volumen der Importe nach Deutschland hat sich vervielfacht. Wurden noch 2017 E-Autos im Wert von 360.000 Euro aus China importiert, lag der Wert 2019 bereits bei fast 11 Millionen Euro und 2021 dann bei 648 Millionen Euro. Der größte Marktvorteil der Chinesen liegt bei den Rohstoffen und den Batterien. Die stellen die Chinesen nämlich selber her und umgehen damit die Probleme hiesiger Hersteller.
Also der finanzielle Umfang ist innerhalb von vier Jahren von 300.000 auf 600 Millionen Euro gewachsen.
Die Summe an sich ist noch nicht riesig, aber der Zwachstum ist exponentiell.
Und wir wissen, wie viele Autos in China hergestellt werden können. Also die können uns überschwemmen, so wie wir mit Kleidung und Nahrungsmittel ganz Afrika überschwemmen. Das ist hier mal so einprogrammiert.
Sieht man schon im Stadtbild chinesische Automarken? Ich habe noch keine Truppen gesehen, die mir irgendwie auffallen. Aber wer weiß.
Also wird jetzt kommen.
Ich habe da nicht so den Blick für. Aber man muss eigentlich darauf achten, dass man da so sieht. Wir hören jetzt noch Yanka Oertel. Sie spricht über den chinesischen Klimaschutz, der sich ja ein bisschen löst von ja auch der Welt. Aber was bedeutet das eigentlich? Yanka Oertel führt das jetzt mal aus.
Die Tatsache, dass auf der chinesischen Seite es kein großes Interesse daran gibt, im Klimabereich zusammenzuarbeiten, sehen wir, wie wir es zum Beispiel im G20-Meeting gerade gesehen haben, wohin die Glasgow-Verhandlung noch mal zurückgegangen wurde. Das heißt aber wiederum eigentlich nicht, dass nichts passiert im Klimaschutz. Denn wenn wir uns anschauen, was an ambitionierter Politik auf chinesischer Seite passiert, mit Blick auf erneuerbare Energien, mit Blick auf Batterietechnologie, mit Blick auf Elektromobilität etc. dann sehen wir hier ein Fortschreiten auf chinesischer Seite, das sehr beeindruckend ist. Unsere Logik, dass nur mit Zusammenarbeit Klimaschutz möglich ist, zieht eigentlich gar nicht mehr. Was wir brauchen, ist Handeln in allen Staaten. Dass China nicht mit uns zusammenarbeiten will beim Klimaschutz, heißt nicht, dass es nichts tut mit Blick auf den Klimaschutz, denn die Bedrohung durch den Klimaschutz ist für China extrem real. Außerdem sieht man den Wettbewerbsvorteil in neuen Technologien, sieht man den Wettbewerbsvorteil, den man sich dadurch global erreichen kann. Und wenn wir uns anschauen, dass China im Bereich der Technologie eine absolute Dominanzposition ausgebaut hat, in der Batterietechnologie eine absolute Dominanzposition ausgebaut hat, dann sehen wir, dass das sehr strategisch angegangen wird. Deswegen glaube ich, müssen wir so ein bisschen aus diesen Dichotomien raus, um zu sagen, aber im Bereich des Klimas, das ist doch so wichtig und dann müssen wir doch alle zusammenarbeiten. Das ist doch eine globale Herausforderung. Von chinesischer Seite geht es um den Schutz und die Adaption Chinas.
Das ist doch eine gute Argumentation, weil ja jetzt gerne so von deutscher Seite gesagt wird, aber es bringt ja alles nichts mehr. Die müssen, nein, die tun, aber die machen das jetzt so auf ihrem Wege und wir müssten dann eigentlich auch wieder diese Importzahlen ja deutlich zeigen.
Wir haben ja in Shenzhen das besprochen, wie da einfach die ganze Busflotte umgestellt wird auf Elektromobilität. Solche Projekte gibt es in Frankfurt auch, aber das ist dann halt die drei Buslinien zwischen Bahnhof und Höst oder so. Die werden dann so testweise mal für drei Jahre schon mal umgestellt, während da einfach die ganze Stadt schon umgekrempelt wird. Die warten dann eher weniger auf uns. Ist natürlich auch wieder was hier betont, das finde ich super interessant, dieses Deutsche hat man ja auf ganz vielen Gebieten. Wir, die Datenschutzkönige, wir, die Umweltschützer und so weiter. Und nur wer mit uns zusammenarbeitet, macht das auch. Wir hängen eigentlich hinterher. Wir sind zu langsam für die, weil die chinesischen Städte werden ja schon seit 2008 irgendwie, seit Olympia, wird ja da alles entzmockt, ganz Peking wurde entzmockt, beispielsweise über diesen Umbau von diesen ganzen Industrieanlagen und dem Straßenverkehr.
Wir hören jetzt in den Podcast The Sound of Economics rein. Xianggang Xu ist Senior Research Fellow in Stanford, Center für Chinas Ökonomie und Institutionen. Und er erklärt jetzt mal, wie wird denn eigentlich jetzt regiert mit Xi?
In diesem Lernendienst-Partei ist alles in einem sehr kleinen Kreis geschehen. Und dann haben sie eine Formalität. Das ist die Formalität. Die wichtigsten Dinge sind bereits in einem sehr kleinen Zuge.
So, jetzt begeben wir uns doch mal auf das Feld nicht so ganz stadthafte Vergleiche und vergleichen es mal mit einer Aktionärskonferenz, wo man zwar auch anwesend sein kann und man darf ja auch noch widersprechen und manchmal kennt man ja schon mal, dass es zu einem Tumult kommt, aber die Entscheidungen werden längst woanders getroffen. Nun ist es natürlich so bei einem Aktienunternehmen, dass es da das Board gibt und da ist durchaus Entscheidungsgeräte, da sind Stimmrechte da, aber es gibt ja doch einen sehr speziellen Fall, nämlich Facebook. Du hast es schon angesprochen. Mark Zuckerberg hat zwar ein Aktienunternehmen, aber der regiert da ja wie ein König oder wie Präsident Xi. Und wir hören uns jetzt mal an aus dem Doppelgänger-Podcast, wie eigentlich Zuckerberg regiert und stellen uns immer Xi noch mit dabei vor, Pip Klöckner erläutert es hier.
Facebook hat, so wie auch zum Beispiel Google oder Snap, eine Dual-Clear-Shareholder-Class-Struktur. Das heißt, es gibt Class A-Shares, davon gibt es ungefähr 2, 4 Milliarden Aktien. Das ist sozusagen, wenn du jetzt irgendwie in deiner Trading-App einmal Meter orders, dann bekommst du einen Class A-Share in der Regel. Und dann gibt es eine weitere Share-Klasse, nämlich die Class B-Shares, die auch nicht an der Börse gehandelt werden. Und von denen besitzt oder kontrolliert Mark Zuckerberg. Das sind rund ein bisschen mehr als 400 Millionen. 360 besitzt er davon, weitere 30 ungefähr kontrolliert er. Also es sind bei Freunden Personen, die ihm nahe stehen.
Also da haben wir entsprechende Seilschaften. Mit dieser A- und B-Struktur hat man immer die Stimmrechte auf seiner Seite. Egal, was nun wenn sich alle dagegen verschwören, ist Mark Zuckerberg immer derjenige, der gut raus ist. Hier nochmal Pip Klöckner.
Und diese Class B-Shares haben zehnfache Stimmrechte. Und wenn man also diese kontrollierten rund 400 Millionen Shares mal zehn nimmt, also die zehnfachen Stimmrechte, bist du bei vier Milliarden Votes. Und die gesamten Class A-Shares, 2, 4 Milliarden in der Zahl, haben 2, 4 Milliarden Votes. Das heißt, er hat eine rund 60-prozentige Mehrheit bei jeder Abstimmung, wenn er alle seine Stimmrechte ausübt und kann damit letztlich machen, was er will. Er ist Gründer, CEO und Chairman of the Board.
Es ist doch interessant, dass man so dieses ganze Aktienprinzip aber aushebeln kann, dem einfach sagt, ich beteilige euch nur an den ökonomischen Gewinnen. Politisch ist leider mit euren Eigentumstitten nichts erwürgt.
Naja, das gibt es auch bei unseren deutschen Familienunternehmen, wenn die Vorzugsaktien ausgeben. Vorzugsaktie heißt, dass du dann ein bisschen mehr Dividende vielleicht bekommst, aber du darfst nicht mitstimmen.
Ja, das finde ich besonders gut, dass man da das Wort Vorzugsaktie für genutzt hat.
Also wir haben natürlich diese undemokratischen Prinzipien in Unternehmen. Manche sagen ja, Unternehmen sind in Demokratien die letzten gebliebenen Diktaturen. Ja, das kann man also bei Zuckerberg sehen. Und jetzt wissen wir von dieser enormen medialen Macht, die Zuckerberg hat. Du hast es eben schon, als wir über den medialen Einfluss der Partei gesprochen haben, gesagt, na ja, das wird halt bei uns aufgeteilt. Das macht dann Zuckerberg über seine Algorithmen, wenn gleich dann darüber doch noch ein bisschen mehr Pluralität möglich ist. Wir hören jetzt mal etwas zu Xi's Zeitplan im Global Dispatches Podcast von Jessica Chen Weiss. Sie ist Professor für China und den Asienpazifischen Raum. Es wird jetzt hier ganz langfristig, sagen wir es ruhig mal, investiert. Ich finde, wir sollten das mal noch enger zusammenbinden. Xi hat einen völlig anderen Zeitplan vor Augen, als wir, die wir die Tageszeitung aufschlagen und sagen, die chinesischen Aktien sind nochmal richtig in den Keller gekracht und die waren doch schon ganz unten. Wir wussten gar nicht, dass wir nochmal weiter runtergehen würden. Natürlich, das ist nämlich passiert, also so haben die Märkte auch noch nie reagiert auf China, also auf ein Parallel-Kongress, dass man wirklich gesehen hat, okay, der meint das ernst, was bedeutet das eigentlich für das private Kapital in China und die Märkte sagten offenbar nichts Gutes und dann sind die Aktien nochmal richtig runtergekracht. So, aber es gibt eine langfristige Strategie. Jetzt überlegen wir mal, wenn wir das jetzt verbinden, wie ist eigentlich so das bei manchen Unternehmen mit der langfristigen Strategie? Ich habe mal das heute morgen noch schnell rausgeschrieben. 2012 ging Facebook an die Börse, da kostete die Aktie 25 Euro. Im September 21 hatte sie dann ihre absolute Höhe erreicht, 320 Euro. Und jetzt kostet die Facebook-Aktie 98 Euro. Also nur noch ein Massaker. Es ist ein Massaker und manche sagen, das kann noch weitergehen. Manche reden vom Ende von Facebook oder so. Wir geben hier keine Aktientipps oder so, aber sagen wir mal so, diese Zahlen sind ja doch sehr beeindruckend, wie sich das entwickelt hat. Und jetzt hören wir noch mal aus dem Doppelgänger-Podcast diese Thematisierung von Shareholder Value. Also wir hatten jetzt eben noch mit Ramaswami jemand, der in Bezug auf ESG sagte, ja hört doch auf damit Politik zu machen, konzentriert euch nur auf die Shareholder. Man kann jetzt Mark Zuckerberg nicht vorwerfen, dass er sich auf die Shareholder konzentriert, denn die sind ja deutlich ärmer geworden, wenn sie jetzt noch die Akte gehalten haben. Wir hören hier also noch mal rein.
Shareholder-Value ist ihm auf jeden Fall nicht wichtig genug, zumindest nicht kurzfristig. Er würde bestimmt argumentieren, dass langfristiger Shareholder-Value viel mehr von der Strategie abhängig ist als von den Cash-Flows im Jahr 2022. Das ist auch fair, glaube ich. Und am Ende ist seine Aufgabe auch, die Firma die nächsten zehn Jahre für Shareholder-Guts zu verwalten.
Also ist das vielleicht dann bei Zuckerberg eine sehr, sehr langfristige Strategie, dass er sagt, wir gehen jetzt sehr lange durch den Tal, wir halten durch, ich habe euch auch eine Ideologie besorgt. Es ist nicht der Marxismus oder die chinesische Tradition, sondern ich nenne das Metaverse. Und diese Erzählung soll uns tragen, auch durch die finsteren Täter, durch die wir gehen müssen.
Kann ja immer noch aufgehen. Er ist ja unter 40. Das heißt, er kann das noch 30 Jahre machen oder so. Solange wird ihn sein durchtrainierter Körper da noch bringen. Warum man sich so sehr von seinem Körper verabschieden will, ist seine Sache. Aber klar, das ist das Metier Facebooks. Er ist über Technologie irgendwie zu machen. Es gab jedenfalls dieses eine Werbevideo, wo sie ganz viel Wert draufgelegt haben, dass die Avatarer jetzt auch Beine haben im Metaverse. Es ist nicht nur noch der üblich schwebende Oberkörper. Lauter so ein Halli Galli. Klar, er wäre auch gerne jetzt in einer Position, wo er mehr Kapital in seine Richtung lenkt. Er findet aber gerade nicht den Weg, aber er setzt einfach darauf, dass irgendwann der Knoten platzt.
Und er dann liefert. Wie Xi jetzt sagt, wir müssen gar nicht so profitabel sein im Sinne von wir müssen mit aller Gewalt wachsen, sondern wir trosseln lieber zugunsten der Sicherheit. Also es ist ja eine Sicherheitspolitik, die Xi macht auf lange Sicht und sagt, wir müssen so aufgestürzt sein, dass wir das alleine stemmen können. Und Zuckerberg macht so eine Sicherheitssache, dass er sagt, wir verzichten jetzt auf all das, was so ein Tagesgeschäft sein könnte. Ja, also er macht das ja ganz offensiv dadurch, dass er extrem viel investiert in dieses Metaverse. Es ist ja ganz ungewöhnlich, dass wenn eigentlich das Unternehmen gerade sehr schlecht aufgestellt ist, ein profitables Geschäft ja auch hat mit der Werbung, dass zugleich man dann, also normalerweise würde man in einer Krisenphase dann sagen, ja wir haben ein profitables Geschäft, darauf konzentrieren wir uns. Und er macht aber genau das Gegenteil und sagt, ja es ist Krise, wir geben jetzt trotzdem richtig viel für Forschung ab.
Er positioniert sich einfach für das, was kommt.
Ja, wir hören mal weiter nochmal das Sound of Economics über Covid und die Partei.
Die Covid-0-Polizei ist nicht nur eine Politik, die eine Pandemie enthält, sondern das ist die Partei-Linie. Die Partei-Linie muss korrekt sein, die Partei-Linie muss groß sein. Wer den Partei-Linie zerstört, ist der Gegner der Partei. China war die erfolgreichste Partei in der Welt, in der Pandemie enthalten wurde.
Keiner darf Xi widersprechen. Im Politbüro ist jetzt alles so aufgestellt, dass ihm nur noch applaudiert wird. Ganz ähnlich dann wie beim Board von Zuckerberg, wo er Freunde und Gleichgesinnte versammelt. Und jetzt hören wir im The Economist Podcast David Renney, der mal beschreibt, was wir jetzt erlebt haben.
So in der Kontext des Partei-Kongress, wo wir wissen, dass er überwältigend als Partei-Leader eine dritte Linie bekommen wird, ist er eigentlich die Befehlung seiner ersten Jahrzeit in der Macht. Es hat wirklich nicht mit den Anstrengungen in dem Land, der größte, die schlossende Wirtschaft, mit dem Fakt, dass viele chinesische Menschen sich über die Wohnung, die sie haben, verletzen, die ihre Werte, die hohen Unbewerbungsleveln zwischen den Jungen, die die Arbeit, die die Partei, die die Arbeit, die die Arbeit, die die Arbeit, die die Arbeit, die die Arbeit, die die Arbeit, die die Arbeit, die Arbeit, die Arbeit, die Arbeit, die Arbeit, die Arbeit, die Arbeit, die Arbeit, die Arbeit, die Arbeit, die Arbeit, die Arbeit, die Arbeit, die Arbeit, die Arbeit, die Arbeit, die Arbeit, die Arbeit, die Arbeit, die Arbeit, die Arbeit, die Arbeit, die Arbeit, die Arbeit, die Arbeit, die Arbeit, die Arbeit, die Arbeit, die Arbeit, die Arbeit, Ich hab mir den Earnings Call angehört von Mark Zuckerberg und dachte auch, dass er vielleicht so ein bisschen versucht, tut mir leid und da müssten wir mal.
Nee, der macht einfach, stellt die Zahlen vor, sagt, da entwickeln wir uns groß, ich hab gleich noch so ein Clip dabei und sonst ist alles okay.
Er sieht sich da gar nicht in der Verantwortung irgendwie.
Überhaupt nicht. Und noch einmal David Rennie, der jetzt sagt, naja, es gibt aber schon so etwas wie eine Spaltung.
Die Sache, die wir hier sehen, ist, dass die chinesische Elite, ob das die Geschäftselite oder die Regierungsschule oder Techniker, sie sind eigentlich ziemlich geteilt durch Xi Jinpings Regel, weil er massiv die Kontrolle, die die Partei hat, über Universitäten, über die Regierungsschule, über private Unternehmen, über wirklich jedes Aspekt der Leben. Und es gibt viele Menschen in der chinesischen Elite, von privaten Entrepreneuren zu Universitätsprofessoren, oder sogar Menschen in der Regierung, die denken, dass das China schaden, dass es China aus dem Weltkrieg schlusst, dass es z.B. Und also für Xi Jinping, dass er keine Kursveränderung und wirklich keine Engagement mit den Anxiegen, die er bis heute durch seine sehr aggressiven Politiken generiert hat, das ist selbst ein Politikensignal. Die Unwahrheit der Veränderung, die sich so in die Hände dreht, ist die Reaktion von allen Stimmen der Unbequemkeit und der Begabte, die Menschen wie ich in Beijing jeden Tag hören.
Das ist ja eigentlich super interessant mal zu betonen. Denn das ist ja, was den deutschen Journalisten immer so fehlt. Was sie sich insgeheim wünschen, obwohl sie gar nicht genau wissen, wo ihre Fragestellung herkommt. Wenn sie irgendwie sehen, Olaf Scholz hat einen Brief geschrieben, jetzt hat er durchgegriffen. Zu was führten das so? Und dann sagte Habeck aber einfach, es ist halt passiert, jetzt arbeiten wir damit und es geht weiter. Und dann kommen die und sagen, naja, aber da hat doch jemand entschieden. Das ist doch jetzt nicht Gefahr gewesen, die ihn da drohte als Partei, sondern da ist doch jemand ins Risiko gegangen, nämlich der Olaf Scholz. Und dann sagte Habeck wieder, ja, was ist jetzt passiert jetzt? Es ist über unsere Partei hereingekommen. Wir müssen jetzt in den sauren Apfel weisen, machen wir auch. Das Atomkraftwerk läuft länger, irgendwann ist April. Dann machen wir eine Feierstunde, wobei wir es dann wirklich ausschalten und dann geht es halt weiter. Und dann kommt wieder diese Rückfrage, ja, aber sind sie jetzt nicht zerstritten und so? Was soll denn jetzt so? Was ist mit Linden und so? Und hier ist das für Xi eigentlich schon auch eine blöde Situation, dass er eben für alles verantwortlich ist. Genau, wann immer irgendwer eine Unzufriedenheit hat, weil mal wieder Befehl aus Peking kam, wie das jetzt in Shanghai oder so zu machen ist, wird sich Unzufriedenheit aufbauen. Die wird auch Organisationsformen finden. Und manchmal staut sich's auf. Und dann weiß vielleicht auch Xi nicht mehr genau, in vier Jahren, wie in fünf Jahren der nächste Parteitag ablaufen wird, weil zu viel unberechenbares Enttäuschungspotenzial so rumschwebte, als er so vier Jahre lang dachte, naja, der Parteitag ist so weit weg, ich kann jetzt erstmal walten und so weiter. Aber irgendwann sammelt sich's dann doch. Und in deren Sicht stellt er sich schon ganz schön ins Feuer. Und soziologisch ist es eigentlich super interessant, dass man wenn man Institutionen und Strukturen austauscht und Entscheidungen und Personen reintut, dann mindert man in erheblicher Weise die Leistungsfähigkeit von solchen Systemen. Weil du einfach nicht mehr dieses freie Kräftespiel, wo dann viele auch sagen, ja gut, das ist halt jetzt passiert, gehen wir trotzdem weiter, wir vertragen uns wieder und so. Sondern wenn du immer eine Quelle hast, die du verantwortlich machen kannst. Das ist ja auch, was die ganzen Querdenker in Deutschland immer suchen, die Verschwörung. Irgendwer muss doch entschieden haben, auf irgendeinen müssen wir doch wütend sein. Und dann ist immer wieder die Antwort, nee, das sind einfach die Umstände. Das ist halt für alle blöd, für euch auch. Aber es ist auch für die anderen blöd. Ihr könnt nicht immer den anderen unterstellen, dass sie eure Schicksalsgeber sind, denn die sind genauso ausgeliefert.
Aber sobald man jemanden hat, den man adressieren kann.
Genau, dann wird es kritisch. Und Xi stellt sich hier nun wirklich besonders ins Feuer, sichtbar. Es gibt ja keine Interviews und so, aber das nährt ja nur umso mehr die ganzen Kommunikationspotenziale. Ja, das wird auf ihm fixiert.
Also es gibt ja da auch so einen neuen Kult um ihn. Und wie sehr sie mit ihm verbunden sein müssen, müssen die Chinesen ja auch am Smartphone unter Beweis stellen, indem sie sich diese Xi-Reden täglich anhören.
Genau.
Das sind natürlich alles solche Maßnahmen, die kippen können. Also sicherlich strategisch klug ist es, so eine Ampelregierung zu haben. Und dann am besten so ein Christian Lindner hinter dem kann man sich auch verstecken. Also ich glaube auch, dass das ist ja so eine Sache, wo die Grünen auch selbst nicht so ran wollen, dann vielleicht dann immer so sagen können, naja, aber Christian Lindner. Und Christian Lindner wird wahrscheinlich auch im Zwiegespräch sagen, wir machen das jetzt so, aber wenn was ist, ihr könnt ruhig sagen, dass ich das bin, weil das wiederum mir Follower auf TikTok bringt. Also ich glaube, das ist sein, für seine Klientel geht das ja wunderbar. Also wenn die Grünen und der SPD wüten, dass sie irgendwas nicht machen können wegen Lindner, dann hat ja Lindner wiederum eine Bühne, wo er sich produzieren kann. Also eigentlich ist das eine super Arbeitsteilung.
Für ihn ist es super, weil er ja immer noch dieses Ziel hat, das konservative Erbe der CDU anzutreten. Und umso mehr ihm das vorgeworfen wird, genau das zu tun, umso besser ist natürlich für ihn, weil er dann beim nächsten Mal sagen kann, ihr müsst den März nicht wählen, ihr habt hier eine 30-jährige Jüngerin.
Und die anderen müssen vielleicht auch gar nicht so progressiv sein, weil sie immer sagen, wir spielen das alles über Lindner. Deswegen noch mal zurück zu Zuckerberg im Sinne von wenig Demokratie. Und einer entscheidet ganz allein, dass das Metaverse der richtige Weg ist oder das Zero-Covid der richtige Weg ist. Wir hören hier mal einen kurzen Beitrag aus CNBC mit klaren Forderungen.
Ich denke, das Nummer 1 ist, was du mit Facebook falsch findest. Das Problem mit diesem Stock ist, dass es ein Verwundesverlust ist. Du hast einen Jungen, der viel Geld verdient, für alles, was er bis jetzt erreicht hat. Aber er hat alle Voting, niemand von draußen kann ihn mechanisch beeinflussen. Du musst hoffen, dass dieser Drums-Beat, den er seit sechs Monaten gehört, etwas anderes machen kann. Und dann kannst du die Metaverse-Fantasien entdecken.
Hier wird richtig das Bild eines autorifären Führers gezeichnet. Sehr bemerkenswert, mit welcher Klarheit. Wir hören noch mal ganz kurz was aus dem BBC Podcast von Suchin Mao zu den nationalen Talenten, die Xi fördern will.
China sieht die domestikalen Talenten als eine sehr wichtige Komponente für diese Selbstverwaltung und Selbstverwaltung.
Ja, Domestic Talent. Das ist natürlich das Zauberwort für alle alten republikanisch geplagten Länder oder Organisationen. Es wirkt ja wirklich wie ein bisschen als wäre Facebook das ZDF, dass es einfach nicht mehr hinkriegt und sich am Ende alles zukaufen muss. Ja, und so ist es ja auch. Also WhatsApp und Instagram sind Zukäufe. Das ist nicht Facebooks eigene Schmiede gewesen. Und das lastet natürlich extrem auf diesem Nimbus, dass man hier so im Zentrum die Spinne im Netz ist, wo alles toll ist.
Und sie will jetzt die Leute behalten, gut ausbilden, kämpft um diese Talente. Wir hören jetzt nochmal den Doppelgänger Podcast, geht jetzt aber nicht um Facebook, sondern um Alpha.
Es geht nicht darum, das Business so profitabel wie möglich zu führen, weil dann würde man das nicht machen. Ich würde hier nochmal überprüfen, aber es sind 186.000 Leute, glaube ich, Sekunde. Ja, 187.000 Leute. Das sind 24, 5% mehr als letztes Jahr.
Alpha hat 24% mehr Mitarbeiter nun als im letzten Jahr. Und du hast gerade gesagt, das ist so dieser Kampf, dass.
Man sagt, wir versuchen, Businessmodelle nicht mehr so effizient wie möglich zu betreiben, sondern versuchen, auch Humann-Kapital zu binden, was ansonsten unser Geschäftsmodell eventuell angreifen könnte.
Mary Jane und Humann waren ja hier, wir haben ja darüber gesprochen, im Corporate Theory Podcast, was es für Unternehmen bedeutet, in einer alten Republik zu leben. Und ich habe dann gesagt, irgendwer muss in den sauren, also irgendwer wird der Erste sein, der in den sauren Apfel beißt. Und diese ganzen Talente abgrast, auch wenn jede einzelne Rekrutierung sechsstellig kostet. Allein um...
Das sind ja Top-Entwickler, von denen wir jetzt da reden würden. Einfach mal 20 Prozent mehr jetzt bezahlt werden müssen.
Die werden erst mal nur eingestellt, weil sie da sind. Da geht es gar nicht um konkrete Projekte oder so, sondern man sieht, wie sich der Markt entwickelt, nimmt sie erst mal. Man sieht ja jetzt auch die Kündigungswellen, die da so stattfinden. Da muss man sich aber genau anschauen, wer wird denn gekündigt bei Snap und Twitter und so weiter. Also bei Twitter ist es sogar noch besonders, denn Elon Musk ist ja hin, besitzt das ja seit gestern und hat dann gesagt, ich werde hier auf 75 Prozent der Leute verzichten. Und dann hat Scott Galloway das ganz wunderbar kommentiert mit, wenn du mit der Ansage kommst, du willst auf 75 Prozent der Mitarbeiter verzichten, wirst du als allererstes die 25 Prozent verlieren, die du brauchst. Weil die nämlich als erstes gehen, wenn das die Stimmungslage ist. Deswegen macht Google das immer noch anders, immer noch der beliebteste Arbeitgeber, allein weil man da so schön aufgenommen wird. Und ja, da kommt es dann auch erst mal nicht drauf an, gleich morgen ein Projekt abzuliefern und so weiter, sondern nee, da spielt man langfristig dieses, dass er ja nochmal sagt, ja die grasen dann auch einfach mal den Markt ab, damit die nicht in der Konkurrenz gegen Google arbeiten. Vielleicht ist es schon so weit. Vielleicht ist das echt schon eine der zentralen Sachen, dass man einfach ein echtes Budget dafür hat, keine Konkurrenz entstehen zu lassen. Wäre natürlich der Hammer irgendwie, wenn das wirklich da die Hintergründe sind.
Blicken wir mit Pip Klöckner nochmal auf Facebook.
Hiring 28% mehr Mitarbeiter. Eine andere Sache, die noch so ein bisschen für diese Monopolmargen spricht, was ja auch eigentlich relativ einzigartig ist, ist, die haben mal WhatsApp für 16 Milliarden gekauft und sie leben seit Jahren. Wann war das? Vor zehn Jahren vielleicht? 2014, vor acht Jahren. Sie sind vollkommen okay damit, nicht einfähig Geld zu verdienen.
Also auch das wieder ganz verrückt, 16 Milliarden von aus. Auch hier Hiring ohne Ende. Leute angestellt wie bei Alfa und trotzdem tut sich auch nichts auf irgendeiner Ebene.
Forschung und Entwicklung steigt um 45 von 6 auf 9 Milliarden, um 45 Prozent. Die Ausgaben für Forschung und Entwicklung, das entspricht inzwischen ein Drittel des Umsatzes, muss man auch mal sagen. Und General Admin steigt auch noch um 15 Prozent, während der Umsatz schrumpft.
Zuckerberg macht da einen eigenen Kapitalismus. Also das ist nicht mehr in irgendeiner, das könnte man mal hier dem AfD-Mann vorspielen, mit Angebot und Nachfrage und so ein ganzes, wie er das mal einordnen will. Das ist etwas ganz Eigenartiges, was hier stattfindet. Also wir haben nicht den Shareholder-Value-Kapitalismus, also zumindest nicht den, also man muss ja auch sagen, klar langfristig ein Unternehmen, aber das ist ja schon eine extreme Langfristigkeit. Also hier kann man ja wirklich dann schon von den Fünf-Jahres-Plänen einer KP sprechen, was hier gemacht wird. Und Zuckerberg hält an dieser Metaverse-Idee fest, wie Xi an der Zero-Covid-Strategie und an dieser neuen Idee der Binnenwirtschaft. Und das kann er machen, weil er das im Board, in seinem Politbüro so aufgeräumt hat, dass nur noch er eigentlich tonangebend ist. Und das ist so erstaunlich zu sehen, also wie wir, wenn wir über Autoritarismus reden, natürlich immer so den staatlichen Autoritarismus sehen, aber eigentlich den privatwirtschaftlichen nicht. Und wie eigentlich solche Parallelen doch ganz, ganz deutlich sind, auch was diese langfristigen Investments jetzt anbelangt. Und man gar nicht weiß, naja, es gab neben dem Shareholder Value immer den Stakeholder Value Kapitalismus. Also das ist ja was, was in Davos dann immer hochgehalten wird. Darum muss es doch eigentlich gehen. Nicht die kurzfristigen Gewinne, nicht Gordon-Gekko-Prinzip. Aber hier haben wir jetzt eine Abkehr vom Shareholder Value Kapitalismus in ein Stück weit zumindest und es entsteht aber jetzt nicht vielleicht das gewünschte daraus. Also es ist eine Alleinregentschaft jetzt von jemandem, der sehr früh zu sehr viel Macht und Geld gekommen ist.
Das wird erstmal wirklich wie beim ZDF, wo man dann nach Jahren feststellt, ach so, hier fließt nur noch 9% ins Programm. Alles andere ist Management, Leute warm halten und so riesigen Wasserbauch betreiben.
Ja, wie Klöckner ja sagt, die haben WhatsApp jahrelang und machen, also kriegen das nicht richtig profitabel. Es ist aber auch nicht dadurch noch irgendwas Innovatives entstanden. Jetzt macht man ein bisschen mit Influencer Marketing und In-Shop Modellen, dass man sofort da kaufen kann, aber viel mehr ist da ja auch nicht. Wir hören jetzt zum Abschluss dieses Sektors, dieses Kapitels noch Mark Zuckerberg selbst beim Earnings Call und er verkauft also ganz viele Dinge als super und kommt auf die Reels zu sprechen und jeder, der Instagram nutzt, weiß, wie furchtbar es geworden ist. Man sieht nicht mehr, was denen, die man eigentlich folgen tut, was die so machen, sondern ich bekomme zum Beispiel lauter Tiervideos gezeigt. Also ich gucke nie Tiervideos und jetzt plötzlich bekomme ich die laufend angezeigt. Was ist da schief wieder?
Also meiner Beobachtung nach spielen die diese Reels einfach kreuz und quer. Ist ja eine gigantische Masse. Und dann wissen sie, welchen 0, 01 Prozent der Reels bei 80 Prozent der Leute gut funktionieren. Und dann kriegen alle dasselbe.
Ja so scheint es zu sein. Das ist einfach nur so ein riesiger Aussiegelprozess. Mein Geschmack ist da ein bisschen spezieller offenbar. Und ich kann mich mit diesen Tieren nicht so anfreunden. Also naja, ist es grauenhaft, ganz kurz, so weil du Twitter angesprochen hast, müssen wir das ja kurz hier noch thematisieren. Elon Musk hat es gekauft. Ich habe heute morgen noch nachgeguckt. Du bist nach wie vor bei Twitter. Hast dich noch nicht verabschiedet in ein Alternativ Netzwerf?
Nein, nein, ich habe auch einen Masterdon Account seit ewig Zeiten, aber keine Ahnung, ob ich das mal benutzen werde.
Ich bleibe natürlich auch bei Twitter, denn ich will ja im Auge des Orkans sein. Ich möchte ja alles mitbekommen. Aber Elon Musk hat schon wieder was verrücktes gemacht. Er hat so einen Artikel gepostet, so eine Verschwörung. Wer dann da jetzt eigentlich diesen Einbruch verursacht hat und den Angriff auf Nancy Pelosi's Mann, irgendwie so Gerüchte um Callboy oder so was. Und das ist von einer Seite, die 2016 schon behauptet hat, dass Hillary Clinton verstorben sei und dass es sie nur noch als Doppelgängerin gibt. Ja, aber er hat das jetzt einfach schon mal gepostet mit seiner Durchweite.
Daraufhin hat ja die New York Times geschrieben, Elon Musk twittert Link zu Verschwörungsseite, woraufhin er einen Screenshot von dieser New York Times-Seite genommen hat und darüber auch wieder getwittert hat. Nein, das ist Fake News. Ich habe die New York Times nicht verlinkt. Also es ist echt so eine ganz dämliche Spielerei. Ich sehe es ja ein bisschen so. Scott Galloway hat uns ja darauf vorbereitet. Elon Musk hat einen ganz großen, gigantischen Fehler gemacht, indem er nämlich sagte, ich will Twitter kaufen. Und dann wollte er doch nicht mehr. Und dann stand aber fest, er wird müssen. Oder er wird für diesen Galloway-Akkord, das sich darum kümmert, einfach wirklich verdonnert zu 30 Milliarden Strafzahlungen und so weiter. Also hat er den sauren Apfel gebissen und hat es jetzt gekauft, für 45 Milliarden. Gleichzeitig wissen aber alle, es ist eigentlich nur 15 Milliarden wert. Und selbst die 15 Milliarden kriegt man nicht so besonders leicht finanziert. Für mich ist es also ein ganz großes Theater. Wie kommt Elon Musk aus dem größten Fehler, den er in seinem Leben bisher gemacht hat, wieder raus, der auch gleichzeitig einer der größten Investitionsfehlentscheidungen aller Zeiten ist? Also in diesem gigantischen Maße hat, glaube ich, noch niemand eine Fehlentscheidung getroffen.
Und wir gehen ja in eine Rezession erst rein. Das wird ja alles noch viel ungemütlicher. Der Werbemarkt bricht ja überall zusammen. Und der erste Versuch, YouTube verdient weniger Geld und sowas.
Genau, der erste Versuch, an dem ich heute Morgen las, ist, Twitter wird jetzt die Verifikation seiner Nutzer nicht mehr kostenlos anbieten, sondern das wird eine Gebühr kosten. Und da denke ich mir, geil, wenn das der erste Move ist, es zu refinanzieren, 45 Milliarden für so ein soziales Netzwerk, denke ich mir, gute Reise. Das werden interessante und bescheuerte Jahre und es wird Elon Musk auch ärmer machen. Da steht ja doch einiges auf dem Schirm.
Die ganzen Silicon Valley Konzerne versuchen jetzt eine Monetarisierung durch Preiserhebungen oder Preissteigerungen. Apple hat diese magische 10-Dollar-Schranke überschritten mit Apple TV. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie die Preise in Deutschland sind. Ich habe ja keine Apple TV, aber es ist so, dass die alle jetzt über diese magische Grenze hinausgehen. Ich glaube, dann ist auch 10, 99 Euro hier geplant. Spotify denkt ja auch über so etwas nach. Also wir sehen schon, wie man versucht, an dieser Preisschraube zu drehen. Amazon hat das vor zwei Monaten sehr stark gemacht. Aber ob man was kostenlos war plötzlich monetarisiert bekommt, also dass man sagt, die kriegen einen blauen Haken und zahlen dann. Wie viel soll der blaue Haken einem wert sein? Also ich habe ja bis heute keinen blauen Haken. Das muss man natürlich irgendwie beantragen oder so.
Also Elon Musk wird sich die Zähne daran ausbeißen. Er wird lieber seine Rocket Science weiter machen wollen, aber jetzt muss er, weil er kann ja sich diesmal nicht aus dem Management einfach zurückziehen wie überall sonst, sondern die Leute wollen jetzt wirklich 45 Milliarden gerechtfertigt haben. Also es wird jetzt seine Lebensaufgabe sein, zumindest für die nächsten zehn Jahre, das irgendwie zu rechtfertigen, auch sich selbst gegenüber. Nicht, dass nicht in den Geschichtsbüchern steht, du hast die Autos gebaut und dann Raketen und dann so einen krassen Twitter Fail. Wie geht denn das?
Man versteht es auch gar nicht so, also wenn man mal wirklich in dieser unternehmerischen Logik ist und sagt, man will irgendwas tolles schaffen, dann kann ich das ja sowohl mit E-Mobilität als auch mit Raketen, die uns auf den Maß bringen, nachvollziehen. Da muss man jetzt nicht nur ein kleiner Junge für sein, sondern das kann man generell, glaube ich, so sehen. Aber dass man sich an einem sozialen Netzwerk, dass man nicht erfunden hat, sondern dass es eigentlich schon ewig gibt, jetzt noch mal lang macht und gucken, ob man da irgendwie einen Werbemarkt findet, der noch nicht sich aufgetan hat und sowas. Das ist doch nicht besonders befriedigend.
Also der Twitter-Börsenwert ist ja, wo er schon immer war, oder dass es zwischendurch mal nach oben ging. Also sie haben es gar nicht irgendwo losgelegt. Sie hatten einfach nur viel Aufmerksamkeit. Sie publizistisch eine Macht, die man aber nicht steuern kann. Die User machen es selbst. Die Eingriffe über algorithmische Steuerung, das ist kein TikTok oder so. Leute wollen da inhaltlich getrieben Sachen machen. Die lassen sich da nicht einfach so treiben und sich so einen Algorithmus ausliefern. Also ich bin sehr gespannt und empfehle aber auch sehr, damit so einer gewissen Lockerheit ranzugehen. Wir werden sehen, dass Elon Musk eben nicht Iron Man ist, sondern einfach nur manchmal auch ein Idiot, der sich wirklich vertut. Er hat halt sehr viel Geld, um sich zu vertun. Aber es gibt auch sehr viele Leute, die haben einfach 10.000 Euro und verschwenden 2.000 völlig sinnlos. Manchmal 200 Milliarden und verschwenden dann 50 Milliarden davon. Weil die sind los und es scheint sie hier so zu sein. Diese ganzen Ängste vor, er wird die super App gründen, er möchte WeChat beerben, er hat ja schon die Autos, also wird er die ganze Flotte von Tesla irgendwie an Twitter anbinden und dann noch über PayPal-artige Verkaufs-Dinge, da irgendwelche App-Synergie-Effekte oder so.
Der macht da ein bisschen Kulturkampf oder so, aber letztlich ist er genau auch auf die Leute angewiesen, die nichts anderes machen, als den ganzen Tag vor Trump zu warnen. Also auch die braucht er als Interaktion bei Twitter, anders geht es nicht. Er kann auch da nicht jetzt alle Liberalen aus den USA als Follower verlieren, als als Subscriber. Nun wollen wir nochmal hier ganz kurz Mark Zuckerberg hören von den Earnings Call.
Our AI Discovery Engine is playing an increasingly important role across our products, especially as advances enable us to recommend more interesting content from across our networks and feeds. There are now more than 140 billion Reals plays across Facebook and Instagram each day. Reals is incremental to time spent on our apps. And we believe that we're gaining time spent share on competitors like TikTok.
Ja, die haben jetzt die Reals verdoppelt. Die Zeit, die damit verbracht wird, ist natürlich länger als einfach nur mit einem Post. Wie kann man das verdoppeln? Na ja, die haben das ja so penetrant jetzt überall. Man kommt ja auf dieser Seite nicht umhin, dass man ständig irgendein Real präsentiert bekommt. So haben sie das nach vorne gepusht. Und hier haben wir noch mal den Kreis, der sich schließt zu China. Also das ist alles, um mitzuhalten gegen TikTok, wenn gleich TikTok viel, viel massiver präsent ist bei jüngeren Leuten, aber ja auch in ältere Kohorten durchdringt. Also ich bin da sehr skeptisch, ob diese Real-Strategie aufgeht. Dass es da jetzt mehr Interaktion gibt, klar. Aber viele Leute sind, glaube ich, auch richtig genervt davon.
Ja, vor allem, ich meine ja klar, der Überraschungseffekt ist irgendwie vorbei. Wir können uns jetzt ernsthafte Fragen stellen. Welchen volkswirtschaftlichen, biografischen, sonstigen Nutzen hat es, viele Reals zu gucken? Das lässt sich nirgendwo niemandem rechtfertigen, weder den Eltern, den Lehrern gegenüber, noch irgendwelchen Shareholdern gegenüber, von den Anbietern dieser Reals. Also ist ja völlig Banane, irgendwelchen Menschen bei irgendwas zuzugucken. Die Ermüdungsgeschichten werden alle geschrieben werden. Netflix war ja super interessant, dass auf der einen Seite dieses Jahr Netflix kommt, macht dieses redaktionelle Angebot und bleibt aber immer dabei, während dann TikTok und so weiter die Leute so richtig süchtig machen nach diesen kleinen Sachen. Und ich glaube, man wird wieder zurückkommen zu diesem, man hat den Fails in der Brandung und dann geht man halt was gucken und Netflix bemüht sich darum, die sozialen Medien zu nutzen als Marketingplattform für irgendwas. Ich habe schon wieder gesehen, wie sie auch dann bei Instagram und so weiter so ganz viele Making-of kleine Werbefilmchen machen, die einen irgendwie so interessieren sollen für das Zeug, das sie haben. Und dann guckt man sich halt doch irgendwie am Ende das Original Zeug an.
Aber glaubst du auch, dass TikTok sich abschwächen wird, dieser Hype?
Naja, irgendwann wird ja alles mal gedeckelt.
Klar, aber ich meine, wir haben jetzt eine Rezession und nächstes Jahr wird es richtig hart werden. Und das bedeutet auch, dass weniger Werbebudget da ist. Was bedeutet, dass diese ganzen Social-Media-Plattformen extrem leiden werden? Das deutet sich ja jetzt schon an, beziehungsweise die Aktienkurse nehmen ja genau eine solche Entwicklung schon vorweg. Das heißt ja, dass jetzt gerade ein guter Zeitpunkt ist für Angriff. Das heißt, jetzt kann natürlich sehr schnell die eine oder andere neue Plattform entstehen, gerade weil Rezession ist. Also wenn die so mächtig sind und so viel Kapital haben, dass Facebook sofort sagen kann, was entsteht da, oh das kaufen wir mal lieber schnell. Da ist das natürlich nicht so, dass da unbedingt was reinkommen kann, was neu ist. Aber vielleicht hat genau diese Rezession jetzt für den Social Media Marken disruptiven Charakter, dass wir vielleicht in einem Jahr oder vielleicht anderthalb über irgendeine Social Media App sprechen, die plötzlich eine gewisse Dominanz hat, weil TikTok ja auch ein relativ neues Phänomen ist. Also das flächendeckende TikTok, diese Verbreitung, die begleiten wir erst seit es hier den Podcast gibt. Davor gab es auch schon TikTok, aber so dominant war es davor ja überhaupt nicht.
Ja, aber ist die Magie so insgesamt nicht irgendwie durch? Ich weiß noch wie, was weiß ich, so Mario Sixtus und so weiter, diese ganzen eingefleischten Early Adopter, wie man sie damals nannte, die dann irgendwie, ach, in New York ist ein Flugzeug abgestürzt, es konnte sich noch notwassern im Hudson River und erstaunlicherweise war nicht die New York Times zuerst am Ort, sondern jemand mit seinem Smartphone und dann hat er ein Twitterfoto gemacht und plötzlich hieß es, oh cool, die Nachrichten kriegen wir über Twitter und dann sehen wir auch das echte Flugzeug statt nur einen Bericht dazu zu lesen. Das war ja vor 15 Jahren alles noch anders.
Wenn man jetzt irgendwie sich den Markt anschaut, also angenommen, Gucken wir mal 2018, 2019, da kommt hier TikTok mal so bei den ganz jungen an. Unser eins war dann noch gar nicht auf der App. Also wir waren da mal, ich glaube 2019 waren wir bei so einem Talk zusammen und da haben wir kurz über TikTok gesprochen und da haben wir schon gemerkt, okay, es ist wichtiger, aber lange nicht so wichtig wie jetzt. Und man hätte ja nicht 2014 da gesessen und gesagt, obwohl es da schon Musical.ly gab. Also ich glaube, was ich so mal richtig durchsetzen könnte, wäre, dass 15 Sekunden Lip-Sync und Tanzvideos wäre. Und jetzt haben wir eine Plattform dafür und wir haben doch, also es gibt doch, es können ja Dinge noch miteinander verbunden werden, beziehungsweise irgendwelche Sachen auf so Plattformen stattfinden, von denen wir jetzt nichts wissen. Also wir, ich finde es schon interessant, dass wir auch so, also wir haben so einen Aufstieg von Oldie Fans in einem Spektrum, wo man dachte, naja gut, also mit Pornografie Geld zu verdienen, also komplett payable Content, dass man nicht mehr irgendwas auf der Plattform sehen kann. Und das soll sich rechnen? Offenbar schon.
Das ist ja wieder, da spielt ja nicht so eine Algon-Rolle, sondern Leute erregen Aufmerksamkeit über soziale Netzwerke, transferieren das auf Onlyfans und werden echte Nutznießer echter Geldzahlungen, die einfach im eins zu eins, private to private sozusagen stattfinden. So wie wir ja auch mit unserem Salon und so weiter. Wir brauchen ja keinen Megakonzern, Steady, sondern wir bleiben aber angezogen.
Nur für die, die noch nicht den Salon abonniert haben, wollen wir da schon mal alle Hoffnungen.
Wir brauchen ja nur einen Zahlungsabwickler für und das ist eine kleine technische Aufgabe, der wir uns nicht selber stellen wollen, weil wir wollen lieber Bücher lesen als doch verschreiben. Und deswegen lagern wir das als Dienstleistung aus, nehmen das in Anspruch, fertig ist die Laube. Aber wenn du jetzt so eine Hülle der Löwen hast und du gehst da irgendwie 2022 hin und sagst, ja, wir haben so eine ganz neue Idee für Social Media App, die Leute werden gefesselt sein, die werden es acht Stunden am Tag gucken. Und dann sitzt da irgendwie so jemand und fragt dann, ja, also, okay, ihr macht also dann irgendwie so TikTok-Konkurrenz, weil ihr besser seid, okay. TikTok ist ein Milliarden-Grab für Geld. Das Marketing, das die aufwenden, ist so immens. Und diese ganze ByteDance-Operation muss so nah an den Start angegliedert sein. Und das ist so viel Investition, die da drinsteckt, um irgendwelche Leute, ja, was denn eigentlich, kurz in der Aufmerksamkeit zu fesseln. Und wir wissen immer noch nicht genau, wie wir das eigene Geld da verdienen. Klar, ein paar Influencer werden da Geld rausziehen durch Product Placement oder was auch immer. Aber ByteDance crept doch genauso rum wie Facebook. Sie haben diese ganze Aufmerksamkeit der ganzen Welt. Und sie wissen überhaupt nicht, wie sie da mal in eine Plusrechnung kommen.
Das stimmt.
Und was willst du den Konkurrenz machen? Was hast du gewonnen, wenn du da erfolgreich sprichst?
Ich glaube, dass viel Investitionen kann es ja trotzdem interessant sein. Kurzfristig, also von Stefan Kühl gibt es ja diesen Begriff Exit-Kapitalismus. Also, dass man sagt, na ja, es ist ja keineswegs so, dass die Leute die Aktie von Facebook einfach nur gekauft haben. Und jetzt gucken die, wie die runter sackt und dann sagen die, oh, jetzt habe ich ja Geld verloren. Sondern hier gibt es ja enorme Sprünge. Also wenn die Aktie, und da waren ja schon vorher, waren ja schon Investoren. Also vor dem Börsengang waren Investoren da. Dann kommt 2012 die Aktie, die kostet 25 Euro. Wenn man die damals gezeichnet hat, dann kann man die theoretisch für das Zwölffache dann verkaufen im September 21. Wenn man die natürlich dann behalten würde, dann wäre es dann nur noch das Vierfache. Aber man hat ja Geld gemacht mit dieser Aktie. Und bei den Investments ist es ja nochmal anders. Also bei den Business Angel und Venture Capitalist, da ist es ja so, dass die jetzt zu einem ganz anderen Verhältnis da eingestiegen sind. Und da geht es ja dann darum, dass sich der Gewinn verhundertfacht. Und das muss ja nur eine gewisse Zeit gehen. Ich glaube auch, dass wir wahrscheinlich hier im Neuen Zwanziger Podcast auch das Absterben von großen Silicon Valley Konzernen erleben können. Wir können dann uns überlegen, welcher das ist, ob das dann wirklich Meta ist. Wir haben ja heute noch gar nicht gesagt, das heißt ja gar nicht Facebook, das heißt ja Meta. Das wird sich zeigen. Aber eine Zeit lang wird es wahrscheinlich funktionieren.
Ja, für mich ist das, wir sehen gerade jetzt noch die Pioniere, und bei dem Pionieren noch die Gründer selbst am Werk, gerade beim Meta mit Mark Zuckerberg. Aber das werden jetzt so nach und nach normale Unternehmen, die sich ohne noch irgend wem zu überraschen, einfach entwickeln müssen.
Genau, und da ist aber doch der Punkt, dass da noch mal was Neues passieren kann. Also da würde ich sagen, der Markt ist ja nicht geschlossen. Also das ist für mich, wäre jetzt so wie zu sagen, es gibt genug Podcasts oder so. Also Facebook würde jetzt ein junger Mensch einfach nicht mehr frequentieren. Also jemand, der 18 ist, ist niemals bei Facebook. Instagram wird schon kritisch, eher ist es dann TikTok. Und es ist ja durchaus möglich, dass wieder irgendeine App entsteht, ein soziales Netzwerk, das irgendeinen Vorteil mit sich bringt, irgendeinen Gebrauchswert hat, den die anderen nicht haben und der nicht so leicht kopiert werden kann, sodass da wieder irgendwas entsteht. Ich glaube auch, dass die Aufmerksamkeit, ich meine, die Leute sind fünf Stunden am Tag durchschnittlich mal an ihrem Smartphone zugange, das ist nicht mehr viel steierbar, sonst müsste man dann in den Schlaf ran oder so. Aber naja, dieser Kuchen wird wahrscheinlich auch noch mal jetzt im Laufe der Jahre neu verteilt. Und die Rezession könnte da zumindest eine disruptive Wirkung haben.
Kann durchaus sein, dass wir einfach nächstes Jahr um diese Zeit dann feststellen, nach Fortnite und Roblox gibt es dann halt ein nächstes Unternehmen, das für ein Jahr irgendwas macht.
Vielleicht hat dann eher Stefan es auf seinem Smartphone, als ich auf meinem Laptop.
Ich hänge immer noch dieser Theorie von Adam Curry an, der ja aus dem Fernsehzeitall kam als MTV-Typ und dann das Smartphone zahlt alle so ein bisschen mitbestimmt auch durch die Entwicklung von Podcasterei und so. All das, was wir hier besprechen, hat so viel Erfolg, weil wir Smartphones haben. Und das Smartphone ist aber eine Erfindung, wie das Fernsehen, das bleibt erst mal eine Weile. Da wird es keine fundamentale neue Entwicklung geben, weder in der Uhr, weder in der Brille, noch sonst irgendwo. Es wird das Smartphone sein. Wir haben jetzt die Pioniergeneration derjenigen, die die Software für Smartphone schreiben, einmal durch. Die ganzen Gründer haben ihre Magic abgefeuert. Wir bewundern sie bis heute. Und jetzt ist halt Tagesgeschäft angesagt. Also nochmal ein Kurs-Gewinn-Verhältnis von 150 irgendwie und so, dass man mit keinem Umsatz 500 Milliarden Unternehmenswert generiert, wie bei Facebook. Da wäre ich doch sehr überrascht, wenn sowas nochmal passiert. In der Ansicht. Ja, es ist so ein bisschen wie, als wir über Shenzhen sprachen, gab es ja andere Regionen, die auch kurz thematisiert wurden in dem Buch, die halt Küchengeräte herstellen und noch viel mehr Umsatz machen als Shenzhen. Und jetzt ist halt Shenzhen rückt so auch langsam in diese, ja, da wird halt sowas hergestellt, sind nicht mehr die Küchengeräte, sondern aber es ist so auch langsam Alltag und gewöhnt. Und man kann vielleicht nicht mehr als so viele damit unter dem Sofa herrocknen, locken und in deren Sicht. Was eine Sache in China müssen wir noch behandeln. Und zwar es gibt eine Überseepolizei, die hier kurz behandelt wurde in den Tagesthemen.
Dass Chinas langer Schatten sehr weit über seine eigenen Grenzen hinausreicht, das zeigt sich auf vielfältige Weise. Bekannt ist, dass Dissidenten sich auch im Ausland nie ganz in Sicherheit wiegen können. Aber hat Chinas Regime zur Verfolgung und Überwachung eigener Staatsbürger auch eigens illegale Polizeizentren auf fremden Staatsgebiet eingerichtet? Niederländische Behörden untersuchen einen solchen Verdacht derzeit in zwei Fällen in unserem Nachbarland. Aber könnte es solche Büros auch in anderen Ländern geben, etwa auch in Deutschland?
Tja, lasst uns alle mal raten, ob China im Ausland illegale Polizeifilialen unterhält, die dann so eine Art chinesische Hoheitsarbeit erledigen im Ausland. Ich würde mal sagen, der Verdacht liegt nahe. Sie werden sowas wohl tun und sie haben hier einen Zeugen gefunden.
Ich kann das nicht verstehen. Selbst wenn die Regierung denkt, dass ich etwas falsch gemacht habe, warum sperren sie dann meine Eltern ein?
Ich kann das nicht verstehen.
Die Verhaftung der Eltern solle Druck auf ihn ausüben, sagt er. Über Umwege landet er schließlich in Den Haag. Dort werde er seitdem von chinesischen Regierungsmitarbeitern bedrängt. Sie sagen, wir sind die chinesische Übersee-Polizei. Lösch deinen Twitter-Account und gib keine Interviews mehr. Und dann geht zurück nach China. Wo ihm Gefängnis drohe, sagt er.
So, es ist noch nicht so weit, dass die Chinesen hier einfach Menschen kapern. Aber sie machen das dann zu Hause, übersippenhaft. Sie nehmen also die Eltern mit und drohen an, solange du im Ausland deiner Freiheit waltest, ist deine Familie hier im Bedrängnis. Man fragt dann nach bei der chinesischen Regierungssprecherei, in dem Falle des Außenministeriums.
Die chinesische Regierung lässt diese Vorwürfe bei einer Pressekonferenz zurückweisen. Ich will betonen, dass sich die chinesischen Sicherheitsbehörden streng an internationale Gesetze halten und die Souveränität anderer Staaten respektieren. Doch allein für Europa listet Safeguard Defenders mehr als zwei Dutzend verdeckte Polizeistationen auf. In Deutschland soll sich eine in Frankfurt am Main befinden. Das Online-Portal T-Online berichtet außerdem über weitere inoffizielle Büros und Mitarbeiter in NRW, Hamburg und München.
Ja, also das glaube ich mal sofort. Es gibt sehr viele Berichte, dass sich Studenten hier nicht sicher fühlen. Also in Frankfurt ist eine Filiale, aber dass man sich deutschlandweit nicht sicher fühlt in Hörsälen, wenn man zuhört und am Ende noch mal eine Frage an den Professor stellt, weil man nie genau weiß, wer hört denn hier noch so zu. In deren Sicht sind viele Chinesen in Europa und studieren und machen alles mögliche. Aber so richtig aus den Fängen ihrer kommunistischen Regierungspartei kommen sie nicht.
Naja, ich will mal noch die historische Perspektive aufmachen, die Importe aus Europa, der Marxismus im Besonderen, das haben wir jetzt eben gehört. Und natürlich gibt es diese starke Connection, dass man quasi glaubt, Ideen zu importieren. Das ist etwas, was wir auch in anderen kommunistischen Staaten erlebt haben. Also in Kambodscha war es ja so, dass die Führungsriege um Pol Pot und Pol Pot selbst in Paris studiert haben. Und die kommen da zu den sozialistischen Theorien und importieren die dann. Also ist jetzt wiederum bei Ländern wie China die Angst da, die sind hier, kommen jetzt hier nicht nur mit Marx in Trier in Verbindung, weil das ist natürlich eine museale Marx-Rezeption, die man in Trier erleben kann, sondern auch mit irgendwelchen anderen Ideen und importieren die, ja, nehmen die wieder mit zurück bzw. verändern dann die Gesellschaft. Und das ist schon interessant, dass deshalb, glaube ich, dann auch gerade auf Studenten so ein Augenmerk gelebt wird, weil man gesehen hat, naja, das war ja eine sehr junge Entwicklung damals. Und das war ja aus dem Lesekreis heraus, sage ich mal, auch wenn man gerade bei Mao sagen muss, ist die Marktsektur erst viel später erfolgt, wenn überhaupt.
Genau, aus Angst vor diesem Kulturimport der westlichen Welt macht man einen Autokratie-Export in diese westliche Welt. Und die Zahlen sprechen jedenfalls schon mal für sich. Ich würde sagen, das ist nicht einfach nur geraten, sondern es gibt da schon echte Hinweise darauf, dass es in diesen Dimensionen sich abspielt.
Laut Schätzungen hat China mittlerweile über 230.000 Auslandschinesen unter Druck zurück ins Land geholt. Wenn auch Wang Jingyu zurückkehrt, würden seine Eltern freigelassen, wird ihm versprochen. Vorerst will er dennoch in Europa bleiben. Sicher fühlt er sich allerdings nicht.
230.000 Chinesen wurden so zurückgeholt. Und wir haben eben gehört, der Kampf um die Domestic Talents.
Das auch, richtig. Das auch. Es geht nicht nur um politische Desidententum, sondern auch, gründe doch dein Unternehmen hier bei uns. Komm doch nach Hause und so. Spielt alles eine ganz, ganz, ganz große Rolle. Bleiben wir mal bei diesen Domestic Talents Schule. Wir reden kurz über die Schule. Wir schauen uns dazu Tagesthemen und heute schon eine Alberichterstattung an. Man kam nicht drum herum. Karin Mioska moderiert mal zu dieser Bildungsstudie, die jetzt stattfand. Vier Klessler wurden getestet. Es ist nicht Pisa selbst. Das kennen wir noch von vor 20 Jahren. Im Anschluss ist es eine Art Lernstandserhebung, die den internationalen Vergleich aufmacht.
2011 haben wir davon zum ersten Mal gehört. Grundschulkinder beherrschen oft die Grundlagen nicht. Das Einmaleins genauso wenig wie die Rechtschreibung. Weil viele darüber so entsetzt waren, versprach die Politik, das muss sich dringend und schnell ändern. Doch die Jahre gingen ins Land und nichts verbesserte sich. Im Gegenteil, und dann kam auch noch Corona dazu. Grit von Petersdorf über eine Studie, die sämtliche Schwächen unseres Bildungssystems ausbuchstabiert.
Während ich das so sehe, dieses grüne Bild hinter Karamjowska, mit der ich melde mich hand, habe ich damals im Internet auch gefunden, ausgedruckt. Dann habe ich in Visitenkartengröße unserer großen Tochter so ein Kärtchen gemacht, wo sie immer einen Haken machte, wenn sie sich gemeldet hat. Weil die Lehrerin immer meinte, sie sitzt so als stilles Mäuschen hinten. Dann hat sie 10 Kästchen gehabt und sollte sich immer... Da habe ich auch schon gedacht, warum ist das eigentlich meine Aufgabe als Eltern, das Kind zu animieren mit solchen Tricksereien in der Schule? Kann ich die Lehrerin, dass einfach, wenn sie es sieht, selber so die Animationsarbeit erfüllen?
Die Lehrerin wird wahrscheinlich sagen, dass sie ganz viele Klassen hat und eine Klassenstärke von wie groß sind die Klassen? 30?
Na 20, 22 Grundschule. Ach so Grundschule, ja.
Aber höher weiterführend ist dann schon 30. Ja, es kann dann größer werden. Das ist ja in Luxemburg anders. Da bist du ja durchaus bei 20 auch auf dem Gymnasium.
Ja, genau. Also man könnte diesen internationalen Vergleich aufmachen.
Dann wird es aber wirklich bitter für uns.
Dann wär es super bitter, weil dann auch jeder Zuschauer sieht, ja ich weiß, wo die Probleme sind, zum Beispiel in Klassengröße. Macht man aber nicht, man doktort lieber so ein bisschen thematisch dran heroben.
Es wäre so einfach, den Leistungsabfall der Grundschülerinnen und Schüler mit der Pandemie zu erklären. Aber es stimmt nicht. Die Pandemie hat ihn nur verstärkt. Laut Bildungsstudie gehen die schulischen Leistungen seit Jahren kontinuierlich nach unten. 2011 erreichten noch 67, 9 Prozent der Viertklässler den Regelstandard in Mathematik. 2016 waren es noch 62, 2 Prozent und 2021 noch 54, 8 Prozent. Ähnlich das Bild bei der Lesekompetenz. 2011 schafften 66, 7 Prozent den Regelstandard. 2016 noch 65, 5 Prozent und 2021 noch 57, 6 Prozent.
Das sind unsere Ressourcen, die wir haben für unser schrumpfendes Arbeitnehmerpotenzial. Und Bettina Stark-Watzinger, FDP-Bildungsministerin, eigentlich gar nicht richtig zuständig für Schule, aber sie wurde natürlich gefragt, was ist denn hier los, sagt dann Folgendes.
Wir brauchen hier eine Trendwende. Wir können nicht zulassen, dass die Schülerinnen und Schüler nicht mehr über die notwendigen Grundkompetenzen verfügen, wenn sie die Grundschule verlassen. Diese sind die Grundlage für den weiteren Bildungsweg.
Wir können nicht zulassen, und was heißt das dann? Sie reduziert es auf den individuellen Bildungsweg. Dieses kollektive Schicksal, das dahintersteckt, das droht sie ja gar nicht, wenn wir so eine Niveauabsenkung um 10 Prozent in der Leistungsfähigkeit haben. Erstaunlicherweise braucht man gar keinen großen internationalen Vergleich, es reicht ein nationaler.
Auffallend sind die enormen Unterschiede zwischen den Bundesländern. Während Bayern und Sachsen weit über dem Leistungsdurchschnitt liegen, sind Berlin, Bremen, Brandenburg meistens deutlich drunter zu finden. Um es klarer zu machen, fast jedes zweite Kind in Berlin und Brandenburg erreicht bei der Rechtschreibung nicht mal den Mindeststandard.
Wir wissen, was Bayern macht. Die bezahlen einfach genug Lehrer. Sie bezahlen den Lehrern genug und sie bezahlen genug Lehrer. Ganze ostdeutsche Jahrgänge sind einfach nach Bayern abgewandert, um einfach dort Lehrer zu werden.
Aber Sachsen, was macht Sachsen gut?
Sachsen genauso. Du hast die Urbandzentren und man ist ja auch stolz auf diesen. Man hat ja echt was zu verteidigen in Sachsen. Also wenn du da kommst, ist das eben eine andere Diskussion, als wenn du da in Bremen anfängst, dann Budget regeln und so. Alles kompliziert. Also es gibt die Lehre. Die Politik muss nur genug erstens thematische Relevanz und Geld hinter das Thema stellen. Zack, funktioniert es auch.
Und das ist ja unglaublich, wie das geregelt ist, dass die Lehrer, die dann als Einspringer eingestellt werden, die dann nicht eine feste Stelle haben, dass man die dann für die Sommerferien wieder entlässt. Genau, weil sie Geld sparen. Genau, und die wissen das ja auch. Und dann überlegt man sich das natürlich zweimal, wie lange man das Ganze noch mitmacht. Mal ganz zu sprechen, zu schweigen von der universitären Lehre, wo ja Leute in Seminaren der Uni geben, ein ganzes Semester, und bekommen dafür einen Stundenlohn von 32 Euro, also pro Stunde, die sie geben. Damit ist aber dann keine Vorbereitung. Und die sollen aber dann noch 25 Hausarbeiten, A15 Seiten, bereiten. Also wenn man das mal durchrechnen würde, sind die dann bei einem Stundenlohn von 3, 50 Euro angekommen.
Genau, man hat dann hier Wortspenden eingesammelt, z.B. von der GEW in Brandenburg.
Wir haben nicht genug Lehrkräfte, die dafür ausgebildet sind. Und die Klassen sind viel zu voll. Das heißt also, wir haben eine Situation, dass die ganzen Reformansätze, die personell nicht untersetzt wurden, sind jetzt das Ergebniszeitigen, dass wir einen dramatischen Abbruch der Leistungen haben.
Also die Gewerkschaft für Erziehung und Wissenschaft sagt, uns sind die Hände gebunden. Also wir bräuchten halt von außen mehr Unterstützung. So auch ein Kommentar aus der Schulleitungsverbandebene.
Natürlich würden wir uns auch wünschen, damit Kinder besser gefördert werden können, muss es kleinere Klassen geben. Aber es ist im Moment eben einfach nicht unsetzbar. Das geht nicht, weil wir nicht genügend Räume, nicht genügend Personal haben.
Alle sagen dasselbe, es fehlt an Ressourcen. Wir haben zu wenig Räume und zu wenig Personal. Jetzt wieder stark Watzinger in den Tagesthemen.
Der Kompetenzverlust zeigt sich bei allen Schülerinnen und Schülern. Er zeigt sich aber nochmal besonders bei denjenigen, die einen Zuwanderungshintergrund haben oder aus sozial herausfordernden Situationen kommen.
So, sozial herausfordernde Situation als Slang für arme Familien. Das Herkunft, die so eine krasse Rolle spielt, so zur ökonomischen Herkunft, wissen wir doch seit ungefähr der antiken Geschichte. Wir kennen die Probleme mit zu wenig Lehrer, zu wenig Klassenräume usw. Es ist also ein eindeutig als politisches Problem klassifizierbares Ding, das wir hier zu handeln haben.
Ja, Armut größer im migrantischen Milieu, wo Armut ist, ist die Bildungschancen schlechter. Hat sich durch Corona, wir wissen das, verschärft, besonders dann, wenn Homeoffice angesagt war, Homeschooling angesagt war und Kinder nicht ein eigenes Kinderzimmer haben, wo sie das dann machen können alleine für sich, sondern dann zu dritt oder was irgendwo rumwurscht. Und die Eltern sind auch noch da. Das hat sich ja alles verstärkt.
Genau.
Das dauert dann noch. Wahrscheinlich im nächsten Jahr werden wir dann so um diese Zeit wirklich mal so diese ganz große Corona-Bildungsbilanz noch ziehen können. Das wird dann richtig finster.
Es ist jetzt schon gruselig. Ich nehme an, die Thematisierung wird zunehmen, weil das Problem so groß ist und so wenig aus dem Weg geräumt wird. Und wir werden demnächst einen Wechsel in der Kultusministerkonferenz Vorsitzenden schafft haben. Wir hören also hier noch mal im Amt Karin Prien, die uns CDU versucht, Dinge zu erklären, auch wo jetzt die Ansätze sind.
Wir müssen uns dagegen stemmen als Gesamtgesellschaft. Das fängt in der Kita an. Wir brauchen verbindliche Sprachstandserhebungen mit verbindlichen Sprachfördermaßnahmen.
Also die machen jetzt so ein Migrationsthema daraus oder was?
Nicht nur das.
Wo ich das gerade habe, also ist es ja eigentlich so, sofern man nicht arm ist, das müsste um das Ökonomische eigentlich gehen, dass wenn man eine weitere Sprache noch hat oder beziehungsweise die deutsche Sprache dann in der Schule lernt, dass das gerade eine besondere Kompetenz hervorbringt für Sprachen. Also ich hatte ja auch immer wieder natürlich in der Klasse Leute, die wurden im Elternhaus so gut wie nicht deutsch gesprochen wurden, aber die natürlich perfekt deutsch konnten und noch die andere Sprache, die italienisch oder so. Und das ist ja auch etwas, was die CDU-Abgeordnete von NRW, die Laschet so ein bisschen nach vorne gestellt hat, mit Migrationshintergrund, die auch schon bei Tilo zu Gast waren.
Die sich mit März ein bisschen überworfen haben.
Ja genau. Sie hat das ja gesagt. Sie sagt Gott sei Dank, haben meine Eltern kein Deutsch gesprochen. So konnte ich das wirklich richtig lernen, wie man spricht.
Genau. Also was Karin Brinja sagt, ist ja besonders perfide. Wir haben eine Lehrstandserhebung bei Viertklässlern gemacht. Vier Jahre Grundschule liegt hinter denen. Es sollte völlig egal sein, wie der Zulieferbetrieb Kindertagesstätte da funktioniert hat. Oder ob er überhaupt funktioniert hat.
Ja, also vier Jahre, also überlegt man, nach vier Jahren lernt man eine Sprache und ein bisschen Mathe dazu.
Und sie schiebt das einfach auf die, ja, wir kriegen halt schlechtes Material aus den Kitas. Nur, wir haben ja auch eine Nachrichtenlage zum Thema Kita.
Im kommenden Jahr könnten in Deutschland mehr als 380.000 Kita-Plätze fehlen. Zu dieser Prognose kommt die Bertelsmann Stiftung in ihrer aktuellen Studie. Dabei zeigt sich ein Gefälle zwischen den Bundesländern. In Ostdeutschland gibt es einen Bedarf von etwa 21.000 zusätzlichen Plätzen, im Westen von 362.000. Am größten ist der Mangel in Nordrhein-Westfalen. Um die Nachfrage bundesweit zu decken, müssten 99.000 Erzieherinnen und Erzieher eingestellt werden. 94.000 im Westen und 5.000 im Osten Deutschlands.
So, 100.000 Erzieher fehlen, weil man einfach nicht, und ich sage das häufig, aber selten habe ich es so gemeint, weil 1 plus 1 ist 2 in der Politik nicht ankommt. Man sieht doch, wie die Geburtenzahlen sind und sollte sich auch darüber freuen. Und dann übersieht man aber, dass man da eine Handlungssache, also dass man da entsprechend handeln muss, im Sinne von, ja, die bleiben wahrscheinlich nur so ein halbes oder ein Jahr zu Hause, danach braucht man so eine Kita-Bedrohung.
Ja, das kann man doch alles wirklich wunderbar berechnen. Also da ist ja nichts mit, wo hoffentlich kommt nicht noch eine weitere Virus-Variante. Also es tauchen ja nicht plötzlich 500.000 Kinder über Nachtmeer auf.
Es ist eins der größten Rätsel überhaupt. Kinder brauchen sechs Jahre, um eingeschult zu werden und um Lehrer auszubilden, brauchst du noch sechs Jahre. Dann ist dein fertiger Lehrer, da der Referendar halt ein Studium abgeschlossen. Aber trotzdem passt das irgendwie nicht in Deutschland. Das Matching findet nicht statt. Jetzt haben wir die Wortspende einer Mutter. Also wir haben schon die Schullehrer, der Schulleitungsverband, die Gewerkschaften. Alle sagen, das ist ein politisches Problem. Wer muss es ausbaden? Na klar, die Eltern.
Lernen für das Leben. Bei Eleonore stockt das bereits in der Grundschule. Schreiben top, Mathe schwierig. Sie bräuchte Förderung. Diese kann ihre Schule in Berlin aber nicht mehr anbieten. Lehrermangel. Nun wiederholt Eleonore die zweite Klasse. Und die Mutter hilft, wo es geht.
Wenn das der Staat nicht machen kann und nicht helfen möchte, muss ich als Mutter kürzer treten und dafür weniger leisten. Ich bin kein Pädagoge und kann es dem Kind nicht so erklären wie ein Lehrer.
Wir haben eine Mutter, die wir ganz dringend im Bewerbsversuch Potenzial brauchen. Und wir haben eine Tochter, die wir auch ganz dringend brauchen. Aber eins plus eins ist nicht zwei in Deutschland. Und jetzt wird es absolut brutal. Uns wird jetzt die Neue vorgestellt. Astrid, Sabine, Busse. Nächste KMK-Vorsitzende, zuvor allerdings noch hinleitend. Ein kleiner Bericht zum Lehrermangel. Der schließt dann ab mit einer Frage an Sie. Wir machen dann noch mal eine kurze Gedenkpause, bevor wir uns Ihre Antwort anhören, weil ich euch alle noch mal zur Aufmerksamkeit rufen möchte.
Bundesweit fehlen zehntausende von Lehrerinnen und Lehrern. Gleichzeitig steigen die Schülerzahlen weiter an, besonders in den großen Städten. Verfehlte Bildungspolitik? Die Prognosen der wachsenden Schülerzahlen sollte der Kultusministerkonferenz, kurz KMK, seit Jahren bekannt gewesen sein. 2023 wird Berlins Bildungssenatorin der KMK vorstehen. Warum nicht früher gehandelt wurde?
Warum nicht früher gehandelt wurde?
Jetzt sind wir gespannt.
Sie wird es 2023 übernehmen. Es ist, wie wir alle wissen, der Start in die Alten Republik. Ab dann wird es wirklich kritisch. Und zwar jedes Jahr, und es wird jedes Jahr schlimmer. Wir haben jetzt alle Fragen aufgeworfen. Kinder werden geboren. In der Kita kommen sie schon nicht vorwärts. Grundschule absolut desaströs. Und sie fallen am Ende mit 100.000 plus ohne Schulabschluss raus. Warum wurde nicht früher gehandelt? Wir hören jetzt die Antwort von Astrid Sabine Busse, Bildungssenatorin in Berlin, die demnächst das wichtigste Gremium zum Thema anführen wird.
Dieses Problem, das hat sich ja schon länger gezeigt. Da hätte man hingucken müssen. Ja, ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt auch nicht. Aber man denkt manchmal nur in Legislaturperioden möglicherweise. Und jetzt ist das Problem aber so ernst. Es ist ja ein Problem. Wie geht es mit unserem Land weiter? Und wie können wir unseren Wohlstand auch behalten?
Sie weiß es leider auch nicht.
Schade, aber mal gucken, was die Zeit so mit sich bringt.
Man kann mittlerweile so ein Witzebuch machen wie Alexander Lortz, auch mal hier in Hessen Kultusminister, KSK-Vorsitzender, KMK, wie er in der Bundespressekonferenz sagt und auf die Frage hin, was tun sie denn jetzt gegen die Vererbung des sozialen ökonomischen Herkunfts und so, sagt, wir haben alles versucht, vielleicht haben sie ja noch eine Idee, fragt er die Journalisten zurück. Ja, da hätte man echt mal früher hinschauen müssen. Ich weiß auch nicht, warum das nicht so ist.
Wir denken ja auch so in Legislaturperioden viel zu oft.
Ja, es ist wirklich, es ist einfach brutal. Schließen wir ab mit einer Lehrerin, die mal so einen ganz interessanten Hinweis macht. Wenn die Schule scheiße ist für alle, dann will auch keiner mehr Lehrer werden.
Die jungen Menschen, die jetzt in der Schule sind und mit all den Problematiken, die im täglichen Schulleben sind, konfrontiert werden, die müssen sich ja eigentlich für den Beruf entscheiden. Also stehen wir vor der Herausforderung, den Beruf auch wieder attraktiv zu machen. Das ist eine enorme Herausforderung, weil wir gleichzeitig in dem Beruf arbeiten und die Belastungen sehen. Und über die Belastung müssen wir ja sprechen, weil die auch dadurch entsteht, dass wir zu wenig Lehrer haben.
Ist ein bisschen wie in der Pflege. Du erinnerst dich, als die Pflegeprofessorin meinte, sie schickt uns bloß keine Freiwilligen in die Pflege. Wenn die erleben, was hier passiert, sagen die auch noch ihren Freundinnen Bescheid, arbeitet nicht hier. Also in deren Sicht, das ist wirklich eine unterirdische Problemlage, die wir ja haben in Deutschland. Man glaubt es nicht, aber es ist die Realität.
Ja, und damit sollten wir doch schließen. Erstmal mit dieser grauen Realität. Ich würde die wenigen Spotify-Clips auf den Teaser verschieben. Das bleibt aktuell und dann können wir noch ein bisschen Rätsel raten. Was ist dabei Spotify los? Die sind nämlich auch nicht so profitabel, wie man vielleicht denken könnte. Uns bleibt der Verweis auf den Salon. Wir sprechen über das Metaverse und wie es alles revolutionieren wird. Von Matthew Ball, ein Buch, das Zuckerberg und Reed Hastings schon gelesen haben. Also höchste Zeit Reed Hastings. Reed Hastings haben wir schon gelesen. Höchste Zeit, dass wir uns diesem Werk annehmen. Das werden wir wieder kontroverser diskutieren. Dann habe ich noch zwei Bücher, über die ich sprechen will. Und zwar einmal von Helvig Schmidt-Klinzer. Der Edle und der Ochse. Chinas Eliten und ihr moralischer Kompass. Dieses Buch schaut sich also an, wie wird jetzt nun China regiert. Und wie funktioniert eigentlich diese kommunistische Partei. Das wird sicherlich sehr spannend. Und die Soziologin Hannelore Bublez hat ein Buch publiziert mit dem Titel Die Verborgenen Codes der Erben über die soziale Magie und das Spiel der Eliten. Also wir haben ja schon über das Geld und die Häuser und all das gesprochen, dass wir Erbwirt. Aber wie ist es eigentlich mit diesem sozialen Kapital und welche feinen Unterschiede kennt diese Elite? Ich bin sehr gespannt darauf, was Bublez dazu berichten hat.
Brexit spielt eine Rolle, bei mir vielleicht Audiobooks. Dann vielleicht noch was zur Kunstaktion mit der Suppe. Was haben denn alle gegen die Suppe? Das ist eine Fragestellung. Die vergessene Not der Universitäten. Also einiges. Ich habe gesehen, Bono hat eine Autobiografie veröffentlicht.
Soll ganz schlimm sein. Aber du hast doch von Michel Friedman das Buch gelegt.
Und Friedman.
Ich habe dich jetzt bei mehreren Auftritten schwärmen hören und ich bin sehr gespannt, was du da zu machen kannst.
Friedman ist fest gebucht. Wir werden über dieses Buch reden und einiges interessante Anmerkungen machen. Ich bin mir ganz sicher, das wird euch interessieren.
Dann sehen wir uns im Salon und wünschen einen schönen Monat.